Tabea Kemme hat wirklich eine beeindruckende Karriere hinter sich. Olympia-Gold, Champions League Sieg, Meisterschaften in Serie. Einen Wettbewerb gab es, da lief es nicht ganz so gut. Aber darum soll es heute nur am Rande gehen. Wir wollen über ihre Karriere sprechen. Eigentlich war auch geplant, über die Karriere nach ihre Karriere zu sprechen. Das dritte Leben, wie sie es nennt, denn ihr kennt sie natürlich vor allem jetzt auch als Expertin an den Expert-Innen-Tischen dieser Nation bei Amazon Prime, bei Sky, bei Magenta Sport. Sie ist überall zu sehen und immer merkt man, die Frau hat wirklich was zu sagen. Und unter diesem Motto haben wir sie auch in den Rasenfunk eingeladen und es ist in rasenfunktypischer Art etwas eskaliert. Ich wollte mit ihr über ihre sportliche Karriere sprechen. Wir sind nicht bis zum Ende ihrer Karriere gekommen. Deswegen gibt es hier Teil 1 des Tribünengesprächs mit Tabea Kemme. Immer wieder biegen wir ab aus der Chronologie der Ereignisse in andere Themen, aber wir kommen immer wieder zurück. Ich hoffe, die Sendung macht euch so viel Freude, wie mir das Gespräch Freude bereitet hat. Jetzt lernt ihr Tabea Kemme noch besser kennen und los geht's.
Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Das ist bei allen Spielern hingeblieben. Es gab eine Kategorie geht, geht nicht, geht gar nicht. Und dann kannst du die Verletzungshistorien der jeweiligen Spielern unter Bernd Schröder sehen, bis hin jetzt in Validitätsrente. Ich krieg 20 Prozent Invaliditätsrente. Das ist wie so ein kemsches Ding, das muss krass gewesen sein, das erste Länder-Spiel geschossen.
Ich kann mich wirklich dran erinnern. Welche Bedeutung hatte das erste Tor für dich? Okay, gut. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Tabea Kemme, ich freu mich sehr, dass du im Rasenfunk bist. Hi.
Hi, moin. Moin, sagt man ja hier.
Ja, moin, sagt man hier. Wir sind hier im St. Pauli Museum. Sehr schöne Kulisse. Es heilt ein bisschen. Bin gespannt, wie ich das rauskriege aus der Audioaufnahme. Aber ich glaube, es wird klappen. Schöne Kulisse, oder?
Ja, ich mag das schon. Ich bin gerade auch mit den Öffis hergekommen, wenn man dann hier ums Stadion spaziert, mit dem Flintereingang, alles sehr sensibel. Das merkt man so. Ich fühle, dass irgendwie alle hier willkommen sind. Das ist schon schön.
Und wie ist das für dich, in der Stadt zu sein? Also kommst du ursprünglich vom Land? Ich hatte das neulich. Ich war ungeplant bei mir in der Heimat. Ich komme auch vom Dorf. Ich bin da so hingejuckelt und so weiter. Den Weg kennt man irgendwann auswendig. Dann bin ich aus dem Auto ausgestiegen. Und mit dem ersten Einatmen wusste ich wieder, wo ich bin. Weil ich so genau den Geruch noch in der Nase hatte. Ist das bei dir auch so?
Das ist bei mir identisch. Ich finde das sogar noch krasser, weil ich vor zwei Jahren wieder aufs Land zurück bin, weil ich mit meiner Schwester in den Hof übernommen habe. Und wenn ich jetzt mit den Schafen über die Weide spaziere, kommen wirklich Bilder aus der Kindheit wieder hervor. Das ist so krass, was dieses Gehirn kann. Und auch damit sogar ein Gefühl. Also die Festplatte im Hirn gibt mir ein physisches Gefühl auch noch mit. Das ist brutal.
Und aber dann hoffentlich gute Gefühle?
Ja, voll. Also dieses kindliche, freie. Ich verbinde eigentlich die Kindheit nur mit Freiheit. Das ist immer mal wieder ein Reminder für mich. Okay, warte mal, wo kommt es eigentlich jetzt noch mal genau drauf an?
Aber kannst du dann Stadt und magst du Stadt?
Ja, ich liebe alles. Ich liebe also ich habe das für mich jetzt, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren habe ich es rausgekriegt für mich. Okay, ich kann Land leben, nur wenn ich die Stadt habe und ich kann Stadt leben, nur wenn ich das Land habe, das Landleben. Also ich brauche diese, könnte auch sehr ambivalent sein. Ja, die Stadt ist es mir, ich liebe diese 24-7 Zugänglichkeit, Verfügbarkeit und dann habe ich irgendwann aber auch schnell die Schnauze voll, weil es so schnell alles ist und ich meine, ich lebe auf dem Land, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, aber also wir haben noch nicht mal eine Glasfaser. Das heißt, selbst wenn wir da eine Podcastaufnahme haben, ey, uiuiui, da sind Anja und Josie schon dolle.
Ja, also jetzt wohne ich ja in der Stadt, aber ich konnte auch ganz lange, also für mich war immer klar, ich muss auch weg vom Land, weil mir war es, du kennst es ja, es hat ganz viele gute Seiten, alle kennen sich, das Schlechte ist, alle kennen sich und alle beobachten sich. Deswegen für mich war völlig klar, ich muss da weg und dann bin ich unter anderem, bin ich nach Freiburg gezogen und ich weiß aber noch ganz genau, dass ich die ersten Monate in Freiburg hatte, ich so eine Unruhe in mir und das war, obwohl Freiburg ja auch ein Dorf ist, ehrlich gesagt, das ist ja auch keine große Stadt und irgendwann ist mir aber aufgefallen, woran das liegt, als ich wieder zu Hause war, weil ich habe von meiner Wohnung aus die Sonne nicht mehr gesehen und ich hatte früher, hatte ich sogar, als mein ältester Bruder ausgezogen war, hatte ich das beste Zimmer, meiner Meinung nach, da konnte man nämlich den Sonnenaufgang sehen und den Sonnenuntergang. Und irgendwann, als ich wieder zu Hause war, habe ich mich da minutenlang reingeguckt und da dachte ich mir so, ach krass, das fehlt hier, glaube ich, die ganze Zeit in Freiburg.
Das sind diese Naturereignisse, die fehlen. Also das Leben mit der Natur, das fällt mir halt immer wieder auf, was ich zu Hause genieße und tatsächlich auch mit Sonnenaufgang und Sonnenuntergang. Ich versuche dann wirklich auch meinen Rhythmus anzupassen.
Ach verrückt. Wusstest du, dass früher die Leute im Mittelalter, nach allem, was man heute weiß, die sind ja logischerweise mit der Sonne aufgestanden, mit der Sonne ins Bett gegangen und zwischendurch sind sie aber noch mal wach geworden und haben so zwei Stunden, zwei, drei Stunden gearbeitet. Das hatte so einen besonderen Namen auch, weil das offensichtlich wohl der eigentliche Biorhythmus des Menschen sein soll. Zumindest damals war es so.
Sollte ich mal versuchen.
Ich fand es interessant, weil wir haben gerade schon im Vorgespräch ja kurz über Schlaf und so weiter gesprochen und Schlafcoaching und Schlafwissenschaft und wie wichtig das ja gerade für SportlerInnen ist. Und dann hör ich aber irgendeinen Geschichtspodcast, das war Geschichten aus der Geschichte und da kommt das drin vor und ich denke so, ach, das ist ja verrückt. Das habe ich ja noch nie gehört.
Tatsächlich gucke ich aber gerade auch viel in die Vergangenheit, was das Thema Ernährung angeht, also Jäger und Sammler, was da eigentlich abging und wie wir durch die Industrialisierung quasi eigentlich so ein bisschen dieses Gespür für die eigentliche Notwendigkeit verloren haben. Auch super spannend.
Das war doch Harari. Hast du das zufällig gelesen, wie der Weizen den Menschen domestiziert hat und nicht umgedreht? Weil vorher sind quasi die Menschen eben, ja, herdenartig eben als Jäger und Sammler durchgezogen und haben sich durch die Welt gezogen und haben sich dementsprechend auch ernährt. Und als man dann den Weizen für sich entdeckt hat, dann musste der Mensch sesshaft werden, um dieses Korn zu produzieren. Er musste sich um diese Pflanze kümmern. Gleichzeitig hat sich dadurch auch ganz viel physiognomisch verändert. Also die Menschen haben mehr Kinder bekommen. Sie mussten dann noch mehr Korn anbauen, um die zu ernähren. Gleichzeitig haben sie sich aber anders ernährt. Und deswegen, das hat Harari in, ich weiß jetzt nicht, in welchen seiner Bücher beschrieben.
Boah, das nehme ich mit, das Buch. Geil, danke für die Empfehlung. Ich habe tatsächlich jetzt gerade in dem Bauernhaus, habe ich das eigentliche Arbeitszimmer in ein Bibliothekszimmer umgewandelt. Das haben wir renoviert zusammen zu Hause. Und weil ich möchte in einer Bibliothek, ich brauche mal wieder dieses Analoge bei der vielen Digitalisierung und generell, wie viel man ja auch immer im Netz rumhängt, einfach mal diese Analogie wieder zu haben, das Analoge, das Buch blättern zu können, riechen zu können. Und dann stapeln sich jetzt die ganzen Bücher in diesem Regal. Es hat auch was.
Ja, das ist, finde ich, so ein ewiger Kampf, wenn man Sachbücher gerne liest. Und das ist bei dir auch der Fall. Es wäre eigentlich sinnvoller, sie digital zu lesen, weil du dann deine alten Notizen und markierte Zitate und so weiter ganz schnell zugänglich hättest. Aber es ist halt so viel weniger geil.
Ja, ja. Und ich finde auch, also das Thema Zeit, weil ich auch oft immer die Dinge sehr schnell haben möchte. Und also mein Geduldsfaden ist so semi-lang. Und dann liebe ich es, weil das immer wieder eine Erinnerung dran ist. So nee, ich nehme jetzt wirklich mal Zeit, setze mich hin, machen mir Gedanken, bereite das vor, bereite das nach. Und ich bin so zufrieden danach. Das ist so ein geiles Gefühl.
Ja, so wird es sich hoffentlich für mich anfühlen, wenn die Session hier vorbei ist. Das war nämlich meine letzte Vorbereitung. Wir wollen heute ein bisschen über deine Karriere sprechen, über das Sportliche, was du erlebt hast. Aber da geht es eben logischerweise dann auf dem Land los, bis am 14. Dezember 1991 auf die Welt gekommen. Und du hast neben dem Tollen, was das Land dir geboten hat zum Aufwachsen, hast du bis im Alter von zehn Jahren noch nicht in einem Fußballverein gespielt. Also Reiten war ein Thema, Schwimmen nur einmal, habe ich gehört.
Ja, einmal beim Triathlon habe ich als Letztes aus dem Wasser. Das fand ich nicht so geil.
Und wir werden später noch drüber sprechen, dass du eine sehr vielseitige Spielerin warst. Vielleicht ist dir das manchmal sogar zum Verhängnis geworden, dass man dich überall hinschieben konnte. Glaubst du, dass das daher kommt, dass du so spät dich erst auf den Fußball fokussiert hast?
Nee, meine Eltern haben das tatsächlich unterbunden, dass ich zu früh zu einem Fußballverein gehe, weil ich zu früh hätte spezialisiert. Also man hätte mich zu früh spezialisiert für eine Sportart, weil dann ist es ja wirklich, wenn man im Jugendalter guckt, so dieses Ball und Gib eben. Und ich habe also alle, ich habe noch zwei ältere Schwestern, wir sind alle durch das Kinderturnen. Meine Mutter war Kindertrainerin. Ja, Spiele und Spaß war das. Das ist wie Sporthalle, alle Geräte aufstellen und dann sind da 15, 20 Kinder, die durchdrehen. So, da war ich halt vorne mit an. Und dementsprechend auch so Bundesjugendspieler und all sowas, was ich gemacht habe. Also diese Vielfältigkeit, diese wirklich breitathletische Ausbildung hatte ich halt sehr, sehr früh. Und dann wurde ich aber irgendwann auch ein bisschen konsequenter mit meinen Eltern, weil ich echt gesagt habe, so ich hab jetzt echt schon noch Bock auf Fußball, so lasst mich jetzt mal. Dann hat mein Onkel auch noch ein bisschen Druck ausgeübt auf meine Eltern. Und dann bin ich in einem Mädchenverein tatsächlich. Einmal in der Woche Training und am Wochenende Spiel oder Turniere.
Und also der Mädchenverein, die SG Freiburg-Öderquart.
Also im Norden, das Freiburg, genau.
Sensationelle Homepage, muss ich sagen.
Die kenne ich nicht mal. Aber witzig.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, so wie man sich es vorstellt. Eine Spielgemeinschaft seit 1974. Das habe ich nämlich extra noch. Wollte ich noch nachlesen. Dann hatten sie es netterweise direkt auf die Homepage geschrieben. Weil heutzutage ist es ja so, dass es ganz viele Spielgemeinschaften gibt, weil eben das Vereine starben eingesetzt hat auf dem Land. Aber damals ja offenbar noch nicht. Und damals auch schon mit einem Mädchenteam.
Ja, voll, voll. Wirklich. Also wir hatten die C, die B Mädchen. Ich bin relativ schnell zu den B Mädchen. Und da waren wir auch immer. Also ausgelastet. Wir konnten da immer voll aus dem Kader zählen. Und dann mit Inge, die Trainerin, die parallel auch irgendwie alles im Verein gemanagt hat, so der Klassiker.
Okay, jeder Verein hat eine Inge.
Die ist wirklich. Und die ist jetzt 20 Jahre später auch, oder über 20 Jahre auch immer noch im Staat. Die rockt das da, ja.
Ja, das ist ja quasi die Schulden des Giganten, auf denen alle LeistungssportlerInnen eigentlich stehen. Weil alle kommen daher. Und ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, du hast jetzt einen Verein gefunden, aber du kennst ja auch die Probleme, die es aktuell gibt. Was braucht es denn deiner Meinung nach, um eben auf dem Land für beides zu sorgen? Das eine, erstmal einfach nur Spaß am Sport. Und das zweite aber, für diejenigen, die Talent und den Willen dazu haben, die sollen ja auch gerne an die Leistungspyramidenspitze hochbefördert werden.
Wissen. Das Wissen, wie kann der Weg aussehen noch ganz oben hin. Und das, was du eigentlich gerade schon angesprochen hast, ist für mich eigentlich so sinnbildlich, dieses so lange wie möglich in einem Kosmos der Lebensfreude zu bleiben. Dieser Street-Style-Soccer. Einfach selbst auch. Es muss ja nicht gleich Siebener Feld sein. Elver ist ja immer noch eine ganz andere Nummer. Sonst ist es irgendwie mal so ein Drei gegen Drei. Einfach so dieses Zocken, in dieses freie Spielen reinzukommen. Weil was passiert ist ja, ich meine, das war ja auch ein Grund, warum meine Eltern gesagt haben, so nee, Fußballverein so früh keine Chance. Weil dann kommst du sehr schnell in dieses Szenario rein. Okay, lauf von Hütchen blau nach Hütchen rot und dann noch zu gelb. So und dann noch mit einem Trainer oder einer Trainerin. So dieses, dann kommt ganz schnell dieses, ja Performance muss sein, weil dann spielst du. Und dann hast du sehr schnell diese Machtkonstellation. Ist nicht geil. Also das so lange wie möglich zu fördern, einfach nur diese Freude daran zu haben. Und dann auch so parallel immer so ein bisschen einzubauen, weil Fußball ist halt mehr als Fußball im Sinne von diese Freude daran, das eine, und dann aber auch so ein bisschen die athletischen Perspektiven mit einzubringen. Das heißt, so ein Gefühl für deinen Körper zu bekommen. Was heißt das eigentlich? Beuger-Strecker-Verhältnis, Thema Kreuzbandrisse. Wir haben halt einfach ein Beuger-Defizit. Also dieses Wissen, diese Aufklärung so ein bisschen mit einzubeziehen, weil es ist halt nicht einfach nur gib ihm mit Ball.
Das ist ja der für mich total unterschätzte Vorteil von Foninho, gegen das ja, also bei mir auf dem Dorf wurden da Petitionen gegen gestartet, ein Trainer zurückgetreten, weil er gesagt hat, wenn ihr mich die ganze Zeit anmotzt, weil ich jetzt Foninho spielen lassen möchte, dann will ich nicht mehr Trainer sein. Jetzt spielen sie wieder das alte Spiel und draußen stehen die übermotivierten Eltern und brüllen alles Mögliche rein. Und das ist aber der Vorteil von Foninho, dadurch, dass da mehrere Spiele gleichzeitig stattfinden, niemand außer den Kindern, die spielen, wissen, wie es gerade steht und man es nicht so im Blick behalten kann, glaube ich, dass da auch so, also zumindest hoffe ich das, ich habe es noch nicht erlebt, dass die überambitionierten Eltern da ein bisschen schwerer haben, einfach rein zu grätschen verbal ins Spiel.
Also das ist auch im Falle dessen, dass ich mal Trainerin werden sollte, was sehr weit weg ist.
Ist es jetzt doch eine Option?
Nein, noch gar nicht.
Ich dachte so.
Weil das ist zum Beispiel genau so eine Sache. Also wenn ich dann eine Gruppe trainieren würde, würde ich einfach die Eltern verbannen müssen und wirklich nur für die Kinder diesen Raum schaffen. Nichts anderes mache ich gerade, wenn ich manchmal Workshops in Schulen mache. Und da fällt mir das schon schwer, wenn die Lehrer und Lehrerinnen irgendwie Einfluss nehmen wollen. Und das ist so, ich merke gerade so dieses, okay, ich lerne da auch nochmal neue Grenzen zu setzen, weil ich möchte diesen geschützten Raum für die Kinder haben, wo sie frei aufspielen können. Ohne dass irgendjemand immer dazwischen hier noch so, ja, oft ist es ja so, ich hatte ein Szenario, oder hatte ein Junge halt seine Schuhe vergessen. Und die Lehrerin hatte halt vorher angekündigt, wenn jemand halt seinen Stuff nicht dabei hat, dann wird er nicht mehr dran teilnehmen. Mir ist es voll egal. Also dann spielt er halt einfach barfuß, der wird danach drei Blasen haben und dann weiß er um diese Konsequenz, er wird nie wieder die Schuhe vergessen. Ich war nämlich selber diejenige, die die Schuhe vergessen hat und die drei Blasen. Weißt du so? Genau, aber dieses Learning lassen wir ja gar nicht mehr zu.
Ja, ich meine, ich will jetzt auch nicht über irgendwelche Regeln von anderen Menschen urteilen, weil wer weiß, also ich war mal in einem jungen Internat zwei Jahre lang und logischerweise gab es da manche sehr strikte Regeln, das hast du ja später auch mitbekommen.
Ja, so Prinzipien halt einfach.
Und ehrlicherweise glaube ich, manche davon braucht es auch, weil ansonsten...
Es braucht eine Orientierung. Ey, safe, bin ich voll bei dir. Ich finde das so, was ich ein schönes, das habe ich von Josie Henning gelernt, weil sie im Jugendknast Workshops gegeben hat, sowohl mit ihrer Kunstperspektive, aber natürlich auch mit ihrer Fußballerinnenperspektive. Und das war so schön, weil es war eine Runde von... Wir waren zu 20. und auch noch welche aus dem NLZ, Köln war das, und dann hattest du halt die Insassen und Insassinnen. Und wir haben zusammen, haben wir die Prinzipien herausgearbeitet. Das war vorneweg, war das, lass es zehn Minuten gewesen sein, haben wir die Regeln selber aufgestellt, und damit war das Ding durch. Und wenn irgendwie jemand, das ging dann auch so, eine Regel war, dem anderen zuzuhören, wenn er redet. So, und dann war mal der Fall wieder, dass es nicht funktioniert hat. Und dann hat man einfach nur mal kurz die Regeln aufgelistet, aufgezeigt und dann war wieder okay. Und das finde ich so geil, weil zusammen in der Gruppe zu definieren, was für Regeln wollen wir hier für uns schaffen. Und das gemeinsam zu machen, weil wer bin ich, dir sagen zu müssen, was jetzt hier meine Regeln sind. Dieses, damit hast du direkt wieder so eine Hierarchie. Und das, da bin ich halt echt nicht geschädigt. Ich bin halt aufgewachsen, so auch in diesem Sportsystem. Ich war irgendwie so dieses letzte Glied irgendwie in dem System. Und eigentlich, worum geht es doch? Das geht um die Spieler und die Spielerinnen auf dem Platz.
Ich glaube, wir reden gerade schon indirekt über deine Sportschulenzeit. Ich will aber vorher noch wissen, gibt es denn eigentlich Erinnerungen für dich vorher? Also was war denn für dich Fußball, bevor du ins System reingekommen bist?
Freies Aufspielen. Das war in jeder Pause, selbst wenn sie nur fünf Minuten war, so abzisch auf dem Fußballplatz, beziehungsweise manchmal hatten wir gar keinen Fußballplatz, wir hatten nur so ein Rondell und dann hatten wir so einen Supermarkt, Plastik bei, wo nur noch die Hälfte der Luft drauf war. Und hatten uns so ein eigenes Spiel kreiert. Und ich hatte auch immer, also jetzt gerade auch als junges Mädchen, immer den Zugang, da wurde halt nicht differenziert, dass es mir echt noch mal so hängen geblieben, dass ich halt unabhängig von dem Geschlecht einfach auf der Ebene aller war.
Ja, das ist auch oft ein Vorteil vom Dorf. Da gibt es nicht so viele, die mitspielen können, da ist es dann egal, wer mitspielt.
Wirklich. Und dann einmal war es aber, eine Erfahrung, die ich auch gemacht habe, war, ich stand dann einmal zur Debatte, ich war ja bei den Mädchen, dass ich den einmal bei den Jungs mitzocke. In einem anderen Dorf war ein Jungsverein, da bin ich für ein Training mit und Papa hat mich gefahren. Und da war es nämlich beispielsweise so, dass man mich noch nicht kannte. Ich habe da mittrainiert, wir haben dann, ich glaube, das war so ein 6 gegen 6 gespielt. Und mir hat man nicht wirklich den Ball zugespielt.
Und man merkt das ja so fort.
Direkt. Und ich meine, dieses so ein richtiges Störgefühl. Und dann auch der Trainer, der da auch großen Einfluss hatte. Und danach hat mein Papa dann auch noch gesagt, Tabea, wie fandest du es? Ich fand es richtig scheiße. Möchtest du noch mal hier hinfahren? Nein. Und dann bin ich da nie mehr hingefahren. So, das war mein, okay, hier passiert gerade, da hat jemand Einfluss. So, das sind ja, das sind ja nicht die elfjährigen Jungs, sondern das ist die Erziehung dieser elfjährigen Jungs von Seiten des Trainers und auch natürlich die Eltern, die da eine Rolle mitspielen. Und so, da habe ich gesagt, so, nee.
Aber hast du noch irgendwelche Positiverinnerungen? Also ich kann dir immer noch, das werde ich jetzt nicht machen, keine Angst, aber ich kann dir immer noch vom eins zu sechzehn erzählen, dass ich gegen Emskirchen geschossen habe.
Ah, witzig. Nee, ich habe mich Tore, also solche, ähm, anhand von Resultaten oder Vorlagen oder Toren kann ich mich an nichts wirklich erinnern. Das war auch nicht, wenn auch teils später als Kapitänin bei Turbine Potsdamen es dann irgendwie so 3-1 oder 4-1 Abpfiff-Interview. Ich immer noch irgendwie, das war Johanna Elsig, mir ist so Jojo, wie war jetzt nochmal? War 3-1 oder 4-1? Weil ich war nie so dieses Resultat fokussiert, denn natürlich absolut, ich habe diese absolute Winning-Mentalität, aber das war irgendwie einfach von diesem Gefühl. Ich wollte dieses Gefühl so und ich wusste, wie ich in dieses Gefühl komme, das heißt Ballaktionen und dann auch bestimmte Ballaktionen. Und dann kommst du irgendwann in so einen Flow, dass ich sage mal, dass dieser Zauber, wo es einfach läuft. So und dieses Gefühl, das habe ich, kann ich mir auch visualisieren anhand Spielsituationen, was ich viel in meiner Reha-Zeit auch gemacht habe, um immer wieder in dieses Gefühl reinzukommen. Und das ist für mich dieser Zauber, das ist nicht dieses einzige Resultat.
Und sind das dann offensive Spielsituationen oder?
Ja, oder die, die ich sag mal Anja Mittag Gedächtnisgeräte, die finde ich schon mit dabei, oder? Ja, natürlich. Das ist ja, wenn es so ein bisschen leicht genieselt hat.
Ja, geil.
Und dann so die erste Rasenkante, die du noch, die rutscht noch ein bisschen mit hoch und dann, ja.
Ich hab's auch geliebt. Ich weiß noch, ich hab mich nie näher am Fußballprofi geführt, als wenn wir bei leichtem Nieseregen trainiert haben im Flutlicht. Dann habe ich da immer hochgeguckt und dachte mir so, ich bin ein Gottverdammter Profi und ich hab vier Schatten. So wie die im Fernsehen und ich hätte nicht weiter weg davon sein können. Aber dann bist du ja eben irgendwann auf die Sportschule gekommen und das war so, dass deine Schule war bei Jugendtrainiert für Olympia und ihr seid mit der S7 gefahren und deine Eltern haben dann die Trainer, der auch dort anwesenden Turbinenspielerin, haben die einfach angesprochen. Und das hast du schon ein paar mal erzählt, aber du hast noch nirgendwo, nachdem ich es jetzt recherchieren konnte, erzählt, warum glaubst du denn, haben deine Eltern das überhaupt gemacht?
Die wussten schon sehr früh, dass ich einfach talentiert bin, Bewegungstalent bin und dann auch von meiner Mentalität, so dieses so, ich lasse halt einfach nichts anbrennen, so ich ziehe halt durch. Und das wussten sie. Und dementsprechend sind sie dann auch zu dem Trainer gegangen, so übrigens hier. Und dann ging es ja alles so rasant schnell. Also es war ja auch im Vergleich, also mit meinen älteren Schwestern, die waren, die waren Trainingstypen oder sind Trainingstypen. Und ich hatte halt immer kein Bock auf Training. Ich wollte den Wettkampf machen. Das hat sich herauskristallisiert, wenn wir, wir hatten zwei Pferde und wenn wir auf Reitturnieren waren. Meine Schwestern haben halt damit angefangen. Und natürlich ich als Küken so. Natürlich gehe ich dann ja auch reiten bzw. auf die Wettkämpfe, so was man halt macht. Und da war dann echt so das Ding, ich hatte keinen Bock unter der Woche halt zu reiten, sondern ich wollte immer nur bei den Wettkämpfen am Start sein. Und bei meinen Schwestern war es genau das Gegenteil. Wettkampf war immer Stress.
Ja, okay, interessant. Aber trotzdem ist es ja so, dass damals, jetzt im Nachhinein kann man ja sagen, ja super, danke Mama, Papa, ihr habt damals schon gesehen, du hast irgendwann mal erzählt, dass du mit vier erzählt hast, dass du Nationalspielerin werden willst, da konntest du dich lange nicht dran erinnern, aber deine Familie wusste es. Und im Nachhinein kann man natürlich sagen, ja hier alles richtig gemacht, die wussten einfach schon mehr als wir alle. Aber es ist ja trotzdem auch für Eltern gar nicht so selbstverständlich, weil zum einen geben sie dich ja auch ein bisschen aus der Hand. Du musst vom Dorf in die Stadt oder da ist die Stadt, je nachdem, wie man es sieht. Und zum anderen ja auch in ein System, von dem sie dich ja vorher interessanterweise fahre gehalten haben.
Ja, das war dann die Grundlagen der Erziehung. Die waren ja bereits getan. Also ich sag mal so, ich bin ja dann mit 14 weg. Und es war auch gut, weil ich ja auch hart pubertierend unterwegs war und dann natürlich auch ein gewisses Konfliktpotenzial war. Es war für alle was besser.
Ja, okay, die Phase hatte ich auch in meinem Leben.
Ich glaube, da ist ja jeder irgendwie mal durch. Und dann auch so ein gewisses Vertrauen darin. Und auch daran kann ich mich noch sehr stark erinnern, die Aussage meiner Eltern mir gegenüber, wo das dann auf dem Blatt Papier safe war. Ich gehe jetzt aufs Internat dieses Tabea, wenn du merkst, es wird so viel oder es bringt mir keine Freude mehr. Du weißt, wo dein Zuhause ist. Du kannst jederzeit zurückkommen. Mit diesem Satz haben sie mich quasi gehen lassen. Ich hätte auch ein Problem damit gehabt im Nachhinein, wenn sie mir das irgendwie unterbunden hätten. Ich höre das von vielen tatsächlich und werde angeschrieben. Oder hatte jetzt auch mal mit Eltern ein Gespräch. Können wir denn unser Kind so früh losgehen lassen? Also dass die Eltern eher ein Problem mit haben und somit eigentlich eine Sportkarriere ihres Kindes unterbinden? Ich glaube, das muss man sich ja auch bewusst werden. Ich habe keine Kinder. Ich habe absolut keinen Plan, wie das ist, als Elternteil ein Kind mal eben mit 13 oder mit 14.
Ich meine, ich kann es auch aus der Perspektive desjenigen sagen, der quasi früh lernen musste, mit Heimweh umzugehen und das deswegen dann später nie wieder hatte. Aber das ist, glaube ich, für die Eltern schon hart, auch weil du ja dann einen geschützten Raum verlässt. Und ich meine, ich springe jetzt ein bisschen, wir müssen gleich noch zu deinem Probetraining zurückkommen. Aber wenn du zum Beispiel erzählst, ja relativ vor kurzem erst, dass mit 16 Jahren, als du dann schon Spielerin warst, ein Mann im Supermarkt auf dich zukommt und dir einfach auf die Stirn küsst, das zeigt ja auch, in welchem ungeschützten Raum du dich da letztlich begeben hast. Und wirft auch die Frage auf nach Schutzkonzepten und so weiter.
Ja voll. Also ich meine, es müssen wir, also gerade jetzt ist es ja nochmal so offensichtliches Thema, inwiefern ich als Frau oder auch als junges Mädchen einfach der männlichen Gewalt ausgesetzt bin. So und ich sag mal so dieses Thema Schutzkonzepte ist das eine und auf der anderen Seite dieses geh ins Leben rein. Das Leben prägt dich, das lehrt dich. Ich sag immer die Lebensschule, das habe ich wieder von meinen Eltern irgendwie beigebracht bekommen, in der Schule gelernt oder im Studium, beziehungsweise im Polizeistudium habe ich schon einiges gelernt. Auch Täter-Motive und auch Eingriffstechniken, wenn mal irgendwie was passiert. Aber grundsätzlich, also zum Thema Schutzkonzept, merke ich auch jetzt immer wieder, inwiefern wir eine externe Anlaufstelle brauchen. Es darf nicht im Verein selbst passieren, weil was passiert in den häufigsten Fällen, ist, dass ich eine Meldung mache als Betroffene. Und das bleibt in dem Verein, weil man natürlich in der Außendarstellung never ever mit dieser Story raus würde, weil es Shitstorms gegenüber dem Verein gibt. Deswegen behalten wir das irgendwie drin und lassen das irgendwie so ein bisschen verschwimmen. Das ist der Fakt, was passiert.
Gleichzeitig ist man ja aber nicht nur in einer höchst vulnerablen Lebenssituation, sondern ja auch in einem ganz stark leistungs- und hierarchisch geprägten Raum. Also, du lebst dann im Internat, du hast dann, wie du ihn auch genannt hast, Haustrachen. Und das hat ja jeder, der mal in so was gelebt hat. Die müssen auch ein bisschen strenger sein. Und dann gibt es mal die Abmahnung, weil ihr mit den Matratzen das Treppenhaus runter. Aber ich fand es zum Beispiel schon interessant, was du vom Putztag am Donnerstag erzählt hast, dass da sogar mit dem Finger noch irgendwie unten am Luftdurchlass von der Badezimmertür und dann irgendwelche Athletinnen dann Rasierkling reingelegt haben. Das ist aber auch krass, oder?
Das ist natürlich, natürlich, ja.
Aber deswegen finde ich, dass diese Frage nach Schutzkonzept und was es eigentlich braucht, so drängend ist. Und ich meine, es gibt jetzt wieder ganz schreckliche Beispiele, das von dem ehemaligen Schiedsrichter vom SCA Altach, der da Funktionär war und Spielerinnen bespannt hat und damit mit einer absoluten Witzstrafe. Ich rede jetzt nicht juristisch, einfach nur moralisch. Das ist absolut, absolut grauenhaft, wie wenig den Spielerinnen da letztlich dann gezeigt wurde, dass man das ernst nimmt. Das ist ein aktueller Fall, aber es gibt ja noch viele davon und es gibt ja auch ganz viele, über die dann eher so in Lokalpresse berichtet wird. Denn gerade im Lokalsport, im Breitensport ist das ein riesiges Thema. Und dann stelle ich mir schon die Frage, wenn wir einen solchen Fall haben, wenn wir eben die, ich weiß jetzt nicht, Anekdote, die Begebenheit, die du erzählt hast, haben, warum ist es denn so schwer anzuerkennen, dass man da ganz grundlegend viele Dinge mal anders angehen müsste zum Schutz der Kinder?
Ich glaube, das kannst du nur aus Sicht tun, wenn du selbst betroffen bist. Weil du dann, also ich meine, ich als Betroffene in dem Fall hatte diese eine Situation und sie ist mir nie wieder passiert. Selbst wenn ich jetzt merke, mir kommt jemand zu nahe. Ich hatte das vor zwei Wochen in einem Zug, ein angetrunkener Mann.
Natürlich angetrunken, natürlich ein Mann.
Ja, irgendwie auffälliger. Und dann habe ich ihn einfach, weil er vor meiner Nase rumtanzte, einfach so, hey, entweder du gehst jetzt da lang oder du gehst da lang. Und dann fing er halt an, sich vor mir groß zu machen und halt ein bisschen eine Drohung auszusprechen, habe ich ihn einfach weggeschubst. So dieses, okay, du kommst nicht mehr in meine Sphäre rein. Das lernte ich aus dem, was mit 16 passiert ist. Weil ich als Betroffene mich damit befasst habe. So ich habe mich auf den Weg gemacht, mich aufklären lassen, damit mir das nicht nochmal passiert. Und daraus auch eine gewisse Stärke gezogen. Und auch viel an mir selbst gearbeitet. Thema Zweifel, Angst. Ich darf keine Angst haben. Wovor habe ich Angst, wenn ich sie empfinde? Weil ich sage mal, der Täter riecht das. Und genau diese Motivlage auch. Dann half mir ja das Polizeistudium natürlich so voll. So Täter-Motive. In welchem Spektrum bewegen wir uns? Thema Emotionen. Auch oftmals als eine Emotion, die nicht angepasst in dieser Situation ist. Warum habe ich da eine emotionale Störung, sage ich mal? Was habe ich nicht verarbeitet? Also auf psychologischer Ebene das ein bisschen zu checken, um halt zum einen das Wissen zu haben und dann aber auch vielmehr eine Handlungsstrategie. Und das, wenn du das nicht selbst erlebt hast, dann bleibt es die Theorie. Und das musst du im Verein ja dann auch vorleben. Das musst du teilen, das unmittelbar auch sanktionieren. Also es muss eine Konsequenz erfolgen, wenn sich nicht an diese Regel gehalten wird. Und wo ist diese Konsequenz? Und das geht ja auch ganz vielen, dass sie diese Konsequenz nicht sehen. Und deswegen treten sie halt nicht hervor und äußern sich.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass jede Frau irgendwelche Situationen dieser Art schon mal erlebt haben? Also ist ja eigentlich die Antwort auf die Frage, es tut sich deshalb nichts, weil Männer oft immer noch das sagen.
Ja, durchaus. Ja, voll, voll. 100 Prozent. Also auch sowohl jetzt den Weg, den ich gegangen bin über die letzten Jahre und auch meine Weggefährtenen. Wir tauschen uns regelmäßig aus. So was hast du hier wieder erlebt? So dieses auch. Es gibt auch heute noch Situationen dieses Nee, ist jetzt nicht wirklich passiert. Das kann doch nicht sein. Und es passiert. Und dann halt sich das zu erzählen, zu sagen hast du das schon ist dir schon mal passiert. Welche Handlungsstrategie hast du? Das ist so ich sag mal so ich suche mir Verbündete um eine gewisse. Ja, nicht nicht eine Bestätigung, doch auch irgendwie eine Bestätigung in meinem Gefühl, in meinem Gestörgefühl zu bekommen, weil dieses ist ich weiß ja nicht irgendwie so. Warte mal, habe ich jetzt vielleicht auch irgendwie?
Man denkt ja immer erst mal.
Was ist denn jetzt mit mir vielleicht nicht so? Das ist auch Teil bei mir und dementsprechend dann halt auch Konsequenzen zu ziehen und auch das zu Feedbacken und wenn es drauf ankommt auch eine Zahnzeige bringen.
Aber wenn wir eben jetzt dann zurückkommen in diese Zeit, gab es da Strukturen, wo du das Gefühl hattest, hier wärst du jetzt damit aufgehoben, dass man erzählt, dass dann eher so als lustige Anekdote zu teilen und guck, wie die Reaktionen sind.
Voll, das ist ein spannender Mechanismus. Dieses, die Dinge nicht, ich sag mal so, die zu verniedlichen.
Ja, genau.
Damit der Schmerz kleiner ist. So ich glaub, dieses oder diese Empörtheit. Dieses ein Beispiel war, boah, das war. Ich glaube, ich war grad volljährig. Da klingelte, ich war in der, sie hieß Chaos-WG. Mit fünf Athletinnen waren wir da.
Das muss ja nur im Label gewesen sein.
Es wurde von außen so an uns ran getragen. Irgendwie haben wir es dann übernommen. Mag wohl was dran gewesen sein. Klingelte abends das BKA mit zwei Kollegen. Meinten, ob sie mit, ich war gerade oben. Ich hatte eine Bänder Sprunggelenksverletzung schon eigentlich schon halb im Bett und dann rief die Leichtwirtin nur so, ey, Tabea, das BKA ist hier nicht so, du Scheiße. Und dann bin ich an die Tür ran und dann haben sie nur gefragt, ob sie mit mir kurz alleine sprechen können. Ich so, ja klar, kein Ding. Wie man dann ja auch voller Funktion ist. Dass ich, der Verein hätte Meldungen gegeben, dass ich Mord, also es wurden anonyme Morddrohungen an mich gerichtet und wir Mail an den Verein geschickt. Und da war, der Verein meldet das dann halt bei der Polizei, aber mich quasi mit einzubeziehen, zu sagen, okay, wir haben ja folgenden Leitlinien, was brauchst du? Brauchst du überhaupt irgendwas? So eine Art Schutzprogramm. Nichts. Ich stand dann da und dachte mir so, okay, alles klar. Was machen wir denn jetzt? Ich hab dir auch gesagt, ich will die Mail nicht lesen. Da hab ich gleich ein, das ist das, was ich kontrollieren konnte, zu sagen so, nee, ich will den ganzen Shit nicht lesen. Und dann wurde ich als Betroffene aufs Revier eingeladen. Da hatte ich dann aber den ehemaligen Kollegen, wo ich ein Praktikum gemacht hatte. Deswegen hatte ich da schon, da war schon mal so eine vertraute Ebene gegeben. Und das war das, was mich aufgefangen hat.
Und das ist ja, wenn ich es richtig weiß, zweimal passiert. Einmal, wir reden später noch über eine rote Karte gegen Kerstin Garifrekes. Das war einmal. Das zweite Mal, als du Fatimir Al-Uyshi bzw. Bayramay damals noch gefordert hast. Also beides Mal auch ein Spielen gegen den FFC. Das heißt, der Auslöser war ein Sportlicher. Und die Täter waren sehr wahrscheinlich wütende Männer, die dachten, es sei jetzt dann die richtige Reaktion darauf, dir quasi eine Mordung zu schicken, beziehungsweise den Verein.
Und da hatte ich ja noch kein Social Media. Das heißt, also da hätten sie mich nicht adressieren können. Deswegen haben sie den Verein genommen und haben sich da quasi ihren Shit abgelassen.
Das ist jetzt, also wir springen jetzt ein bisschen.
Ja, das ist mein Leben. Willkommen in meinem Leben.
Ich habe das auch in bisherigen Sendungen mit dir so wahrgenommen. Ich dachte mir so, schaffe ich das chronologisch? Nein, schaffe ich nicht. Aber ich werde immer wieder zur Chronologie zurückkommen. Du wirst es sehen, hoffentlich. Aber da habe ich viel drüber nachgedacht, weil das ist so, wenn wir jetzt über den Fußball der Frauen sprechen, eine zwiespältige Sache. Denn auf der einen Seite wollen wir, dass der Fußball der Frauen größer wird und bekannter. Gleichzeitig holen wir uns ganz viele schlimme Dinge aus dem Männerfußball mit rein. Und gleichzeitig ist es so, dass schon bei den Leuten, bei den Männern, die jetzt den Frauenfußball und die auch schon vor zehn Jahren den Frauenfußball geguckt haben, da waren damals und sind auch heute noch Weirdos mit dabei. Das muss man einfach so offen ansprechen. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum das manchmal die Leute so ein bisschen eine Hemmung haben, das zu sagen. Also es gibt ja unzählige Beispiele. Zum Beispiel hat mal, ich glaube, es wurde in einem Podcast öffentlich erzählt, aber ich lasse den Namen jetzt mal weg, weil ich gerade nicht weiß, ob ich es erzählen darf. Da war eine Spielerin verletzt, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, auch bei Turbine, eine aktuelle Spielerin. Und da hat dann irgendwann bei ihr zu Hause ein Opa geklingelt, einer von denen, die halt immer da sind und hatte ihren Kuchen gebacken. Und das ist ja absolut grenzüberschreitend. Gleichzeitig gibt es nicht nur natürlich die alten Opas, die auch komischerweise immer ihre Digitalkamera noch mit dabei haben oder jetzt ihr Smartphone und immer sehr viele Fotos machen. Das hat ja auch Lena Oberdorf mal erzählt in ihrem Podcast. Es gibt auch sehr viele Männer. Es ist auch immer so eine Alterskohorte, zumindest häufig bei den Geschichten, die ich gehört habe, die zum Beispiel so extrem touchy werden, wenn es um Fotos geht. Deshalb dann manche Spielerinnen, ich habe das zum Beispiel in dem Fall gehört von Rasenballspot Leipzig, dass dann Spielerinnen sagen, wir wollen eigentlich gar nicht mehr in diese Situation kommen, dass die so nah an uns rankommen können. Das heißt, auf dem Feld verabschieden wir uns gerne von denen mit ein paar Metern. Aber wenn die dann am Bus warten, denn die warten ja dann am Bus, und wollen dann noch irgendwas. Und das ist ja ein Problem, was quasi jetzt schon da ist im Fußball der Frauen, wo ich jetzt auch leider gar keine Lösung habe, aber wo ich mich ein bisschen wundere, warum es so selten thematisiert wird. Also die Dinge, die ich dir jetzt erzählt habe, die habe ich mir so zusammengesucht aus Gesprächen. Und hin und wieder wird es mal so in einem Podcast erzählt, oder in einem Interview fällt das.
Weil wir es billigend in Kauf nehmen. Weil wir, ich merke es selber immer wieder, weil wir es nicht gelernt, ich habe es auch nicht gelernt, eine Grenze aufzuzeigen, zu sagen, nein, hier ist meine Sphäre, also denjenigen, der mir zu nahe kommt, das zu kommunizieren. Wir können gerne ein Foto miteinander machen, nur hier ist eine gewisse Grenze, du gibst mir mein Handy, wir können Selfie machen, du bleibst bitte da stehen.
Aber das verschiebt dir die Schuld auf dich. Du bist ja nicht daran schuld.
Nein, das gar nicht. Ich glaube, das ist in dem Fall auch gar keine Schuldfrage. Also für mich ist es keine Schuldfrage, sondern für mich ist das, wie wollen wir miteinander umgehen. Weil es ist ein Thema auch, ich versuche ja die männliche Perspektive auch mit einzubeziehen. Wenn diese Person nie diese Grenze aufgezeigt bekommen hat, dann ist ja verständlich, dass ich dann einfach durchziehe. Und deswegen appelliere ich auch an jede Frau auch immer wieder an mich selbst, weil es kostet Energie, immer wieder diese Grenze aufzuzeigen und dann zu sagen, okay, ich bin jetzt zehn Minuten hier am Start mit einer gewissen Grenze, die ich hier aufziehe und dann bin ich aber auch wieder weg, weil ich brauche Regeneration und deswegen ist das super wichtig. Und das Schöne ist, ich habe mir das in einem Kommunikationsseminar, was ich regelmäßig mache, gerade wenn wieder viel passiert ist, dann gehe ich mit der Praxis in die Theorie und bespreche das mit meiner Therapeutin, zu sagen, okay, wie verhalte ich mich denn das nächste Mal? Und wir sind halt alle in diesem Raum. So und wenn, ich sage mal, du das nicht gelernt hast und ich aber merke, ich habe ein Störgefühl, dann lass uns zueinander kommen, lass uns besprechen. Und das Ergebnis davon ist jetzt vermehrt und das finde ich richtig schön, ob im Zug, weil ich ja auch immer zu den Spielen, auch zu den Topspielen immer mit den Öffis fahre, also ich teile den Raum weiterhin und da kommen auch auch ältere Männer auf mich zu und fragen, ob sie ein Foto mit mir machen können und ich so, ja, können wir gerne machen, ob das okay sei, wenn sie halt die Hand über meine Schulter legen, also wie so ein Teambild und ich so, ich schätze das, dass sie es fragen, es ist in Ordnung. Und letztens auch, da hat er mich dann im Nachhinein noch gefragt, ob das okay ist, wenn er das Bild in seinen WhatsApp-Status macht. Und ich so, ich finde es total wertschätzend, dass du fragst, es geht für mich in Ordnung. Er so, ja, nee, das ist für ihn selbstverständlich. Ich so, nee, das ist absolut kein Selbstverständnis. Und das merke ich. Und das finde ich halt das Schöne daran. Und ich glaube, ich möchte nicht als Opfer dessen gesehen werden, sondern ich bin diejenige, die handlungsfähig ist und aufzeigt, okay, das sind meine Prinzipien, so verstehe ich das miteinander. Committest du dich? Ja, nein. Ja, okay, wir können, wir gehen jetzt einen gemeinsamen Weg. Und nein, okay, dann gehst du da lang und ich geh da lang.
Ja, also das ist natürlich die individuelle Ebene. Und trotzdem frage ich mich, es gibt ja noch eine strukturelle Ebene. Und das kann ja auch nicht sein, dass wir quasi von jeder Spielerin verlangen, so wie wir es in der Gesellschaft ehrlich gesagt von Frauen zwar auch verlangen. Aber ich will ja ein ideales Szenario, dass man selber einen Umgang damit findet und da findet. Und ich frage mich schon ehrlicherweise, warum das, also warum da, ich sehe da auch so wenig Gegenarbeit. Also als weiteres Beispiel noch, das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, weil ich wechsle jetzt vom Analogen in den digitalen Raum und das ist ja noch mal extremer. Aber ich will zum Beispiel nicht, ich kann nicht verstehen, warum unter Bekanntgabe neuer Transfers, wenn da jemand drunter schreibt, einfach die Spielerin reduziert auf ihr Aussehen, warum dieser Kommentar da stehen bleibt. Ich weiß, dass es Zeit und Geld kostet und auch nerven, das zu moderieren. Aber das schafft ja einen falschen Raum. Und das schafft dann einen Raum mit das größte Reddit-Forum zur Frauenbundesliga. Da steht in den Regeln drin, relativ weit vorne, ja, wir wissen, das sind heiße Mädchen oder irgendwie so, aber das sind auch Sportlerinnen. Die haben da schon in ihre Regeln reingeschrieben. Das ist ja Wahnsinn eigentlich.
Und inwiefern, also ich meine, strukturell ist für mich immer, hinter jeder Struktur stehen Menschen. Und dementsprechend für diese Menschen, die da oben stehen, ist diese Verantwortung auch gegeben. Nur, wir müssen ihnen dann auch die Verantwortung spiegeln. So und jede Regel, die ich aufstelle, wenn sie keine Konsequenz hat, habe ich im Internat gehabt. Habe ich jegliche Konsequenz. Ja, ich muss in der Abmahnung, das war so eine halbe Abmahnung, aber es war ja am Final nicht so konsequent.
Also du wärst noch mal mit den Matratzen des Treppens auskommen.
Ja, natürlich, weil es doch richtig witzig war, was wir da für einen Spaß hatten. Hey, zu dritt sind wir da runtergerutscht. Also wenn ich keine Konsequenz auf mein Verhalten erfahre, dann mache ich weiter. Das merke ich ja selbst auch. Also ich habe mein Wertesystem, da merke ich sehr schnell, wenn ich abrutsche. Da bin ich auch sehr konsequent mit mir. Nur wer dieses Werte-Corsett vielleicht nicht so eng schnürt für sich und danach lebt, der bewegt sich halt in diesem Spektrum. Und wenn ich halt nicht irgendwie, sag ich mal, mal einen auf die Mütze kriege, dann flitze ich da weiter. Und das sehe ich genau in dieser Verantwortungsthematik. Und gerade auch, du sprichst den digitalen Raum an. Da erfahre ich ja auch absolut keine Unterstützung von den Unternehmen, für die ich arbeite. So und dann sage ich, okay, wenn ihr nicht die Verantwortung übernehmt, so ich bin ja als ich AG, sage ich, ich nehme Verantwortung für mich, auch für meinen eigenen Schutz. Und dann treffe ich auf Panemue, beispielsweise, was ein Unternehmen ist, das eine KI hat, mit der ich meine sozialen Medien verknüpfe. Und die liest mir quasi die Kommentare mit und auch die Direktnachrichten. Und sobald da irgendwie was grenzüberschreitendes ist, dann signalisiert der mir das. Und dann kann ich das quasi melden bzw. auch zur Anzeige bringen, weil die dann in Kombination mit oder in Kooperation mit Staatsanwaltschaften arbeiten, die explizit für diese Fälle spezialisiert sind. Und da fühle ich mich gut aufgehoben, weil ich auch diese Hilflosigkeit sonst verspüre. Weil der digitale Raum hat absolut keine Grenzen.
Ja, ich meine, da muss man ja wirklich auch dankbar sein für so zum Beispiel Tennisspielerin Eva Leest, die immer wieder das bekannt macht, wie sie beschimpft wird von Männern, wenn sie ein Spiel verloren hat, einfach nur weil die dove Sportwetten abgeschlossen haben auf ihre Spiele. Vielleicht auch, weil sie generell Frauen hassen. Aber gleichzeitig ist das ja auch so ein entgrenztes Ding, wo du kannst jetzt über deine Kanäle Kontrolle übernehmen. Aber ich kenne zum Beispiel Fußballkommentatorinnen, die gucken generell bei YouTube nie in ihre Highlights rein, weil sie nicht sehen wollen, was da drunter steht. Weil nicht mal in dem Raum, nicht mal bei großen Sendern, die das Geld dafür eigentlich hätten, dagegen gearbeitet wird. Und gleichzeitig sehe ich dann auf der anderen Seite, also das eine ist quasi unterlassene Hilfeleistung. Also aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Wir leisten uns das Community-Management nicht. Das andere ist bewusste Steine in den Weg legen. Also du hast zum Beispiel nach dem sexuellen Übergriff auf Jenny Hormoso, hast du eine Experten-Moderation im Trikot von ihr gemacht. Und ich habe gehört, du kannst jetzt entscheiden, wie du dich dazu positionieren möchtest.
Sehr klar, auf jeden Fall.
Dass das nicht auf unbedingt so viel Zustimmung beim Sender gestoßen sein soll.
Ja, ich bin da, was ich meinte, so mein Wertekorsett, da bin ich halt sehr konsequent. Und ich weiß ja mittlerweile auch sowohl bei den Unternehmen, für die ich arbeite und generell ja, man merkt es auch in der Gesellschaft, wie viel Angst einfach herrscht. Und das wusste ich im Voraus und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, ich werde es einfach anhaben. Ich hole mir weder irgendwie ein Go dafür, weil ich starkes Bauchgefühl hatte, dass mir das dann untersagt wird. Und natürlich hatte das Konsequenzen im Sinne von Worten, wo zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen war, zu hören waren, wenn du das noch mal machst und so geht das nicht und so. Dieses, okay.
Aber was daran ging nicht?
Dann wird das quasi auch so ein bisschen dargelegt dieses Jahr. Ich und ich sehe die Seite auch. Ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig zu verstehen, dass ich meine Kollegen damit ja vielleicht unwissentlich in einem Raum stehen lasse, wo sie nicht darauf reagieren könnten. Sehe ich voll, weil mein Verständnis ist, in einer Teamarbeit auch Dinge abzusprechen, zu sensibilisieren für die Themen. Nur in dem Szenario habe ich das bewusst in Kauf genommen, weil ich das Vertrauen auch in die Männer dort hatte, mit denen ich arbeite und auch immer noch habe. Wir kriegen das auch live geregelt. Und dann diesen Weg bewusst zu gehen, darauf aufmerksam zu machen. Und es ist explizit dieses Beispiel hat mir auch bewiesen und zeigt mir immer wieder, inwiefern das versucht wird, zu unterbinden, nicht so groß machen zu lassen. Und ich sage immer, mit dem, dass ihr mich einkauft, kauft ihr auch Werte mit ein. Und hey, ja, das ist meine Position als Frau.
So.
Get it.
Könnte sich als übertragene Sende ja auch die Frage stellen, warum braucht es eigentlich noch ein so plakatives Beispiel? Warum ist da jemand im Spanentrikot am Tresen? Könnte es auch dafür sprechen, dass man dieses Thema vielleicht bisher noch nicht mit der nötigen Ernsthaftigkeit...
Ja, und vielleicht weil auch in diesen Ebenen Hierarchien stehen und auch sehr männlich geprägt und das bringt Unruhe und keiner will Unruhe.
Ja gut, das ist... Da sind wir jetzt noch bei einem anderen Thema. Aber du wirst es nicht glauben, wir kommen jetzt zurück zur Sportschule. Und zwar, also wir haben jetzt schon gelernt, also in der S7, da fing alles an. Du hattest dein erste Probetraining. Du solltest den Ball zehnmal mit dem Kopf hochhalten. Dreimal hast du geschafft und später hat ja Almut Schuld in der ihr berühmten Offenheit hat ja auch später mal erzählt. Also wir hatten dann irgendwann mal bei so einem Lehrgang eine Tabea dabei, die konnte ja gar nichts. Jetzt ist es ja aber so, dass du deinen Weg gegangen bist und dass es dann ja vielleicht dann doch gar nicht so wichtig ist, ob man zehnmal den Ball mit dem Kopf hochhalten kann. Was sagt denn das, dass du quasi entgegen der Norm, in Anführungszeichen, da reingekommen bist über dieses System? Ja, Auswahl, Sport, Leistungssport aus.
Dass ich nicht richtig anpassungsfähig war. Im Sinne von auch mich, es klingt jetzt sehr groß und es ist auch, sich immer unterzuordnen, mich schnell, ich sag zu verallgemeinern lasse, sondern wirklich an dem, meine Schwestern sagen mir oder meine Familie auch so, ich bin ein richtiger Sturbok. So wenn ich mir was in den Kopf setze, dann ziehe ich das durch und weiß auch im Voraus, ich muss diese Erfahrung machen, um dann daraus meine Lehren zu ziehen und das beschreibt eigentlich meine komplette Karriere oder mein eigentlich mein ganzes Leben und dass ich da täglich ja auch, ich meine ich wurde sehr konsequent trainiert und auch, wie meinst du das mit konsequent trainiert? Also ich sag mal so, es war nicht auf Augenhöhe. Also es wurde vorgegeben und wir hatten zu machen und wenn nicht gab es eine Konsequenz.
Also wenn du da jetzt nicht vom gelben zum grünen zum blauen Hütchen gelaufen bist, dann kriegst du einen Einlauf.
Werbar einen Einlauf und auch so fies, so vor der Mannschaft. Eine Situation war auch, weil mit den gewissen Trainingsinhalten ich nicht ganz zufrieden war und dann das quasi auch verschriftlicht wurde und oben Feedback, wie können wir und dann was passiert war, dass dieses Schriftstück mit Potenzialen zum Schulleiter ging und dann eine große Sitzung gemacht wurde und aus dem Schriftstück vorgelesen wurde und man mich das quasi schön ausgelegt hat, mir ausgelegt hat und das war schon heftig.
Aber das heißt, du hast quasi Trainingsvorschläge gemacht, also für Dinge, die man verbessern kann?
Ja, beziehungsweise in Kombination mit meinen Eltern. Also das kam von meinen Eltern, dass sie sagen so, okay, folgendermaßen, weil es war einfach Stillstand in der fußballerischen Entwicklung und von den Trainingsinhalten. Und da hatten sich dann meine Erziehungsberechtigten mit eingemischt.
Das ist, glaube ich, nach all, was ich jetzt so gehört habe, deinen Eltern auch nicht so untypisch.
Da sind es auch ein Stuhl Bock. Wir sind halt alles irgendwie sehr aktiv. Also das eine Mal. Und da habe ich dann aber auch konsequent gesagt, dass das wenn dann auf meinen Nacken wachsen wird und nicht, ich brauche jetzt keine Erziehungsberechtigten mehr, die mir da glauben, mich schützen zu müssen. Das ist ja auch immer so ein Abnabelungsprozess mit den eigenen Eltern. Der kam ja dann auch noch dazu. Und das war schon, da wurde mir mal sehr schnell aufgezeigt, wer hier das Sagen hat und wer auf jeden Fall nicht. Und ich war es definitiv nicht. Und es war ja auch, wir sind ja mittig um die zehn, elf Fußballerinnen gestartet. Am Ende sind wir nur zu dritt geblieben. Weil das war schon mental, hat man da sehr viel getragen.
Also das war jetzt dann die Zeit, das war ja auch schon unter Bernd Schröder.
Ja, dann auch.
Also zwei, sechs bis zwei, acht, so was.
Genau, ja. Dann bin ich sehr früh hochgezogen worden. Und was davor, bevor ich in die erste Mannschaft gekommen bin, war ja U17. Da habe ich sehr konsequent gespielt. Und dann war das Ding, dass ich in der U17 trainiert, trainieren sollte und dann aber die Spiele schon in der zweiten machen sollte. Und das hatte ich nicht verstanden, weil ich möchte ja quasi die inhaltlichen Dinge unter der Woche mit der Mannschaft trainieren, um dann best zu performen zu können. Und dann bin ich dann halt auch zu dem Trainer der zweiten gegangen, habe gesagt, okay, entweder oder.
So, also das war mit dann 16, 17.
Ja, genau. Ja, und da hatte ich meinen Weg schon sehr klar. Oder das war zumindest in meinem Verständnis und das habe ich kommuniziert. Es war ja auch immer eine offene Kommunikation. So wie wir entscheiden doch hier gemeinsam. Und da bin ich dann auch sehr schnell immer wieder dran gewachsen. Und das ist ja auch, ich sage mal so ein Verteidigen meiner Werte beziehungsweise ich lebe in meinem Verständnis und möchte das auch teilen. Und das ist natürlich auch in einem System, wo es sehr viele Jahre lang so läuft und auch so weiterläuft. Kommt da mächtig Bewegung rein.
Ich meine, das kann man ja auch an Bernd Schröder, glaube ich, erzählen. Und ich will jetzt nichts von seiner Leistung wegnehmen. Absolut. Schon in der DDR-Legende auch ganz, ganz viele wichtige Dinge für den Fußball der Frauen getan. Aber es würde einen ja nicht mal wundern, wenn so jemand mit diesem Werdegang auch so ein bisschen dann noch in älteren Trainingsmethoden verhaftet ist. Und ihr habt sehr, sehr hart trainiert. Wie war denn das für dich? Also vor allem jetzt noch später dann als Kapitänin und so weiter. Da bist du ja logischerweise auch schon mehr auf Augenhöhe vielleicht.
Nee, gar nicht.
Okay, ich habe später auch noch ein Otom mitgebracht, der ist von Bernd Schröder, da können wir das später noch. Aber geht denn das nicht anders für Leistungssport zu trainieren? Also es ist ja leider klar, dass wenn elf anfangen, dass nicht elf im Leistungssport landen werden. Dafür ist es Spitzensport. Und wir kennen da ja gute Zahlen aus den männlichen Nachwuchsleistungszentren, dass es so rund drei Prozent sind, die es schaffen und dass alle mit jedem Jahr 30 Prozent Rotation im Kader stattfindet. Das heißt, je später du eigentlich erst reinkommst, desto besser ist es, desto größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du drin bleibst. Was ja schon zeigt, irgendwie gibt es hier einen Baufehler. So eine Logik scheint das nicht zu folgen. Also geht es nicht anders oder was würdest du dir wünschen, wenn wir eben darüber sprechen, ja wie macht man es denn vielleicht heute mit 14-, 15-Jährigen, dass die kommen, weil was ich gerade sehe ist, dass wir eigentlich versuchen, die NRZ-Strukturen aus dem Enderfußball nachzubauen.
Ja, ich finde, die Zahlen, die du auch gerade benannt hast, also wie mangelhaft ist bitte dieses Sportsystem, wenn ich es nicht schaffe, die Leistungsentwicklung auch zu planen, weil du kannst Leistung planen und damit ist sie auch messbar. Ich meine, ich habe mit 16 angefangen, Leistungsdiagnostiken zu machen. Habe ich irgendwas davon verstanden? Nüscht. Und wurde das auch übertragen auf die komplette Saison, wie ich mein individuelles Training mache? Nein, nicht ansatzweise. Und das hast du heute auch noch. Da musst du nur mal irgendwie zu Einzelathleten in den anderen Sportarten gucken, wie krass umfangreich, detailliert auf ihre Ressourcen trainieren, um folgende Entfaltung zu zu entwickeln. Das haben wir im Fußball nicht. Wir haben im Fußball sind wir in so einer Komfortzone. Und deswegen, ich sage mal so, je früher ich damit anfange, desto schlechter ist die oder desto geringer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, oben anzukommen. Ich bin ja auch mit 14 aufs Internat in dem ersten Gespräch, Aufnahmegespräch, was ich hatte, ist eine spätere Einsteigerin, keine Chance. So, aber da war ich natürlich gekitzelt in meinem kompetitiven Verhalten.
Weil du das entsprechende psychologische Profil hast.
Ja, von dem ich ja noch gar nicht wusste, aber ich dachte mir so, ne, dir zeige ich es.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch den Typ, der sich davon komplett ermutigen lassen würde und wo es dann eine Self-fulfilling Prophecy wird. Und wenn man sich auch anguckt, wie viele, also wie gesagt, dadurch, dass es die NSZ-Strukturen eben bei den Männern gibt, sind es die Beispiele, die ich nenne, aus dem Männerfußball. Aber ich denke, dass sich das bald übertragen lassen wird, leider auf dem Frauenfußball. Wie viele junge Männer, die es nicht in den Leistungssport geschafft haben, also nicht dritte Liga oder aufwärts spielen, wie oft die nicht mal mehr Fußball spielen, weil die entweder, manchmal auch beides, nicht mehr gesund genug dafür sind und aber ganz sicher oft den Spaß komplett verloren haben am Fußball.
Voll. Und ist es nicht irgendwie auch, ich weiß, es ist viel verlangend in den jungen Jahren ja vielleicht auch, was lernst du halt erst mit dem, dass dir solche Sachen passieren, aber auch eine Eigenverantwortung. Und das ist das Thema, was mir in dem Sportsystem keiner gelehrt hat, was Eigenverantwortung anheißt, weil letztlich was passiert gerade Mannschaftssport, Mannschaftssportstrukturen wie jetzt Fußball von morgens bis abends habe ich eine komplette Struktur, die fremd gesteuert ist. Und ich meine, ich habe ja gesehen, wie es auch anders funktionieren kann. Das war in England-Barrasen, wo es heißt, also es fängt halt mit dem, mit dem, mit den Messdaten an. Ich habe eine Leistungsdiagnostik, um mal zu verstehen, was dieser Apparat eigentlich alles kann. So, und dann heißt es ja, wenn ich halt gewisse Trainingsintensitäten fahre, kann dir jeder Leichtathlet, jede Leichtathletin sagen, wie die ihre Kraftspitzen haben, wie sie quasi ihre Regenerationskraftaufbau wieder haben, um dann irgendwann für den Wettkampf, für die Saison bereit zu sein. Im Fußball erzählt dir das kein Mensch. Und über Arsenal hatten wir das dann wirklich zu sagen, okay, das ist der Ist-Stand. Das sind jetzt gerade deine 100 Prozent für die Position, die du spielst. Brauchen wir mehr. Ja, das heißt wiederum, wir haben jetzt ein Jahr Vorbereitung. Beziehungsweise ich war ja auch in Area, das ist nochmal ein anderer Case gewesen. Sagen wir mal, es sind vier bis sechs Wochen Vorbereitung. Da kann ich halt folgende Reize setzen, damit ich halt mein Prozent, mein Maximum steigern kann und bin dann ready für meine Position, die ich fahre in dem Spiel. So und das alles anhand gewissener Daten. Und jetzt sage ich sogar, geht es noch weiter. Was für ein Treibstoff, also ich sage mal, was esse ich, wie regeneriere ich, was lese ich? Mit welchen Menschen bin ich umgeben? Welche Verantwortung trage ich für mich auch nach außen? Welche Werte? Das sind ja alles, sage ich mal, so Skills, die dir keiner beibringt. Und da auch dieses wirkliche, was sind deine Interessen? Und das war eins meiner Ebenen, die ich gelebt habe und die enorm viele Konflikte mit sich gebracht haben. Und auch immer mit eigenen Spielerinnen, die mir sehr nahe waren. Tabea, du bist für mich zu wenig zuverlässig, weil ich dann gesagt habe, okay, ich bin im Szenario Fußball 100 Prozent und ich habe auch 100 Prozent Leben. So und ich habe mir meine eigenen Prinzipien aufgestellt. Und wenn Sonntag Spiel war, war für mich Donnerstag der letzte Abend, wo ich auch noch mal ausgegangen bin. Ausgehen heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich da voll war wie ein Eimer und sonst dergleichen, sondern einfach, weil ich einfach Leben liebe und ich liebe es zu tanzen. Und dann gehe ich halt einfach noch mal ins Waschhaus und gehe tanzen.
Wie viel hast du denn dann letztlich gezahlt von den rein theoretisch 150 Euro, weil du drei Mal auf der Party-Seite der Events-Zeitung warst und eigentlich kostet ein Foto, bei dem man da auftaucht, kostet 50 Euro. Das hast du nämlich nie erzählt. Du hast nur erzählt, dass es eigentlich 50 Euro pro Bild sind.
Ja genau, es waren drei Bilder. Ja das und das meine ich, da lehrte mich ja dann auch das Leben.
Also Jenny Zietz hat dir gelehrt.
Klar, weil sie Kapitänin, sie muss ja auch gucken, dass sie alle beider strangelt. Und dann war sie aber, die jetzt Gespräch mit mir gesucht, Tabea, was hast du denn da schon wieder gemacht? Ich so, ja Jenny.
Also weil du halt in dieser kleinen Zeitung hinten im Eben.
Ja, das ist die Events in Potsdam.
Da wirst du aufgetaucht auf den Party-Fotos.
Ja und dann war es irgendwann, dann war halt irgendwie so, den Fotograf habe ich dann das nächste Mal gesagt, ey bitte mich nicht fotografieren, wird teuer sonst. So und das sind ja dann irgendwie so, ich sag mal so Lebensgeschichten oder dieses, die Freude am Leben, die immer für mich auch mit Priorität hatte, weil das am Ende des Tages auch nochmal die letzten Prozente waren, die ich halt performt habe auf einer Ebene, wo du diesen Zauber schaffst.
Genau, aber dieser Zauber, der wird einem ja ausgetrieben. Du hast es ja beschrieben, wenn schon Mitspielerinnen sagen, du bist nicht zu verlässlich genug, dann will man nicht wissen, was Bernd Schröder manchmal über dich gesagt hat.
Ja, und das ist das Krasse. Ja, ich habe ja oft nicht gehört, was er gesagt hat.
Weil du nicht zugehört hast oder weil das anderen Leuten gesagt haben?
Ich habe gut gefiltert. Aber letztlich, und das muss ich fairerweise sagen, wusste ich, dass ich mich auf ihn verlassen kann und er sich auch auf mich verlassen kann. So, das war irgendwie so ein unausgesprochenes Commitment, gerade was meine Leistung im Spiel anging, die sehr konstant war. Und es gab natürlich auch mal Phasen, wo ich dann echt mal, wo ich auch so Querschläge am Spiel hatte, wo ich selber auch wieder dachte, Tabea, was machst du hier eigentlich? Da musste er dann noch einmal kurz rumbölken und dann habe ich mich aber sehr schnell immer wieder gefangen. So, und das wussten wir von dann. Das musste man auch irgendwie nicht aussprechen. Und so sehr ja auch, ich war ja in einer Sportschule auch und dann, ich glaube, das war 10. Klasse Abschluss bzw. dann auch nochmal so eine Ski-Freizeit und ich wollte da unbedingt mit und ich dachte so, ne, weil das auch in der Vorbereitungsphase war, so für einen Hallenturnier, so come on, da kann ich mal eine Woche nicht, also ne. Und dann hatte er, habe ich ihm das mit ihm geteilt, hatte schon, weißt du, so Plan A bis E, wie ich meine Argumente aufstelle und dann habe ich kurz geklopft an seinem Zimmer und dann ist er so, ne, ne, also das kannst du nicht und dann ich schon so, fuck. Und dann gut erstmal trainiert und so und ich war dann schon so wütend, weil ich mir dachte, so, ah komm, das war keine gute Verhandlung, die ich da hatte. Und dann wusste ich aber immer, was er nämlich, die Werte, die Schrödi Bernd gelebt hat, war immer dieses, okay, dieses Commitment mit Schule, mit Verein, so man gibt sich die Hand und dann wusste ich, okay, das ist mein Argument. Und das mit dem Argument, so komm, ne, und so, ja komm, seh zu, dass du jetzt eine Woche weg bist, aber wenn du mir mit einer Verletzung wieder kommst, dann, das konnte er sich dann auch nicht sparen. Ey, und ich hatte die beste Zeit so dieses, ja, und bin topfit auch wieder im Training gewesen dann. So und das ist halt, dafür musst du einstehen, wenn dir die Dinge wichtig sind. Und das brachte diesen Konflikt mit. Das bringte meine Argumentationsstrategie mit sich und die hat mich ja aufgestellt für alles, was jetzt kommt.
Aber wie wurde dann damals trainiert? Also ich habe gelesen manchmal sogar dreimal am Tag, was jetzt glaube ich nicht so aktuell ist, die Trainingslehre ist.
Ne, gar nicht. Also ich sage mal so, wir haben diese Balance zwischen Belastung, Entlastung, der sind wir nicht gefolgt und...
Es war eine konstante Belastung.
Genau. Auch irgendwie so dieses, also ich habe, was ich gelernt habe, ist auf jeden Fall, stetig Grenzen zu überschreiten und unmittelbar mit dem natürlich auch ein gewissen Verschleiß meines Körpers zu schaffen. Billigende in Kaufnahme, würde ich sagen. Und der Erfolg sprach für sich. Das steht dir auch dabei. Und die Konsequenz am Ende war halt einfach, ja gut, die Regenerationsphase ist jetzt, die steht immer noch an.
Aber war denn das auch schon so noch in der Zeit, in der du noch nicht dann in der ersten von Turbini gespielt hast?
Ja, schon. Also wenn ich überlege, ja, schon. Also es wurde, es war ein konsequentes Training mit Ball und wenig athletische Vorbereitung. Ich glaube, das ist es ja. Ja, und auch, als ob ich da mit 14 verstanden habe, dass Warm-Up wichtig ist.
Natürlich nicht. Aber weißt du, du hast jetzt unter anderem Olympiasieg und Champions-League-Titel, wo du sagen kannst, und bist bei Sky Expertin, kannst sagen, ja gut, das war es am Ende vielleicht auch wert, deinen Körper zu ruinieren. Weiß ich nicht. Das musst du privat. Aber es gibt ja auch diejenigen, die rausfallen, die es nicht schaffen. Und da frage ich mich schon, ob man Jugendliche auch schon so trainieren muss. Wenn ich gar nicht weiß, bekommen die davon überhaupt den Nutzen, den ich ihnen als Korotte vor die Nase hänge?
Das checken sie heute nur nicht. Und deswegen sehe ich ja dann auch die Kompetenz in den Verein. Also oder hinterfrage die, ich glaube, das ist es viel mehr. Ich hinterfrage die Kompetenz der jeweiligen, was sind das dann? Das ist ja mittlerweile ein richtiges Stuff-Team, zu sagen, okay, was heißt denn das gerade, wenn ich jugendlich in einer Wachstumsphase trainiere, die ja bei Jungs noch mal anders ist wie bei Mädchen. Mädchen noch zyklusbasiertes Training, da wird ja oft immer noch mit argumentiert, ja, aber wir sind ein Mannschaftssport, das können wir gar nicht so individuell gestalten. Das ist immer noch und auch, wir reden auch von erster Liga. Also wir haben das in der Breite noch nicht umgesetzt. Und bei den Jungs ja dann auch noch mal, auch gerade bei den Jungs mit Leistenproblemen, das war ganz krass bei denen, wie du da wirklich individuell steuern kannst, musst. Und auch wie du viel, das merke ich ja jetzt auch immer wieder, weil ich da viel dran trainiere, sich die Dinge zu visualisieren, hat ja dann auch den Effekt auf den Körper, wie wenn ich die eigentliche Übung ausführe. Also wie ich mental trainiere. Und da sind wir so hinter Mond in Deutschland, das ist unfassbar.
Okay, aber bevor wir wieder ins Metathema gehen, wir sind ja noch nicht mal bei deinem Profi-Debüt, aber jetzt kommen wir dazu. Also am 17. September 2008 war es dann endlich soweit. Also 2008 dein Debüt gegen Bad Neuenahr und du hast direkt ein Tor gemacht. Wie war das damals? Was hast du für Erinnerungen da dran?
Ich glaube, ich habe das 2-2 gemacht.
Genau, ja.
Ich weiß noch, dass ich mich glaube ich voll geärgert habe, weil ich nicht den richtigen Sport-BA dabei hatte. Nicht mein Spielsport-BA.
Also weil der anders ist oder weil er quasi so ein Glücks-BA hat?
Ich habe immer einen, heute auch immer noch einen Wettkampf-BA beispielsweise. Weil das ist der beste.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Das und ich habe das gar nicht so zu etwas Besonderem gemacht, glaube ich. Sondern ich habe einfach nur gedacht, so geil, ich habe jetzt 90 Minuten. Go for it.
Und ab wann wusstest du, dass du spielen wirst? Weil ja offenbar noch nicht beim Tasse packen.
Am Tag selber, in der Besprechung sogar. Da hieß es ja übrigens Tabea, alles klar. Ich komm mit dem, ich bin bereit. Das war ja das letztlich, was ich auch meinte, so dass ich dieser Wettkampf-Typ war. Das war so, okay, ich war im Wettkampf, ich bin da. Also diese innere Gelassenheit, Leichtigkeit, jetzt auf die Platte zu gehen und 90 Minuten zu zelebrieren.
Aber du warst ja noch nicht mal 17.
Ja, vielleicht ist das also geil. Ja, einfach diese Unbekümmertheit.
Und du hast da in einem Team gespielt, also unter anderem war mit dabei Isabel Kaszowsky, Barbett Peter, Bianca Schmidt, Marie-Louise Ehter, Viola Odebrecht und natürlich Anja Mittag. Wie wurdest du da aufgenommen?
Ich war richtig goldig. Ja, und auch, ich meine, mit Viola, mit Anja, auch Jenny Zietz, Babs, die haben es mir auch total einfach gemacht. Also ich war ja dann auch so, mein Verständnis, dass ich hochgezogen wurde in die erste Mannschaft, war ja einfach so, ich guck mir von den anderen erstmal alles ab. So, ich war sehr still. Ich habe mir alles ganz genau angeguckt, weil jedes Mal, wenn ich neu im Raum bin, beobachte ich erstmal. Ich wollte die Übung verstehen, was manchmal nicht so einfach war, weil die nicht so gut erklärt worden sind. Und die Passfolgen auch manchmal so durcheinander waren. Das hat wirklich, das war, da musste ich höchste Konzentration auffahren.
Hast du dich dann immer hinten angestellt?
Ja, also auf jeden Fall war ich da noch nicht die Erste.
Also erstmal gucken, wer die anderen so in die Übung vormacht.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Ich brauchte Zeit, genau, ich brauchte wirklich Zeit. Ich hatte gar nicht das Thema so, ich übernehme jetzt direkt Verantwortung. Nee, sondern erst dieses, okay, weil die sind eingespielt. Ich gucke mir das mal an und dann habe ich es drauf. So, und das entwickelte sich ja dann irgendwann auch so. Dann war es irgendwann sehr schnell in meinem Verständnis und dann stand ich auch vorne irgendwie so, ja.
Und hattest du damals das Gefühl, dass du eine direkte Konkurrentin hast, die du verdrängen musst, um reinzukommen?
Auch gar nicht. Bis am Ende meiner Karriere nicht. War dieses Konkurrenzthema war nie präsent bei mir. Ich meine, man muss ja sagen, mit dem, dass ich dann gespielt habe gegen Bad Neuenahr, ich glaube, dann habe ich ja sehr konsequent auch an der Startelf immer gespielt.
Genau. Warst du wirklich mit dabei? Ja, genau.
Und ich glaube, deswegen hat sich das gar nicht in, ja, irgendwie so eingebrannt in meinem Hörn, dass ich jetzt hier irgendwie was zu verteidigen habe oder sonst das Gleiche. Bei der Nazio war es dann immer ein bisschen später, da habe ich ein bisschen länger gebraucht, aber es war jetzt nie dieses, war nie mein Verständnis, so ja, die ist jetzt meine Konkurrenz. Gar nicht. Auch heute nicht in einer TV-Welt. Gar nicht. Ich freue mich eher viel. Das merke ich immer wieder und auch schon als Spielerin, diese, ich freue mich so sehr für meine Mitspielerin oder Teampartnerin, wenn die geil performen. Das löst in mir so eine Freude aus. Da freue ich mich teils genauso, wie wenn ich halt selber mal ein Tor schieße oder so geschossen habe.
Ich meine, da ist ja de facto so, es wird wirklich immer Startelf gespielt, Debüt und ab dann immer Startelf in dieser Saison, dass diejenige, die rausgefallen ist, da kein großes Thema draus gemacht hat. Weil sonst hättest du es mitbekommen.
Ja, voll, ja. Ja, das war auch so ein unausgesprochenes Commitment. Weil ich glaube, wenn du selbst nicht so rausfeuerst, dann feuert der andere dir ja auch nicht so viel aus.
Und das interessante ist, es ging von 0 auf 100. Also Debüt mit 16, ab dann immer Startelf und schon im nächsten Monat U17 WM in Neuseeland mit dem Cheftrainer Ralf Peter. Hast du da noch für Erinnerungen dran?
Oh, das ist ein tolles Land. Das wir hatten im Norden und im Süden hatten wir irgendwie gespielt. Und das weiß ich noch. Wir sind mit dann mit einer Maschine in den Süden geflogen und wir sind halt nicht so hoch geflogen, weil es kurze Wege waren. Und dementsprechend hatte ich quasi voll die geile Vogelperspektive auf dieses Land und die Natur. Das ist richtig hängen geblieben. Hängen geblieben ist auch noch, dass bei einem Training, was wir hatten, ein eikoalisierter Mann aus den Büschen gesprungen ist und gerufen haben, ihr Nazis, ihr Deutschen, ihr Nazis. Und das war das erste Mal, wo ich dachte, so okay krass. Ja, also die Konfrontation mit der Historie des eigenen Landes und du trägst den Bundesatler auf der Brust und du singst die Nationalhymne. Okay, da war ich 17 und da war für mich erst mal so, okay, was für eine Bedeutung hat das? Ja, oder wie möchte ich damit umgehen? Thema Nationalstolz.
Wie bist du denn damit umgegangen? Denn interessanterweise hatte ich in Australien mit 16 eine ganz ähnliche Erfahrung. Ich habe natürlich da keinen U17 von mir gespielt. Ich war da auf Austausch und ich hatte einen Onkel der Gastfamilie, bei der ich war, der gesagt hat, ah, German, I won't mention the wars. Und da dachte ich noch, das wäre quasi lustig gemeint gewesen. Und ich hatte aber im Fußballspiel dann in der Schule, da war ich der King, war wirklich sehr schlau gemacht, dort Austausch zu machen, wo meine Fußballskills gut waren.
Geil.
Da habe ich jemanden halt irgendwie ein paar Mal ausgespielt und habe auch ein paar Tore gemacht und dann hat er mir den Hitlergruß gezeigt. Und ich weiß noch, dass ich von null auf gleich wahnsinnig wütend geworden bin, den Ball nach ihm geworfen habe, ihn leider verfehlt habe, ultrapeinlich eigentlich. Und dass ich aber da ganz, ganz lang, also das ist mit einer der prägsten Erlebnisse für mich, dieses ganzen Austausch gewesen, weil ich das so krass fand, dass ich so wütend geworden bin, was gar nicht, also das konnte schon mal passieren, aber es war nicht so wahnsinnig meiner Art. Und weil ich dann eben auch solche Gedanken hatte. Und für mich hat das aber dazu geführt, dass ich dann mich quasi von der aktuellen Version Deutschland so ganz krass distanziert habe und eben auch so Fahnen ganz kritisch fand eben. Und ich hätte nämlich zum Beispiel, glaube ich, dann wahrscheinlich die Hymne nicht mehr gesungen. Und jetzt stelle ich mir aber die Frage, wie macht man das denn, wenn man in einer Funktion ja?
Ja, also im Sinne von, ich meine, das ist mir dann nochmal in England passiert, im Pub, wo auch einer meinte, der hat gefragt, wo ich herkomme, ja aus Deutschland, ja du Nazi. Also es ist halt die Geschichte unseres Landes. Und dann, ey, ich bin Generation Kind 91. So das ist die Historie des Landes, in dem ich geboren bin. Aber ich habe ja so gar keinen Bezug dazu im Sinn. Ich habe die Dinge erlebt. Und ich glaube, da habe ich dann so eine Abgrenzung geschaffen. Und durch das viele Reisen in unterschiedlichste Länder, kontinental auch, weiß ich auch immer wieder, woher ich komme und was ich hier auch stark schätze. Und da auch dann ins Gespräch zu gehen. Und ich merke das ja immer, wenn andere Spielerinnen oder Spieler ihre Hymne singen und italienische Hymne beispielsweise. Und wie ich Gänsehaut bekomme und ich das schön finde, wenn man das Land vertritt, irgendwie eine Gemeinsamkeit teilt und singt. Ja und dann hat sich das, ich habe mich glaube ich selbst damit regeneriert.
Aber wurde es damals von Ralf-Peter dann thematisiert?
Nein, gar nicht. Nein, gar nicht. Es wurde überhaupt nirgends thematisiert. Da hat man auch nichts an die Hand bekommen. Ich meine, ich habe ja auch nicht gefragt. Ich habe es mit mir dann ausgemacht.
Ihr habt im ersten Gruppenspiel dann gegen Costa Rica gespielt. Da hast du das 5 zu 0 geschossen. Du bist in allen Gruppenspielen zum Einsatz gekommen. Es ging außerdem noch gegen Ghana und Nordkorea. Und das ist, wenn man ehrlich ist, so ein bisschen so eine goldene nordkoreanische Generation gewesen. Wie war denn das überhaupt, gegen Nordkorea zu spielen?
Ich weiß, dass ich damals, was auffällig für mich war, dass die alle so gleich waren. Das war meine Wahrnehmung.
Optisch meinst du?
Ja, genau so. Ich meine, das hat man uns auch mal nachgesagt, weil wir immer alle fast einen Dutt hatten. Also, und was ich da aber noch total schön fand, dass wir Hotels hatten, wo alle Mannschaften drin waren. Und dann hatte man so, also wir Deutschen waren immer komplett einheitlich gekleidet, die gleichen Schuhe. Also da durfte, sobald jemand was anderes anhatte, weil man den Plan nicht kannte, musste man Strafe zahlen. So sind wir dann in den Essenssaal gekommen. Dann waren die nordkoreanischen Spielerinnen auch sehr gleich gekleidet. Sie hatten unterschiedliche Schuhe teils an. Dann hatten wir die Ghana-Spielerinnen, die waren komplett bunt einfach da am Start. Sowas ist halt hängen geblieben. Und das fand ich halt so... Ja, du hattest halt einfach Begegnungsräume. Man hatte den Austausch, was ja dann irgendwann bei der Nationalmannschaft gar nicht mehr war, weil du wirklich deinen eigenen... Also jetzt ja noch mal viel krasser, wie du komplett abgeschottet bist, wirst von allem irgendwie, um dich vermeintlich nur zu fokussieren auf den Sport, auf den Wettkampf.
Und wie wichtig ist das Sportliche bei so einem Turnier? Wird am Besten schon eingeimpft von Trainer und allen anderen, ihr vertretet jetzt Deutschland, wir müssen mal wieder U17-Weltmeister werden, weil wir sind der DFB?
Ich überleg grad U17, nee, da hab ich das so alles nicht mitgekriegt. Das war, also man, da bin ich auch nicht so empfänglich, wenn ich ehrlich bin, sondern das ist so, es ist mein eigener Anspruch, der ist klar. So, da brauch auch nicht, ich find das ja auch heute oder damals auch schon.
Du brauchst nicht extrinsisch motiviert werden.
Nein, ich denk mir auch jedes Mal so, versteht ihr das nicht? Ich betreibe Sport in der Häufigkeit, dass es Leistungssport ist und du glaubst, mich noch motivieren zu müssen?
Naja, aber es gibt halt die Spielerinnen, die motiviert werden müssen.
Ja, und da ist doch vielleicht der Punkt, warum man sich hinterfragen sollte, warum man Leistungssport macht.
Ja, okay.
Auf kompetitiver Ebene. Trainingssituationen ist natürlich, boah, da hatten wir dann auch einige Hänge, wenn du drei Mal am Tag trainierst, und nicht mehr weißt, wie du wann du essen sollst, oder hängst du schon durch. Aber am Ende war immer klar, ich wusste immer, wofür ich es tue, immer jeden Tag aufs Neue und ich hatte auch immer Bock.
Okay, also das war quasi, wie es betrachtet wurde von oben dieses Turnier, ihr habt dann im Viertelfinale gegen Kanada gespielt und gewonnen, hast in der Startelf gestanden und nee, wurde es dann ausgewechselt, Hasric Kaikchi wurde für dich eingewechselt. Ich werde jetzt manchmal einfach so Name-Dropping betreiben, weil ich glaube, die Hörerinnen und Hörer freuen sich auch quasi einfach viele bekannte Namen zu hören.
Ja, vor allem gerade mit Hasric, ja.
Und dann habt ihr das Halbfinale gegen die USA gespielt und 1 zu 2 verloren. Du hast bis in die Schlussphase gespielt, wurde es dann ausgewechselt für Svenja Huth und im Spiel um Platz 3, da bist du dann eingewechselt worden, da hast du noch Nachschluss vergeben, nachdem Alex Pop nur den Pfosten getroffen hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie detailliert deine Erinnerung daran noch ist. Aber ich habe jetzt schon die Frage mit Nordkorea gestellt und mit den USA interessiert es mich aber auch. Wie war das gegen die zu spielen? Hatte das was Besonderes und wie haben sich vor allem da vielleicht auch Spielstil, Athletik und so weiter von euch unterschieden?
Es waren immer meine Lieblingsspiele gegen die Amerikaner. Weil es so zur Sache ging, Athletisch. Weil das war, wo ich auch dachte mir so, okay, geil, das ist es. Ich weiß, ich habe eine Gegnerin auf meiner Position, die wird athletisch so krass sein. Das hat mich so krass genial gechallengt. Und daran habe ich mich auch gemessen. Wie sehr halte ich den Zaum? Deswegen habe ich diese Spiele geliebt. Und das zeigt ja heute auch, also auch gerade heute, dass die Amerikanerinnen auch, ich sage mal so in der Athletik natürlich und vielmehr aber auch auf mentaler Ebene, die sind brutal. Die sind so im Winner-Modus, da geht nichts dran vorbei. Und diese Einstellung war schon, da habe ich sehr viel von übernommen.
Ja, dieses 13 zu 0 Gegenteil, das ist das, woran ich immer denke, wenn ich an...
Immer weiter, immer wieder abspulen, joyful, gib ihm.
Alex Morgenthal, ihre ich glaube sieben Treffer, dann hoch, das war.
Und das auch zu zu zelebrieren, so das war ja immer, wir trauen uns ja teils, die Dinge gar nicht zu feiern und ja nicht so hoch, immer Demut, Demut, Demut. So das waren so zwei Extreme, die da aufeinander getroffen sind. Und dann einfach mal dieses, du hast eine geile Ballaktion, du merkst irgendwie so, war voll im Flow und das führte noch zum Tor. So und dann einfach das in den 30 Sekunden ausgelassen zu feiern. Fabelhaft.
Leider aber trotzdem verloren. Ihr wartet damals ein total interessantes Team, also Jennifer Marushan wurde Torschützenkönigin des Turniers, da leuchten deine Augen. Alex Popp war mit dabei, Sven-Jahu, Turit Knark, Hasrit haben wir schon angesprochen, Kaikchi, Karo Simon, Leonie Meyer, um jetzt nun mal so ein paar zu nennen. Wie war es denn auf dieser Ebene, wo man, also ihr seid ja nicht direkte Konkurrenten gegeneinander, aber man hofft, dass man sich noch möglichst oft in der Liga ja auch gegenseitig begegnet. Und kleiner Spoiler, das wird noch bei eigentlich allen denen hier der Fall sein. Wie war das so untereinander?
Wie Klassenfahrt. Es war großartig. Es war wie, vor allem wir waren ja fünf Wochen unterwegs. Du erlebst ja wirklich, du erlebst ja eine Reise in deiner jugendlichen Zeit, die du so nicht erlebst. Weil, wann ist man, wir waren vorher noch zwei Wochen im Trainingslager, auch in Neuseeland, um uns das schon mal alles anzugucken. Dann kam die WM fünf Wochen zusammen. So du teilst dir dein Zimmer mit einer Mitspielerin, die Abläufer, die Hochs und die Tiefs. Du isst drei gemeinsame Mahlzeiten am Tag. Du gehst gemeinsam quasi abends im Bett. 22 Uhr war Schicht im Schacht, vorher noch Behandlung. Das war, ist Familie. Ja voll. Also ich meine, das waren auch gerade, wenn ich jetzt am Poppy denke, an Svenny, an Hasrid, so das war ja mit 16 Jahren, mit 17 Jahren bis jetzt am Ende. Ich bin mit 28 aus der Liga raus. So das sind genau über 10 Jahre war. Ist das ja ein Leben, was man gemeinsam führt.
Weißt du noch, wer das Turnier damals gewonnen hat?
Wahrscheinlich die USA.
Nee, Nordkorea. Ach krass. Das war nämlich die Generation, die dann auch später die U19 haben sie dann auch gewonnen und U20 und ganz viele von denen sind dann. Das war, also es tut mir so leid, ich kann mir die Namen immer so schlecht merken. Aber genau, das war, also Nordkorea hatte mehrere gute Generationen, aber das war die Goldgeneration. Genau, die waren das.
Ja gut, gegen die kann man auch mal verlieren.
Ja, beziehungsweise ich glaube in der Gruppe habt ihr ja gar nicht verloren.
Nee, das steht aber im Turnier grundsätzlich halt.
Genau. So, du kommst zurück wieder aus Neuseeland. Du spielst mit der Turbine in der Liga. Das muss auch schon wieder krass gewesen sein, dann im November irgendwann wieder in Deutschland zu sein. Mein Mitleid nochmal nachträglich dafür. Und ihr habt unter anderem im DFB-Pokal erfolgreich gespielt. Ihr seid gegen Tennis Borussia Berlin, gegen den Mellendorfer TV, den VfL Sindelfingen und gegen die SG Wattenscheid mit nur einem Gegentor ins Finale eingezogen. Du weißt jetzt natürlich schon, was kommt. Dort gab es dann aber vor 20.000 ZuschauerInnen im Olympiastadion ein Finale gegen Duisburg. Weißt du noch, wie das aussieht?
9-0.
Ne.
Ne?
0 zu 7.
8-0-7 war das nur.
Eine dir bekannte Anja Mittag sagt nach dem Finale, dem Tagesspiegel, unvorstellbar, in der E-Jugend habe ich vielleicht mal so hoch verloren.
Ja, das war, ich habe das abgestempelt für mich als historische Niederlage im Olympiastadion. Das muss man auch erstmal schaffen.
Aber was hat denn damals für dich so ein Spiel vor so einer Kulisse auch bedeutet? Wahrscheinlich waren ja auch Leute da, deine Eltern sind auch bekannt dafür, auch gerne mal da zu sein. War das auch das, wo dein Vater die Fahne geschwenkt hat, mit der er bei Stefan Raab kam?
Nee, das war in einem anderen Pokalfinal, in Köln war das schon.
Aber was hat das damals für dich bedeutet und kannst du mal erklären, wie sowas überhaupt auch zustande kommt, dass dann Spiele so komplett gegen einlaufen?
Also in der Vorbereitung war das so, dass wir die Nacht vor dem Spiel auswärts geschlafen haben. Also keine Spielerin halt bei sich zu Hause, was halt eigentlich nahegelegen hat, weil wir in Potsdam Berlin ist jetzt Katzensprung. Sondern wir sind in Schwielosee in so ein wunderschönes Hotels, Bar, Resort und da war schon so dieses, wieso machen wir jetzt hier so ein Special-Ding draus? Habe ich ja erst mal so stehen gelassen. Dann sind wir ja zum Stadion. Dann hatten wir extra für dieses Spiel komplett weiße Trikots. War auch schon so okay. Und dann war so aber geil, Stimmung war ja mega cool. Alles irgendwie der Rasen war, diese schwebende Kamera. Das kannten wir vorher auch nicht. Und dann war so okay, Anpfiff so geil. Und dann haben wir, es war nichts griffig. Wenn du merkst, okay, warte mal, du stehst hier gerade mit dem komplett falschen Bein auf dem Platz. Und du hast selbst die Achse in der Mannschaft, ist nicht stabil von den Spielerinnen. So, ne, ich hab gerade eine Genizidsbar-Bett-Peter-Anja-Mittag. So sag ich, das waren ja auch immer so meine, war ja auch noch so ein Knurps, dass da auch keine Sicherheit irgendwie holen konnte, hatte. Und ey, da gingen wir gnadenlos einfach unter und wir konnten uns nicht auffangen. Und da hab ich dann auch manchmal gemerkt, so dieses krass, weil wir haben keinen Plan B. Und Plan B wäre dann gewesen, okay, du merkst irgendwie 0-3, so okay, wir stellen uns mal komplett in die Defensive und fangen uns einfach mal, lass es fünf bis zehn Minuten, wo wir einfach nur in der Defensive ein bisschen verschieben, keine gefährlichen Situationen groß zulassen und dann ziehen wir mal wieder die Spieltasso. Also wirklich dann auch mal psychologisch an dieses Spiel ranzugehen. Niente. Ja, und dann war es auch, ich erinnere mich noch so, ja, dann war Abpfiff und dann war es so, ja, krass, 7-0, na ja, passiert halt. Also ich war sehr schnell auch wieder an dieser Akzeptanz, so weil ich das ja während des Spiels schon gemerkt habe und auch gemerkt habe, so okay, ich habe hier auch gerade keine Lösung, weil Überforderung, Hilflosigkeit.
Ich meine, man muss dazu sagen, gegen dieses Duisburg konnte auch mal gut verliehen. Also die haben der Woche vorher noch den UEFA Cup geholt, da haben Inka Grins und Alex Popp im Sturm gespielt. Die waren brutal.
Ja, das war, ja und dennoch, 7-0, das ist so, ja, das war auf jeden Fall, ja, das war gut.
Wie sieht denn bei sowas die Nachbesprechung dann aus? Also man muss dazu sagen, es war noch innerhalb der Saison, ihr konntet jetzt nicht irgendwie bis morgens um 6 Uhr auf den Tisch tanzen. Vielleicht habt ihr das gemacht, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hätte mir das gewünscht.
Das wundert mich jetzt nicht so sehr.
Was passiert war, dann war einfach Stillschweigen. Weil keiner richtig fassen konnte. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ob der Co-Trainer oder der Präsident was gesagt hat. Was dann passiert ist, weil es war ja dann auch schon Essen gebucht, also Restaurant auch mit den Fans und so. Das war im Potsdam beim Griechen. Voll lecker da immer gewesen.
Mit den Fans?
Ja, die sind dann auch mal dabei. Das war ja im Potsdam, da gab es auch keine Grenzen und so. Und dann waren wir bei diesem Essen und wenn du merkst, es ist echt zäh, weil man ja jetzt so hoch verloren hat und dann muss man ja jetzt auch so tun, weil es ja auch echt nicht gut gelaufen ist und ja, nicht lachen irgendwie so. Und schnell irgendwie nur nach Hause. Und ich dachte mir so, ja gut. Aber eigentlich, also ich hatte jetzt schon noch Lust gehabt, irgendwie da ein bisschen zu tanzen und so, weil ich kann es ja jetzt nicht mehr ändern und muss ich jetzt so schmälern, um halt irgendwie jemandem das irgendwie gerecht zu machen oder aufzuzeigen. Ja, es wirklich halt bescheiden gelaufen ist, wissen wir jetzt alle. Und so sind wir dann irgendwie nach Hause.
Es war auch insofern ein historisches Finale, weil es das letzte Finale der Frauen in Berlin war. Das war ja quasi noch früher der Vorlauf zum Finale der Männer. Wirklich ganz fantastische Idee, muss man wirklich sagen. 20.000 Zuschauer erinnern, ich habe es schon gesagt, waren vor Ort. Du hast gesagt, geile Kulisse. Der Tagesspiegel hat geschrieben, Zitat, spärlich besetzt und Gott sei Dank wird umgezogen. Das hat sich für dich logischerweise mit 17 damals anders angefühlt.
Ja voll. Ich meine, ich habe noch nie vor so vielen ZuschauerInnen gespielt, deswegen fand ich es mega geil. Ich fand es dann auch großartig danach, ein Männerspiel zu haben, um das noch anzugucken. Fand ich auch großartig.
Habe ich mir gar nicht mehr rausgesucht, weißt du noch, wer da gespielt hat?
Ne, weiß ich auch alles.
Okay.
War richtig klasse anscheinend. Ich mag das ja, wenn du halt so eine Plattform schaffst, wo beide Geschlechter und man spielt und man guckt bei den anderen noch zu und ich mag das.
Ja, es war halt nur einfach schade, dass du damals, du warst Vorprogramm von Fans von zwei Vereinen, wo es eher der Zufall war, dass auch mal die Frauen im Finale waren. Also es gab es nur bei den Bayern Frauen gab es das mal, dass die im Finale waren und abends haben auch die Männer gespielt. Aber ansonsten, das finde ich halt schon unwürdig, ehrlich.
Ja und ist es nicht irgendwie so, dass es fängt ja immer an, einen gemeinsamen Raum zu teilen. Das war bei Arsenal ja dann, ich bin ja ein bisschen darüber, mit 28 Jahren, 2018 bin ich rüber. Da gab es den Emirates Cup und da haben wir Frauen auch gespielt. Da haben wir gegen Bayern gespielt und dann die Männer gegen Chelsea. Und da haben die Männer dann auch die zweite Halbzeit von uns geguckt. Und wir haben danach dann auch das Spiel der Männer geguckt. Und ich meine, was passiert jetzt? Stadien bei den Heimspielen der Frauen ist ausverkauft. It's a way.
Das geht ja in Deutschland gar nicht, Tabea. Da muss ich schon verabschieden.
Ich glaube da noch dran.
Okay, gut.
Sie gibt ja viele Beispiele.
Stuttgart. Definitiv. Ja, jetzt auch Bayern. Wir nehmen jetzt auf vor dem Champions-League-Rückspiel. 20.000 haben sie schon verkauft. Das ist ja auch schon mal immerhin, muss man sagen. Wir haben jetzt auch so Champions-League-Finale, die die Tickets anguckt. Aber das ist jetzt was anderes. Also du hast 18 Spiele gemacht in der Saison, sechs Tore geschossen. Und das eigentliche Highlight kommt aber noch. Es war komischerweise nicht dieses 0 zu 7 gegen Duisburg. Duisburg hatte dann nämlich, also sie haben den UEFA Cup gewonnen. Jetzt haben sie einen DFB-Pokal gewonnen. Und dann haben sie noch ein Nachholspiel gegen den FC Bayern gehabt. Und das haben sie mit 4 zu 0 auch noch gewonnen. Also im Nachhinein durftet ihr den Duisburgerinnen nicht mal böse sein, denn damit hat sich die Tür zur Meisterschaft geöffnet. Und es kommt zu einem epischen Finale. Am letzten Spieltag spielen die Bayern zu Hause gegen Kreisheim und ihr spielt zu Hause gegen Wolfsburg. Eine gewisse Tabea Kemme macht das 2 zu 0. Und weil beide Teams 3 zu 0 gewinnen und sie absolut gleich sind und ihr nur ein Tor mehr geschossen habt, wird tatsächlich Potsdam Meister. Aber ihr müsst noch fünf Minuten warten auf dem Spielfeld, bis die Bayern fertig gespielt haben. Erzähl mir von diesem Tag und wie das war, da zu warten.
Das war einfach nur dieses, wie kann das angehen? Du hast die Woche davor noch 7-0 verloren und bist jetzt in dieser Situation. Das hat mein Gehirn nicht greifen können. Das war auch diese Ausgangslage dann doch wieder zu haben. Oh mein Gott, und diese fünf Minuten, das war ja auch die Fans strömten dann aufs Feld. Dann gab es irgendwie nochmal eine Durchsage. Es sind noch drei Minuten bei dem Spiel und wir alle nur so.
Ihr hattet ja keinen Livestream.
Nee, gar nichts, gar nichts. Nee, dieses so, da war ich glaube ich gerade 18, sondern dieses, ich hatte parallel, hatte ich noch Schulaufgabe, also so das war, da prasselte so viel auf mich rauf und so habe ich dann noch gefeiert. Das war, es musste ich rauszappeln aus dem ganzen Körper. Das war ja, also es war nicht greifbar für mein Gehirn, wie das geht. Ja.
Und weißt du, was so schade ist? Das ist eins der dramatischsten Saisonfinals überhaupt. Und niemand weiß, also jetzt übertrieben gesprochen, niemand weiß davon. Wir alle können über die Fünf-Minuten-Meisterschaft von Schalke sprechen und so weiter und so fort. Aber das war ja, Bayern hätte nur noch ein Tor machen müssen und dann wäre Bayern Meister gewesen. Und wenn sie dieses Nachrufspiel nicht so vergeigt hätten, auch mit 0 zu 4, hätten sie es auch packen können. Und auch mir, ich habe das ehrlich gesagt mir jetzt auch alles angelesen und habe mich dann so ein bisschen geschämt, weil ich mir dachte, eigentlich muss man sowas doch wissen, weil das war ja ein ganz großer Moment. Gibt es davon, welche Aufnahmen könntest du mit der Welt teilen, dass man sagen könnte, in zehn Jahren die Fans wissen, okay, es gab mal die Fünf Minuten Meisterschaft von Bayern, wo Turbine noch irgendwie fünf Minuten warten muss, bis die Meisterinnen waren?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich selber Aufnahmen davon habe. Ich weiß, dass ich das ist. Doch, ich weiß, welche Aufnahme ich davon habe. Und zwar habe ich ein. Das ist ein bisschen was Persönliches, weil das ein Bild ist mit Melissa Kössler, die war Ballmädchen bei diesem Spiel. Und kaum zehn Jahre später spielt sie auch bei Turbine-Pottsdam. Und ist jetzt, letztes Wochenende, beim Spiel in der US-Liga, vorm Rekordspiel Denver mit 63.000 Zuschauern. So, das ist meine persönliche Geschichte zu diesem Spiel. Das ist so, diese Bilder sind, oder das Bild ist explizit hängen geblieben. Also auch eher so dieses Persönliche. Und das ist, ja, auf der einen Seite sehe ich, dass die Geschichte nicht viel geteilt wurde, weil die Aufmerksamkeit einfach so noch nicht da war. Und in dem Moment war aber mein Herz voll, oder ist voll bei dem Erlebnis. Deswegen ist so, I'm happy. So, und das natürlich jetzt später kommt erst so dieses Okay. Und dann wiederum sehe ich auch den Weg, der früher noch nicht geebnet war. Die Geschichten sind da voll.
Das ist ja auch, also wäre ja schlimm, wenn man sich deswegen da über sowas nicht freuen würde. Und du hast ja auch schon angedeutet, dass dann ordentlich gefeiert wurde. Ich habe mal irgendwann mit Sebastian Schuppern, habe ich auch mal ein Tribünengespräch gemacht. Und der hat erzählt, der ist einmal aufgestiegen, da war er sehr jung. Da hat er sehr, sehr wild gefeiert. Und er ist einmal aufgestiegen, da war er dann schon eher so am Ende seines Profitums. Und da hat er gesagt, hat er endlich verstanden, warum damals, als er so jung war, die älteren Spieler einfach nur da saßen und zugeguckt haben und das so genossen haben, weil er es dann nämlich ganz genauso gemacht hat. Da musste ich jetzt gerade denken, als du erzählt hast, dass du wild gefeiert hast.
Ja voll. Ich meine, das war ja, ich weiß noch, Marie-Louise Etat, die hatte den nächsten Tag Fahrprüfung.
Fantastisch. Ja.
Ich hatte um 10 Uhr nächsten Tag, hatte ich Mathe-Nachhilfe, wo das Fernsehen mit zugekommen ist an der Sportschule.
Fantastisch.
Weil ich brauchte Mathe-Nachhilfe, um halt irgendwie durchs Mathe-Abi auch zu kommen. Da hatte ich dann irgendwie noch eine Fünfkämpferin, die Sophie, mit der ich befreundet bin, die hab ich gefragt, Sophie, kannst du morgen mich unterstützen irgendwie bei Mathe-Nachhilfe, weil sonst schaff ich das nicht. Dann ist die noch mit dazu gekommen. Die war aber allerdings auch auf der Feier. Aber so, weißt du, das sind so, okay, das ist so harter Life-Struggle gewesen. So wie krieg ich halt irgendwie übelst zerfeiert den nächsten Tag hin, weil dann ist ja wieder parallel ja Schule. Also so, ich habe ja meine sieben Tageswoche, wo jeder irgendwie Performance verlangt. Und dann war das halt echt ein Self-Management.
Und es ging ja noch weiter. Das ist wirklich interessant, wenn man sich so durch so Karriere von Fußballerinnen und Fußballern durcharbeitet, dass es ganz oft keine Pause gibt. Bei dir war es so im Juli um 19.00 Uhr in Belarus. Stimmt. Hättest du jetzt nämlich vergessen, oder?
Ja, voll.
Dachte ich mir. Deutschland gewinnt gegen Frankreich, verliert dann gegen die Schweiz und schafft es dann trotz eines 9 zu 0 im letzten Spiel, das war nämlich wahrscheinlich das 9 zu 0, das du im Kopf hattest, nicht ins Halbfinale. Du wurdest im ersten Spiel von der Trainerin Maren Maynardt ausgewechselt zur Pause und danach nur noch zweimal eingewechselt. Wie war denn das dann von von U17 zu U19 mit Maren Maynardt zu wechseln?
Sehr konsequent.
Das musst du bitte erklären.
Anspruchshaltung sehr hoch, das weiß ich noch. Und auch irgendwie jetzt in Bezug auf Maren Maynardt ja auch sehr konsequentes, wie sagt man das, Trainerinnenformat. Und da musste ich mich auch erst mal dran gewöhnen. Auch dieses, okay, in welchen Räumen darf ich freudig sein? In welchen Räumen ist das nicht so angebracht?
Also ging es hier quasi los, dass du lieber nicht gelacht hast beim Training, weil sonst gab es den Abendsbesuch.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Es war schon so dieses, okay, hier ist eine andere Luft. Also auch wieder in meiner Rolle, so ich komme irgendwo neu in Räume rein, erst mal ein bisschen beobachten, ich stelle mich zurück, sehe so, wo werden welche Grenzen aufgetischt und das war erst mal so, okay, wo ist die Freude? Wieso ist hier so viel Angst? So, eigentlich haben wir doch alle Bock. Ja, das war so die ausstrahlend, da hatte ich Empfindungsprobleme.
In der Biografie, die Mara Pfeiffer mit Alexandra Popp über ihre, also über Alex Popp geschrieben hat, da wird beschrieben, dass Mara Meiner da auch Kommentare gemacht hat zum Aussehen und zum Gewicht von Spielerinnen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es genau bei diesem Turnier war, aber eben Maren Meiner und eben in der U19. Das heißt, das hast du gar nicht so mitgelegt?
Nee, das nicht. Was bei mir so hängen geblieben ist, ist die, also Analysen waren immer sehr, sehr klar. Analyseformen, also wenn wir natürlich ein Spiel hatten und dann die ganzen Analyse-Themen hatten, dann gab es so Kategorien, das bei allen Spielerinnen hängen geblieben ist. Es gab eine Kategorie geht, geht nicht, geht gar nicht.
Also zwei Negativ-Kategorien schon mal, okay.
Und das war natürlich, also das ist, meine ich, also dieses, wie schaffst du eine Ebene von Feedback? Und das war halt ganz klar von oben nach unten, das war nicht auf Augenhöhe. Und das war so natürlich dann irgendwie auch so in der Mannschaft, dieses, okay, bloß bitte keine. Bloß bin ich hoffentlich nicht in dieser geht-gar-nicht-Kategorie.
Ach so wurden da ganze Spielerinnen einsortiert?
Ja, das teilt schon. Ich dachte, das werden Szenen gewesen. Also waren natürlich Szenen, aber natürlich war ja dann eine Position, die ging halt gar nicht. Kathi Henrich. Also so dieses, oh ja, Tabea Kemme. So, das ist schon, ja. Und da wolltest du nicht drin sein, so. Weil das war wie so eine Darstellung deiner Person und einfach Mund halten. Ja, ja, stimmt, ja, mach ich nicht mehr besser.
Ja, gut, aber das war ja dann wahrscheinlich auch kein Zufall, dass du einmal ausgewechselt wurdest zur Pause und dann nur noch.
Ja, klar. Also ich sag mal, jedes Verhalten hat auch noch Konsequenzen mit auch meinem Verhalten.
Ich meine, ich will das jetzt auch nicht demonisieren. Mir ist schon klar, dass das Leistungssport ist und da muss auch ein bisschen durchgegriffen werden. Aber ich habe mich ganz oft, ehrlicherweise, gefragt, jetzt wenn ich so mir Dinge durchgelesen habe, die du gemacht hast und Sachen, die du gesagt hast, dachte ich mir ganz oft, hätte es denn nicht auch einen anderen Weg gegeben.
Immer. Ich finde, es gibt ja immer andere Wege. Also ich, was ich ja auch immer merke, so dieses und deswegen habe ich selber ja auch so Respekt vor dieser Position Trainerin und möchte noch überhaupt nicht in diesen, in dieses Szenario rein, weil einfach, ey, Key ist Kommunikation. So und da sehe ich ja selbst auch, weil ich das nicht wirklich gelernt habe in diesem Kosmos des Fußballs, sondern eher immer mit mir ausgemacht habe, jetzt erst mal über eigene Arbeit mit einer Kommunikationstherapeutin zu sagen, so okay, wie heißt denn das, bedürfnisorientierte Kommunikationen, Grenzen setzen, all diese Räder, die rolle ich ja jetzt erst, oder habe ich jetzt vor vier und fünf Jahren angefangen zu rollen. Und das Credo ist halt bedürfnisorientierte Kommunikation. Ich wurde halt im Fußball Deutschland nie gefragt, kein einziges Mal gefragt, Tabea, was brauchst du?
In deiner kompletten Karriere nicht?
Yes, ja. Ein, was sehr nahe kam, war der Trainerwechsel bei Tobine Potsdam, wo nach Bernd Schröder Matthias Rudolf war. Und da hat Matthias Rudolf in einem Gespräch mit mir geteilt, dass er mir gerne mal eine andere Position geben wollen würde, damit ich mal das, was vorher Tobine und Bernd Schröder war, loslassen kann. Also auch sehr, ja, und dieses so, und jetzt gestalte jetzt hier frei deinen Raum.
Da kam der Gymnasaalehrer raus.
Wirklich. Wirklich. Ja, voll. Also wirklich dieses pädagogische, und das hat sich auch voll bewährt. Also der hat quasi gar nicht gefragt, was ich brauche, sondern er wusste schon, was ich brauche. Das ist ja nochmal ein Level höher. Aber in England war er von Pep Montemonturo, wo ich das erste Mal gefragt habe. Nee, Pep hieß er gar nicht.
Doch, das war sein Spitzname.
Das war er, stimmt ja. Oh krass, das ist schon so weit weg. Ich kann meinen Namen nicht gut nennen.
Das geht mir ganz genauso. Deswegen traue ich mich gerade nicht den Vornamen, den ich im Kopf habe zu sagen, der er eigentlich hat. Aber später kommen wir dazu. War das damals für dich schlimm, dass die U19 da ausgeschieden ist? Weil natürlich für den DFB usw.
Nein, das war doch nicht die Situation, wo wir uns ja gar nicht für die WM qualifizieren müssen, für die U20 WM, weil die im eigenen Land war. Und somit waren wir qualifiziert. Damit hatten wir es auch wieder in der Tasche. Das war mein erster Gedanke.
Ich kann sagen, der DFB, hast du da was anderes gesehen, aber es ist ja kein DFB-Interview hier. Ich hätte hier sogar noch weitere Fragen, aber so langsam müssen wir mal in deine Karriere reinkommen. Also nächste Saison, Lira Alushi, damals noch Bayramay, wechselt von Duisburg nach Potsdam. Und wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, korrigiere mich bitte, hat das bei dir schon begonnen, dass du die Positionen gewechselt hast? Du warst vorher Offensivspielerin und jetzt ging es schon eigentlich los in deiner zweiten Saison, dass du ins Mittelfeld und später wirst du in irgendwann in der Abwehr landen.
Ja, offensiv denkende Außenverteidigerin war ich dann ja.
Und wie denkst du da jetzt im Nachhinein?
Ich liebe das, ich liebe das. Das fing ja auch, also diese Vielfältigkeit liebe ich ja. Sobald ich eine Position sehr lange spiele, langweilt mich das sehr schnell. Und was ich auch geliebt habe einfach oder was mir auch sehr schnell zum Vorteil wurde, war, dass ich, wenn ich unterschiedliche Positionen gespielt habe, dass ich genau weiß, wie andere Spielerinnen sich auf dieser Position bewegen, konnte ich zu meinem Vorteil machen, weil ich dementsprechend die Bälle schon spielen konnte. Oder auch beispielsweise im Verteidigen wusste ich, okay, Sechser defensiv denken verteidigt so, dann kann ich als offensiv denkender Ausbettender ein bisschen offensiver verteidigen.
Tabea, du musst Trainerin werden.
Ja, ja. Das Experten sein ist gerade noch......
ist nahe genug dran.
Ja, ist ja. Und auch nicht mit beiden Beinen drin. Ich mag ja auch ein bisschen die Unabhängigkeit.
Aber hat dir nicht das Tore schießen gefehlt? Das hat so ein überwältigendes Gefühl. In der Saison hast du dann nur noch ein Tor gemacht. Ja, gar nicht.
Auch gar nicht, weil selbst die Bälle, ich weiß noch die Bälle, wenn ich von der einen Seitenlinie den Diagonal komplett, ich konnte den halt komplett mit meinem Hebel aus dem Oberschenkel bzw. Beuger komplett auf die andere Seite schieben.
Das war ja gar nicht so viele.
Genau, deswegen, das war so, okay, ich wusste nur so, wenn der Ball mir so liegt, ich schieb den komplett rüber. Und das war ja auch schon so, merkte man ja auch im Stadion. Ich hab es ja auch geliebt, diese Dynamik im Stadion aufzunehmen. Das ist einfach ein reiner Tanz, wenn du die Resonanz aufgreifst und auch dementsprechend wieder spiegelst. So, wenn dann so eine Rauhen mit so einem Ball auch irgendwie, wenn es auch ein offensiver Ball wäre, dann so, äh, und dann merkst du das ja auch. Das war ja, und dann konnte ich das von hinten ja so mit, schon mit zelebrieren.
Okay.
War auch großartig.
Okay, ja, dann braucht man vielleicht wirklich den Torerfolg, nicht? Du wurdest da erst am dritten Spieltag eingewechselt und ich konnte nirgendwo finden, warum. Kannst du dich da dran noch erinnern?
Verletzungen kann das nur gewesen sein.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich hatte viel muskulär, immer muskulär zu kämpfen. Einfach wegen der Überbelastung.
Ja, eine Frage, die ich jetzt geskippt habe, wie hast du eigentlich regeneriert nach der U19-EM? Das ist...
Ähm, also dann war es ja immer die Absprache mit dem Klubtrainer, da habe ich dann oft noch verhandelt. Also ich übte mich sehr früh in Verhandlungen. Oder ich hatte auch immer das Commitment mit dem Arzt und dann war es mal eine Au, eine Krankschreibung.
Ah ja, okay. Also in der Liga lief es gut, gegen Bayern und Duisburg unentschieden gespielt, sonst alles gewonnen, eine Niederlage gab es gegen Frankfurt, sonst wäre es eine perfekte Saison gewesen. Natürlich, Frankfurt.
Ja, das war ein krasser Duell.
Da werden wir noch drüber sprechen. Und im Halbfinale des DFB-Pokals ging es dann gegen Duisburg mit 0 zu 1 verloren. Also wieder Duisburg, wieder in der DFB-Pokal.
Ja, da war ich dann auch... Das war nicht dein Wettbewerb. Nee, gar nicht. War auch okay.
Ich glaube, ich weiß auch, warum es okay war, denn wir haben noch nicht über die Champions League geredet.
Ach ja, die war ja auch krass.
Das war der erste Champions League Wettbewerb unter diesem Namen. Gegen Honka habt ihr gespielt in Finnland. Im Hinspiel wurdest du eingewechselt, im Rückspiel warst du Startelfen, wurdest ausgewechselt. Dann habt ihr Brönpi geschlagen, da warst du auch beides Mal in der Startelf. Ihr habt gegen Rohr in Norwegen gespielt. Da warst du im Hinspiel nur im Kader und wurdest eingewechselt im Rückspiel. Ich weiß nicht...
Auch Belastung war das, war alles auch. Genau, ja.
Und dann gab es da nämlich auch ein Halbfinale gegen Duisburg.
Hinspiel, ne?
Und ich weiß, dass das das ist, über das du viel, viel lieber sprichst. Denn du wurdest im Rückspiel, ihr hattet 0 zu 1 verloren im Hinspiel. Und im Rückspiel wurdest du eingewechselt, 60. direkt in der 62. Ein Weitschusstor zum 1 zu 0. Und so seid ihr ins Elfmeterschießen gekommen.
Stimmt, ey. Da wurde ich, glaube ich, für Corinna Schröder eingewechselt. Ja, das war, oh mein Gott, das war auch wieder so ein Moment so, warte mal, was passiert hier gerade?
Also als du das Tor geschossen hattest?
Ja, voll so dieses, okay, wer hat dieses Drehbuch geschrieben? So krass. Also ich habe immer so schnell irgendwie dieses, wenn man sich selbst mal eben kurz rausnimmt und mal von oben so guckt, so dieses, oh mein Gott, was passiert hier gerade? Ja.
Und ist das aber für dich normal? Also ich weiß von FußballspielerInnen, oft ist die erste Aktion so wichtig, egal ob jetzt quasi erste Aktion nach dem Anpfiff oder eben nach Einwechslung. Ich habe leider kein, ich habe das Tor gesehen, aber ich habe nicht quasi die kompletten, was hast du nach der Einwechslung gemacht? Ich weiß nicht, ob es deine erste Aktion war, aber ist das so typisch für dich, dass du dann auch sagst, gut, ich schieße jetzt halb mal und lande damit in einem Highlight-Reel?
Ach so, ja.
Ja, so war es ja.
Ja, stimmt, ne? Ich wusste eigentlich, dass, also, sobald irgendwie ein betretenes Platz ist, bin ich voll da. So, ich kann dann alles außen vor lassen und das ist diese, und das ist dieses Kompetitive, so dieses Spiel direkt zu lesen, die Situation zu lesen. Ich weiß, okay, Jenny Thies spielt den Ball. Ich sehe die Gegnerin, die guckt nur auf den Ball, deswegen habe ich Raum, weil sie mich nicht sieht. Das ist alles so dieses Gespür für diese Situation. Ich bin voll da, 100 Prozent. So und das trägt mich und dann natürlich auch mein Sicherheitspackage, dieses, okay, der erste Ball, den spiele ich sicher zur Mitspielerin. So, damit baue ich mir das dann quasi auf, um mich dann in diesen Flow reinzubringen.
Der Flow, das ist echt. Man kann ehrlicherweise manchmal an den Ergebnissen sehen, ob du im Flow warst oder nicht. Und dann versucht man es nachzulesen. Manchmal findet man eine Quelle, manchmal muss ich raten. Jetzt weiß ich aber, ihr seid ins Finale gekommen. Es gab ein Elfmeterschießen, du hast nicht geschossen.
Nein, da war ich noch die Kleine irgendwie. Ich hatte jetzt auch nicht das Gefühl, dass ich da diese Verantwortung nehmen muss. Ja, für mich war es klar die anderen Regeln. Ich habe ja im Spiel geregelt.
So, und dann geht es zum Champions League Finale nach Getafe.
Ja, das war auch heftig.
Wie war es?
Es war pompös. Das war so, was war ich da? Da war ich da 18.
Da warst du 18, genau.
Das war ja, und das war während dieser Abiturphase. Also es war dann auch wieder so geballtes Leben prallt aufeinander. Und was ich noch weiß, oh mein Gott, das war auch wieder so eine Special Vorbereitung, so ähnlich wie bei diesem 07 Pokalfinale, wo wir da extra auswärts schlafen. Das war diesmal, haben wir Spielerinnen ein DIN A4 Blatt bekommen in Folie. Wie sagt man das?
Laminiert?
Ja, ein laminiert.
Die deutscheste Form, ein Blatt auszuteilen. Ein Laminiert.
Ja.
Kann niemand mehr drin rumfolgieren.
Wirklich. Und da war dann der Kader von Lyon mit welchen Stärken.
Und ich dachte... Ich hoffe, die Stärken waren geht, geht nicht, geht gar nicht.
Ja guck mal, das weiß ich gar nicht. Ich hab mir einfach nicht durchgelesen. Nee, aber so dieses nicht angeguckt, so dieses sehr kurz müssen durchgelesen, aber es ging auch wieder durch, weil ich auch direkt dieses Verständnis hatte. Ja, sehr schön und gut so, aber ich schreibe mir lieber das Blatt auf und schreibe unsere Stärken drauf und vor allem auch mein. Also das, was ich kontrollieren kann, das sind meine Stärken, meine Fähigkeiten. Und mit dem Matchplan bin ich halt in dieses Spiel gegangen.
Und wann wusstest du da, dass du in der Startelf stehst?
Ich glaube, das wusste ich relativ früh, was ich auf jeden Fall richtig, was ich noch richtig weiß in der Vorbereitung ist. Und es war auch wieder, das war ja ein Spiel, was abends 20.15. Primetime und dann hast du den ganzen Tag Zeit.
Zieht sich.
Und das war so, okay, was machen wir jetzt? Und dann hat sich so eine geile Dynamik irgendwie entwickelt, weil dann haben wir einen Spaziergang gemacht, alle mit der Mannschaft. Und dann hatten wir irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht, warum wir da Basketball hatten. War da ein Basketballplatz und dann war es irgendwie aus so einer Dynamik heraus, dass wir hier Basketball spielen. Zwei Teams. Ja, wie machen wir denn das? Und dann hatten die einen hatten, weil ich so, ja komm, wir ziehen halt T-Shirt aus und dann sind wir die T-Shirt-Losen und die anderen, die halt das komplette T-Shirt an haben. So haben sich zwei Teams entwickelt. Und dann haben wir da so lange Basketball gezockt und haben so die Zeit verloren, bis es dann irgendwann mal hieß, ey, da ist heute Abend noch was. Und diese Dynamik, ich glaube, das ist so das, was bei mir noch so krass präsent ist. Mit der sind wir ins Spiel gegangen.
Und das hat bei Herrn Schröder dann aber zugelassen?
Der war nicht da.
Okay.
Der Physio war mit da und der Arzt. Und die wussten ja, also ich meine, das sind ja, wir sind ja so, die wissen ganz genau. Die halten uns den Rücken immer frei.
Die wissen auch immer am meisten in allen Vereinen. Wirklich? Das ist wirklich so. Du hast im Startelf gespielt, du hast schon in der 15. Minute eine gelbe Karte gesehen.
Ja, ich hatte gegen Lara Dickenmann gespielt, das weiß sie noch. Und die war über ihre Geschwindigkeit immer gekommen. Und da wusste ich, okay, die darf erst gar nicht Anlauf nehmen. Da muss ich stehen. Und dann war es halt immer die Situation, dass ich zu sehr gestanden habe.
Und trotzdem hast du es geschafft, bis in die 106. Minute noch zu spielen und ohne zweite gelbe Karte auszukommen.
Da musste ich raus, weil ich hatte, ich glaube, da hatte ich ein Doppel, fast ein halb Bänderes oder so. Das war die Phase, wo ich übelst lange Probleme hatte mit meinem Sprunggelenk.
Aber hast du dir im Spiel zugezogen? Nee, nee.
Aber schon davor.
Du bist schon vorher so reingegangen?
Ja, schon. Da hatte ich echt lange mit. Ich glaube, über ein Jahr hatte ich damit Probleme, weil ich halt in die Pause gemacht habe.
Ich meine, ich verstehe, du wolltest dann wahrscheinlich auch dieses Champions-League-Finale spielen, aber eigentlich ja nicht so ideal.
Nein, das war, dass ich ein halb Jahre Probleme mit diesem Sprunggelenk habe, weil ich nie das genutzt habe, irgendwie mal wirklich auszuregenerieren, wenn ich dann immer wieder Probleme gehabt habe. Und da ja natürlich war voll unverantwortlich, mir selbst gegenüber.
Und würdest du im Nachhinein sagen, dass auch die Physios Ärzte der Trainer unverantwortlich waren? Die wären ja die Einzigen gewesen, die dich hätten schützen können, weil du kannst es nicht erwarten, dass eine 18-Jährige in ihrem ersten Champions-League-Finale sagt, ich kann nicht spielen, zumindest nicht 90 Minuten.
Wir haben schon gut gedealt. Also Physio und auch Mannschaftsarzt, die waren da auch ein Potsdamer, waren schon immer meine Karriereretter. Ja, das haben wir schon immer echt gut gedeichselt und da war es natürlich auch deswegen auch meine Unverantwortlichkeit. Ich wusste ja auch, was ich mich da einlasse und das habe ich gesagt, okay, das nehme ich ja einfach jetzt be-linkt in Kauf. Was ich jetzt, was ich in der Rückschau sage, ist, okay, ich hätte mich einfach nochmal mehr aus dem Training nehmen können, aber da bin ich dann halt auch einfach mitgelaufen.
Ja, das ist vielleicht auch später als Kapitänin wäre das ein bisschen einfacher gewesen.
Ja, beziehungsweise habe ich, ich habe es ja dann irgendwann auch einfach gemacht. Einfach, das waren dann die Gewissenspisse, die mich da noch aufgehalten haben. Die waren mir dann aber auch irgendwann einfach egal.
Es war insofern auch hier in dem Spiel egal, weil es geht dann ins Elfmeterschießen, ich weiß nicht, wie gut es noch vor Augen hat.
Oh, das war, oh mein Gott.
Janiciz verschießt direkt den ersten Elfmeter. Anja Mittag verschießt dann den vierten. Lyon hätte zweimal dieses Elfmeterschießen dicht machen können, aber sie verschießen sowohl den vierten als auch den fünften. Und Kaszowsky trifft da zwischendurch auch, deswegen geht es dann weiter. Ab dann treffen alle Spielerinnen. Irgendwann tritt Anna Felicita Saarholz, die Torhüterin, selber an und verwandelt mit 17 Jahren ihren Versuch. Und als ihr dann letztlich die neunte Schützin von Leon verschießt, seid ihr die Siegzigerin.
Es gab kurz die Phase, ich weiß noch, ich stand neben Caro Schiewe, die hat ja dann bei Freiburg am Ende ihrer Karrierebeendet stand. Ich stand noch neben ihr und ich meinte nur so, haplatz2 ist auch toll. Das war schon so, dieses, weißt du, diese Akzeptanz. Und dann kam Anna Saarholz. Die ist, also ich meine, ich bin ja mit der großgewonnen. Ich war ja im Internat auf Etage 9, sie auf Etage 2. Die ist, boah, auch heute noch eine richtige Leaderin. Die zieht einfach voll durch und ist so vielen Konflikten damit ausgesetzt, was am Ende auch ihre Karriere bedeutete. Das ist schon heftig.
Kannst du da ins Detail gehen oder?
Ja, klar. Also es war nach der Phase, nach dem Champions-League-Finale, das war ja auch so dieses, okay, was passiert eigentlich? Das muss ja dein kleines jugendliches Gehirn erst mal verarbeiten. Und diese Verarbeitungszeit wurde dir nicht gegeben. Und sie hat da sehr konsequent dem DFB gegenüber kommuniziert. Das war auch U19 Zeit. Ich brauche eine Pause.
Ah, dann ist man raus beim DFB. Das darf man bis heute nicht.
Das war auch eine ganz verzwickte Situation, weil letztlich hatten wir dann in Potsdam noch, wurden wir noch zelebriert vom Oberbürgermeister in der Stadt. Da haben die Riesen mäßig was aufgebaut, richtig groß gefühlt ganz Potsdam war da. Und diese Bilder wurden gesehen. Und das war so dieses so, ja, aber sie feiert ja. Also es war ganz unschön war das alles.
Wahnsinn. Also sie hat drei Elfmeter gehalten, einen verwandelt und es muss ja dann. Es ging ja dann wahrscheinlich um die U 20 WM in Deutschland. Die hat dann nämlich danach stattgefunden.
Und das ist dann, weißt du, das ist so eine Situation. Deswegen meine ich auch so dieses Okay, inwiefern bleibst du dir deiner Linie auch treu? Und ich mache mal, wenn doch eigentlich Anna das so klar kommunizieren konnte, also ich brauche eine Pause, ich brauche mal kurz Raum für mich, um das alles mal eben ein bisschen zu setteln. Dann gebe ich dir die, weil ich weiß, welche Performance ich von dir erwarten kann, die du abrufst und sowas von Siehe-Champion-Finale, dann gebe ich dir, wenn du brauchst, eine Woche.
Ja, vor allem, also eigentlich müssen da doch alle Alarmglocken angehen, wenn jemand sagt, ich möchte nicht bei der U20 WM im eigenen Land jetzt sofort quasi ins Training einsteigen.
Ja, ja. Und deswegen meine ich halt, es gibt so einen Grad, wo ich mich dann teils auch frage, danke für nichts.
Wir kommen jetzt zum Danke für nichts. Beziehungsweise, nee, eigentlich noch nicht direkt. Also Mitte Juli geht es dann los. U20 WM in Deutschland und man muss dazu sagen, 2011 war ja dann die richtige WM, die Seniorinnen WM in Deutschland. Das heißt, es war auch irre aufgeladen, dieses ganze Turnier, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern. Die Trainerin war Wiedermaren Meinhardt. Das erste Spiel war gegen Costa Rica in Bochum für 24.000 ZuschauerInnen. Was ist noch die Anpfiffzeit?
Mittags, oder?
11.30 Uhr.
Das Stadion war voll.
Ja, das Stadion war voll. Ich glaube, es war auch Ferienzeit, wenn ich es richtig nachrechassiert habe. Es gab eine 15-minütige Eröffnungsfeier.
Oh, das war der Horror.
Witzig, weil danach wollte ich dich fragen, wie das war. Steffi Jones und Franz Beckenbauer haben euch begrüßt.
Das war der Horror, weil wir die ganze Zeit standen. Ich weiß, meine erste Aktion, die ich im Spiel hatte, weil ich kalt war, war Muskelfaseris.
Deswegen?
Ja, das ganze Turnier habe ich mit einer Bandage gespielt. Keine Ahnung, wie viele Spritzen ich mir in den Oberschenkel gejagt habe. Ich hatte sogar einen Bündelrest. Und das war so, danke für nichts, geil. Ich bin kalt.
Ja genau, du wurdest dann nämlich schon in der 21. Minute ausgewechselt. Und da war es aber schon deine erste Aktion, das heißt, du hast es noch versucht durchzuziehen.
Ja klar, das war ja voll im Flow.
Und das hat eben auch bedeutet, dass im Grunde große Teile des Turniers für dich dann vorbei waren?
Ich glaube, die komplette Vorrunde.
Genau, also ihr habt dann gegen Kolumbien gespielt, 3 zu 0, wieder in Bochum vor 16.000 ZuschauerInnen, diesmal um 18 Uhr, da wurdest du nicht eingesetzt. Hab gegen Frankreich gespielt, in Augsburg vor 26.000 ZuschauerInnen, wieder um 11 vor 30. Auch da hast du nicht gespielt. Und dann kommt das Viertelfinale gegen Nordkorea in Bochum um 18 Uhr, ordentliche Zeit. Und da hast du von Beginn angespielt und auch komplett durchgespielt.
Ja, ich weiß noch die ganze Vorrunde, was wir da an meinem Oberschenkel rum massiert haben und rum behandelt haben. Und das haben wir echt mit Maiken Birnbaum, die Physiotherapeutin und auch dem Doc Kasten, da haben wir echt wieder hingekriegt.
Weißt du noch, wie ihr gespielt habt gegen Nordkorea? Ihr wart ab der 54. Minute in Überzahl.
War das ein 4-0 oder so?
Ne, 2-0. Hat sich angefühlt wie ein 4-0.
Ja, irgendwie schon.
Ihr hattet einige Chancen. Das war wirklich so. Das findet man noch ganz gut. Highlights. Dann gab es eine Halbfinale gegen Südkorea in Bochum um 15.30 Uhr. Ich nenne die Anstoßzeiten einfach nur, weil ich es witzig in Anführungszeiten fand, wie unterschiedlich sie waren.
Anders einfach.
Das ist ja schon von der Vorbereitung her komplett anders, ob du um 11.30 Uhr oder um 18.30 Uhr spielst.
Ja, essenstechnisch war für mich immer. Bei mir war immer nur Essen und Schlafen das Thema. Wie kriege ich das organisiert? Da war mir der Rest egal.
Gut, das sind ja auch so die elementarsten Dinge. Also gegen Südkorea in Bochum wieder 5 zu 1 gewonnen. Du hast wieder komplett durchgespielt. Das war das Spiel, da erinnern sich vielleicht die Hörerinnen und Hörer noch, da gab es den Schwimmjubel vor der Bank. Generell war das die Zeit, in der immer gemeinsam jubelt wurde.
Voll schön. Da haben wir dann vorher schon, ich weiß ja auch noch, saßen wir noch so zusammen. Ich meine, man hängt ja die ganze Zeit miteinander ab. Und irgendwie hat sich das so herauskristallisiert. Und dann läuft Poppy und dann Svenny und dann immer vor der Trainerbank, beziehungsweise dann bei den Zuckern.
Ja genau, aber wenn es schief gegangen wäre, kann ich dir sagen, dann hättest du die Artikel gegeben, die haben sich schon mit Mule beschäftigt. Ist ja nicht. Ja, aber das zeigt, glaube ich, ganz gut nur, wie Sport, Journalismus, in Anführungszeichen, funktioniert.
Wie sie es nicht verstanden haben, ja.
Dann gab es das Finale gegen Nigeria in Bielefeld vor 25.000 ZuschauerInnen. 15 Uhr wurde angepfiffen und du standest wieder in der Startelf. Welche Erinnerungen hast du an diese Partie?
An die Partie selber gar nicht so viel. Ich glaube, ich krieg's nicht mehr ganz zusammen, aber war das eventuell, wo ich noch eine Vorlage gegeben hab für Alex Pop, die getroffen hat? Das weiß ich nicht mehr so genau, ob das das Spiel war?
Nee, das war es nicht. Alex Pop hat in 8 Minuten 1-0 gemacht. Dann gab es wieder einen gemeinsamen Tanz vor der Bank. Da warst du auf jeden Fall sehr aktiv, ein Foto von...
Ja, da kennst du Vollgas.
Man findet es auch auf YouTube noch. Ganz interessant, Marco Hagemann für EuroSport hat das kommentiert.
Mit dem arbeite ich ja jetzt quasi zusammen.
Deswegen hab ich es hier erwähnt. Dann ist aber das 2-0 erst in der 91. Minute gefallen nach einer Ecke. Die Meinung ging auseinander, ob es Kim Kulig war oder ein Eigentor. Ist ehrlich gesagt egal, weil damit hattet ihr den Titel. Ich hab mir noch rausgeschrieben, Tine Toine hat damals noch gesagt, Kim Kulig ist eine Mischung aus Renate, Lingor und Birgit Prinz. Das fand ich aber nur ein interessantes Zitat, weil ich da sehr lange drüber nachgedacht habe, was das eigentlich für eine Mischung ist.
Aber mit Renate habe ich nie mehr zusammen gespielt.
Aber wie war das damals?
Was ich noch weiß, ist, dass meine Familie vor Ort war, dass wir es gefeiert haben. Was ich noch weiß, ist, dass wir gefeiert haben auf jeden Fall. Und dass morgens, ich glaube um 8 Uhr, der Bus gegen unser Shuttle um für die Turbinenspielerin, um nach Österreich geshuttelt zu werden, ins Trainingslager für die Vorbereitung der Saison.
Am Tag nach dem Finale? Um 8 Uhr morgens? Bist du in diesem Bus eingestiegen?
Ich habe es gerade so geschafft.
Durch welchen der vier Eingänge soll ich denn rein in diesem Bus? Das ist schon hart.
Das war richtig hart. Also krass, das ist hängen geblieben. Das war echt knackig. Und wir waren ja noch da, Bianca Schmidt war mit am Start, das weiß ich auch noch. Und dann sind wir da in irgendwo in Österreich waren wir da immer, sind wir da angekommen und ich dachte mir so, okay, sorry, aber wer verlangt jetzt von mir irgendwie irgendwas? Dem gehe ich aber geschwind aus dem Weg.
Man muss es ja nochmal sagen, was für eine aufgeheizte Stimmung das damals war. Also in dem Team haben gespielt, Unterenbrin, Almohd Schult, Marina Hegerings, Sven-Jahut natürlich mal wieder, Turit Knark, Jennifer Maroschan, Alex Pop, die war auch damals so ein bisschen der Rising Star. Bei diesem Turnier Kim Kulik und Bianca Schmidt hast du gerade ja auch schon genannt und natürlich war die Stimmung auch deshalb so aufgeheizt, weil zum einen war es der Testlauf für die WM und der hat organisatorisch eigentlich gut geklappt, würde ich sagen. Das war großartig. Genau. Deswegen habe ich die Zuschauerinnen-Seine dazu genannt, um das zu verdeutlichen. Und gleichzeitig hat ja wahrscheinlich jede von euch im Hinterkopf immer wieder an diese WM2011 gedacht.
Ich gar nicht.
Gut, dass wir sprechen.
Also ich gar nicht, weil ich fühle es, also was soll hier gerade noch mehr kommen? Das war ein so geniales Turnier, ein Heimatturnier. Und ich dachte, das ist jetzt nur eine U20-WM, also was soll denn noch kommen? So das war meine Einstellung dazu. Und ich war ja eh sehr, von Zukunftsorientiertheit war ich sehr kurzlebig. Also ich war immer eigentlich im Hier und Jetzt und habe gar nicht weiter geguckt, weil ich das Daily-Business halt kenne, wie schnell man halt irgendwie mal raus ist und so. Deswegen habe ich da gar nicht hingeguckt.
Das war dir damals schon klar?
Ja voll.
Ja. Ja.
Ich habe ja auch links und rechts gesehen, wer wegpurzelt und bin ja selber auch viel weggepurzelt.
Ja, da werden wir gleich noch drüber reden. Es war ganz interessant, auch wie medial damals die Aufmerksamkeit sich verändert hat. Also eben über Alex Popp wurde wahnsinnig viel berichtet. Sie hat damals noch, vielleicht lustig, als sie gesehen hat, sie hat damals noch diesen Gubel gemacht.
Kannst du das noch erinnern?
Also sprich mit den Armen links und rechts, als würde sie gleich fliegen oder raven. Ich weiß nicht, was das genau sein sollte.
Sie hatten auch noch alle diese schwarz-rot-gold-Harband, das weiß ich auch noch so, das war auch die Phase.
Und ihr habt den Pokal von Sepp Blatter bekommen.
Ja gut, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Du standst auch ziemlich aurant, als du ihn bekommen habt, aber ein bisschen surreal war es eigentlich.
Das war mir immer nicht alles ganz koscher.
Und dann kommen wir aber in die nächste Saison. Also du musstest um 8 Uhr am nächsten Tag nach Österreich.
Das war wirklich heftig, ja.
Das ist auch heftig. Ich finde es aber gut, dass du das auch nochmal so miterzählst, weil es eben wirklich verdeutlicht, es gab keine Pausen. Und ja, es hat sich einiges verändert bei der Turbine. Es kamen vier Abwehrspielerinnen, also Löwenberg und Wesselie wurden hochgezogen. Deman und Kramer kamen aus der U17. Entzündung, die anderen beiden kamen von der SGS Essen. Zwei sind allerdings auch gegangen. Du hast dann, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, im Nationalteam schon links Verteidigerin gespielt. Das heißt, jetzt bist du quasi innerhalb von einer Saison von ganz vorne nach hinten gerutscht. Und ich wollte dich mal beispielhaft an der Saison eben mit denen wechseln fragen, wie verändert sich eigentlich eine Umkleidekabine, wenn es so viele Wechsel gibt?
Eigentlich war das immer sehr warmherzig alles. Also ich war, ich habe mich ja immer gefreut, immer dass neue Spielerinnen irgendwie kamen, waren immer direkt neue Connecting Points, irgendwie so Austausch, Dynamiken. Ich bin ja auch so reingewachsen bei Turbine-Potts, der Verschleiß war ja enorm. Und bin ja selber quasi auch von neu rein und man... Dann hat der dann auch immer so Dynamiken, irgendwie so ein bisschen Gruppen, da sind die Interessen, da sind die Interessen. Und bei mir, ich glaube, das merke ich auch immer, wenn ich jetzt mit Anja und Josie im Austausch bin, weil die sind ja quasi ja noch mal älter gewesen und waren wirklich in dieser Turbinedynamik und ich war ja eher immer von außen, weil ich hatte ja diese Sportschuldynamik. Ich war dann immer, also mein Freundeskreis im Potsdam ist, der ist heute noch, wir sind der Abiturjahrgang und der ist multisportiv, so das war mein Anker, ist mein Anker, das ist mein Fundament. Es war seltenst, dass ich immer eher so richtig, dass ich so deep im Turbine-Kreis war. Ich bin immer eher von außen gekommen.
Ja, das natürlich gut war, dann ist es auch weniger wichtig, wie sich die Umkleidung verändert.
Ja, voll, ja und deswegen war es immer irgendwie wieder eine Freude, irgendwie so, weil es immer ein neuer Austausch ja auch war.
Und jetzt sind wir aber in der Saison, 30.08.2010, das Spiel gegen den FFC Frankfurt. Es gibt einen falsch ausgeführten Einwurf.
Ja, stimmt.
Eine Frankfurterin, deswegen, ich glaube auch, dass Kerstin Garefrikas ihn falsch ausgeführt hat, aber weil die Freundin von dir, die das bei YouTube hochgeladen hat, erst später einsteigt mit ihrem Video, kann ich es nicht genau bestätigen, aber de facto ist es so, du willst den Einwurf ausführen, Kerstin Garefrikas steht einen halben Meter vor dir, du wirst ihr den Ball ins Gesicht, voll durchgezogen, ja. Siehst dafür rot, wirst vom Frankfurter Trainer Sven Kahlert geschubst, der sieht auch rot.
Stimmt noch. Es war hochdramatisch.
Genau. War auch ein Riesenthema. Also auch das war auch wirklich interessant, auch ein bisschen ernüchternd bei der Recherche, welche Spiele deiner Karriere haben ein überregionales Medien-Echo gehabt? Das Spiel war mit dabei.
Das ist auch, ja, das ist richtig, das ist mehr hängen geblieben, wie die Trophäen. Kemme trifft, muss man eingeben bei YouTube, dann findet man das.
Echt?
Ja, voll. Das war, ich wurde in der Schule, das war nächsten Tag bin ich in der Schule gewesen, am Montag. Das hing dann schon, wir hatten so einen Live-Ticker und da war schon das erste Paper hier aus der Zeitung, war schon direkt angepinnt. Und dann war so, ja, Kemme, also, boah, das war auch alles so schnell und dann auch dieses, ich weiß die Situation noch, dieses, was passiert ist. Ich weiß, wieso, sind ganz, so alles verschwommen und dann kommen aber so gewisse Dinge zusammen. Das finde ich auch so krass, weil in dem Moment, ich meine, das ist meine einzige rote Karte. Ich war weder irgendwie gelb-rot, ich habe einen sehr klaren, zweikampfbetonten Stil gefahren in meiner Karriere und habe dafür sehr wenig gelbe Karten gekriegt. Und wenn ich die gelbe gekriegt habe, wusste ich auch direkt, hier war ich halt die hundertstel zu spät und habe es auch direkt gemerkt. Und dann auch die so, ey Kemme, was ist da jetzt passiert? Was ist da aus dem Ruder gelaufen? Und das hat mir so viel gelehrt, weil was passiert ist, ist in dieser Situation, dass der Ball ja ans Aus ging und dann war das bei uns immer eine Anleitung, okay nutze das und mach den Einwurf so schnell wie möglich, um dir einen Vorteil zu erhaschen. Und dann, das war ja an der Seitenbank von uns, und da war Co-Trainer, ja wirf schnell, wirf schnell, gab Ball und ich sehe Lira noch tief laufen und werf. Und ich sehe Kerstin, ich habe sie gesehen und mit dem, dass ich checke, sie steht da, geht der Ball von meinen Händen weg. Und dann ist der Rest das, was passiert. Und dann war es ja so schnell, da schubs er, da Jenny Zietz kommt gleich, mir war klar, ich kriege eine rote, es ist alles nur noch so Wahrnehmung. Dann sehe ich unsere Team-Managerin Afadit Depotvorica. Sie nimmt mich einfach nur, sagt, geh in die Kabine, geh duschen. Ich geh hoch und dusche erst mal. Und dann so, okay, krass. Okay, und ich wusste, okay, das ist jetzt ein Ding, damit hast du dich jetzt auseinanderzusetzen, weil das wird Thema sein.
Ja, aber weißt du, was ich krass finde daran? Also, es ist eine klare rote Karte und so weiter und so fort. Du wurdest danach für eigentlich sechs Spiele gesperrt. Ben Schröder hat ein gutes Wort eingelegt. So wurden es vier Spiele sperre. Aber was ich wirklich interessant fand in der Rückschau nochmal war, die Artikel, die ich gesehen habe, da ging es immer um dich. Du hast Kassin Garif-Richtlis abgeworfen und dann wurdest du noch geschubst. Ich finde aber ehrlich gesagt, dass der Trainer eine gegnerische Spielerin schubst, viel krasser ehrlicherweise als das andere, was da passiert ist.
Ja, weil das ein Eingreifen eines außenstehender Personen ist.
Und er muss drüber stehen. Er hat auch eine Verantwortung, eine Vorbildfunktion und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, und dann flogen ja noch von den Fans, da waren die die Trommler ja dahinten flogen, noch die Trommlerstöcke da entgegen. Es war hoch aufgeladen und das, was ich daraus mitnehme und das hatte ich auch sehr, das hatte ich während ich war ja alleine in dieser Umkleidekabine. So ich hatte wirklich für mich immer kurzzeitig standen, um es länger unter der Dusche und war so, ey, was nehme ich jetzt daraus mit? So und es war für mich direkt glasklar, so okay, dieses, ich hatte das Gefühl, in dem Moment bin ich fremd gesteuert. Ich steuer nicht das Spiel, ich steuer nicht meine Handlungen. So und das möchte ich ändern. Ich entscheide hier und nicht dieses Würgeschrei von der Bank, die es macht.
Du musst dich schnell ausführen.
Genau, sondern ich bin Frau und Haupt ist diese Handlung, die ich hier fortführe und das hat mich ja auch geprägt, wie sonst was. Das weiß ich auch noch. Nächsten Morgen eine Kanutin, die war auf dem Weg nach Florida ins Trainingslager, die schickte mir nur noch ein Bild von der, ich glaube, das war die Bildzeitung, die da am Flughafen ausliegt. Da war ich auf Michael Ballack, war irgendwie ganz groß in einem Portrait. Und dann gab es so ein Artikel mit der Szene, die in vier Schritten halt gezeigt wurde. Und was am Ende des Tages da passiert ist, dass ich mit Michael Ballack zusammen gearbeitet habe. Also es ist ja auch so, weißt du, wie sich sowas wiederfindet.
Ja, also wirklich verrückt. Und das war eben auch die erste Montrohung, also das, worüber wir gesprochen haben. Das kam ja alles dann danach. Es war eine krasse Saison. Das Spiel ging dann trotzdem noch mit 2-2 1 aus in Unterzahlen gegen den FFC. Das war schon die zweite Niederlage für den FFC. Auch deshalb sind die, obwohl sie wirklich die Liga zerschossen haben, mit 103 zu 16 Toren sind sie Zweiter geworden. Meister ist die Turbine geworden. Im Rückspiel allerdings gab es ein 1 zu 4. Also diese Duelle gegen den FFC.
Die waren auch immer toll.
Außer vielleicht dann das, was ist noch das dritte Duell dieser Saison. Du erinnerst dich, im DFB-Pokal. Es ging wieder ins Finale. Jetzt sind wir in Köln vor 20.000 ZuschauerInnen. Ich kürze das jetzt ein bisschen ab. Letztlich verliert die Turbine 1 zu 2. Es gab aber ein reguläres Tor zum 2 zu 2. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das daran erinnern kann. Das weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe es schon akzeptiert.
Ich lese dir mal vor, was Nadine Angerer dazu gesagt hat. Man muss sie auch wirklich lieben für ihre Offenheit. Lässt sie sich zitieren in den Zeitungen dazu mit Ich lag am Boden, als der Pfiff erntönte und ich dachte Gott sei Dank. Wenn du als Torwart so ein Gefühl hast, weißt du, dass etwas nicht stimmt. Ich denke, dass es ein reguläres Tor war. Nach Ansicht der Bilder kann ich bestätigen, liebe Nadine Angerer, ich sehe da auch überhaupt nicht, warum er abgepfiffen wurde. Aber sie haben deswegen den DFB-Pokal geholt. Was war denn das damals mit dieser Rivalität mit dem FFC? Also Nadine Angerer habe ich genannt, Saskia Batusiak hat da gespielt, Ariane Hings, Melanie Behringer, Kerstin Garifrikas, Jennifer Maroschan dann natürlich irgendwann auch, Julia Smisek, Birgit Prinz von allen. Und das waren immer besondere Spiele, aber auch in dieser Konstellation.
Ja, das war von außen sehr viel drauf gemacht. Für mich war das so ähnlich, wie ich auf Nationalmannschaftsebene die Spiele gegen die USA geliebt habe. So waren das die Turbidenspiele gegen Frankfurt. Das waren halt einfach High-Performance-Spiele. Das war auch, wo es wirklich drauf ankam, dass jede Spielerin individuell high performt. Weil sonst, wenn eine Spielerin es nicht hinhaut, dann hast du oft das Nachsehen gehabt in diesen Spielen.
Und wie empfindest du das jetzt so in der Rückschau, dass das auch so ein überreiztes Klima war manchmal?
Empfand ich ja selbst gar nicht so. Das war eher so wirklich die, das von außen, ich meine, das war ja dann auch so Bernd Schröder, Sigrid D. Also es war ja auch so...
Die beiden großen Männer.
Ja, genau. Und es wurde ja, wie oft das ja quasi auch immer aufgehangen wurde, auch medial. Also es war ganz viel, ganz viele Schauplätze, die im Außen gemacht worden sind. Ich als Spielerin hab das immer gar nicht so gesehen. Ich wusste halt natürlich, dass die Spiele sind, wo du die Meisterschaft oft entscheidest. Wo zumindest die drei Punkte am Ende des Tages entscheiden sind.
Ja, und ich meine, jetzt im Nachhinein, jetzt wo du als Expertin unterwegs bist, siehst du ja auch, glaube ich, noch mehr auch noch den medialen Blick. Es lässt sich halt so viel einfacher erzählen. Hier die große Mannschaft, da die große Mannschaft, hier der große Übervater von Frankfurt und der von Turbine. Und dann auf Spielerinnen-Ebene kannst du es auch runterziehen.
Ja, und das stimmt ein. Das waren auch, wenn ich jetzt überlege so, das war ja noch Schulzeit, so dieses Aya. Es wurde da dann auch, es lief dann auch beim Live-Ticker durch, so Heya, Top-Spiel und so. Ja, die Aufmerksamkeit war schon eine andere, das stimmt ja. Auch rein von medialen Anfragen. Also der Impact für mich als Spielerin war größer im Sinne von Arbeitszeit. Das war aber auch krass, weil nach dem Spiel, wo ich die rote Karte ja gekriegt habe, gegen Kerstin Garifrikes, das war ein Sonntag. Am Montag, das Thema war ja meine erste Nationalmannschaftseinladung kam ja. Und dann wusste ich so, okay, das ist ja, das war eine Woche. Und ich so, am Montag bin ich noch zum Co-Trainerin, ob ich die Teto-Fo-Nummer, ob er die hätte von Kerstin, dass ich sie vorher, bevor ich zur Nationalmannschaft dann anreise, zumindest dass ich mich entschuldigt habe bei ihr, so und dann habe ich da noch angerufen, war auch ein total nettes Gespräch. Kerstin ist die, die sich am Wochenende den Ball ins Gesicht geworfen hat. Ja, und dann haben wir das quasi einmal telefonisch geklärt gehabt und wurde dann ja, also war eingeladen bei der NACIO. Und im Nachgang Jahre später habe ich von einer Teammanagerin erfahren, dass es tatsächlich Thema war, mich aufgrund der Aktion nicht einzuladen. Und deswegen auch so dieses, was mir ja dann auch immer wieder zeigt, okay, wenn irgendwie eine Handlung war nicht geil, so geh in Kommunikation, klär das direkt.
Ja, muss man aber halt auch mutig genug für sein.
Ja, und das ist natürlich dann die Erziehung auch. Ich merke schon, wenn ich irgendwo Bockmiss gebaut habe, so da muss ich dann halt auch echt für gerade stehen.
Man spürt es ja eigentlich schon immer.
Irgendwie schon.
Die Bundesliga war im März schon vorbei wegen der Heim-WM, aber die Champions League lief noch im normalen Rhythmus weiter. Es gab wieder eine Halbfinale gegen Duisburg, aber diesmal ohne Elfmeterschießen wurde das gewonnen. Es ging wieder ins Finale gegen Lyon im Craven Cottage in London war das. Und es gab dann noch einen Bundesliga Cup, der zur Überbrückung ausgetragen wurde. Kannst du dich an den noch erinnern?
Der war wahrscheinlich war mir auch so unnötig.
Die Frage war, ob der Bundesliga Cup sinnvoll ist. Der war nämlich witzigerweise quasi, also der sollte quasi sein für die Nationalspielerinnen und auch für die Vereine, aber vor allem für die Nationalspielerinnen, dass die nochmal in Wettkampfstrukturen reinkommen vor der WM. Deswegen habt ihr das Finale wurde in 30 Minuten Halbzeiten ausgetragen in Ingolstadt. Ich glaube, ihr habt es gegen Bayern verloren, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere.
Das ist nicht mehr andersweise auf meiner Festplatte.
Du hast nichts. Ja, es war in Ingolstadt, aber es gab eben dann das Finale gegen Lyon. Ich möchte dir mal ein Zitat aus dem Spielbericht dazu aus der Zeit vorlesen. Potsdams Spielanlage kommt dem Ideal des englischen Fußballs recht nahe. Offenes Visier, keine Ballschiebereien im Mittelfeld, stattdessen lange und hoch und hinterher. Auch engagiert geführte Kopferduelle und humorlose Grätschen, notfalls auch ohne große Lust auf den Ball, gehören zum Repertoire. Offene Münde in Fulham, kein Spiel für zarte Männer.
Das ist schon hart diskriminierend. Zarte Männer.
Ich meine, es war aus der Haltung geschrieben, guck mal, auch Frauen, selbst Männer, denen wäre das zu hart. Aber allein, dass ich es jetzt schon so formuliert habe, zeigt, ich habe quasi die Diskriminierung wiederholt.
So bin ich auch groß geworden. Aber ich habe so harte Störgefühle gerade dabei.
Deswegen wollte ich es dir vorlesen und ich wollte es nämlich gerne abgleichen. Also ich wollte das jetzt hier nur deshalb reinbringen, dass du jetzt gerne mal deine Perspektive auf dieses Finale...
Ich war 2-0 hatten verloren, glaube ich. Ich weiß auf jeden Fall, wir waren nicht griffig. Das habe ich direkt gemerkt, so dieses, okay, weil mal irgendwas ist hier gerade... Wir kommen nicht so richtig ins Spiel, wir laufen nur hinterher und die waren ja auch... Geschwindigkeit haben uns echt ganz schön doll ausgespielt. Und tatsächlich war das auch eine Spielanlage von uns, zu sagen so, okay, wir überspielen das Mittelfeld. Also es waren viele lange Bälle. Das kann ich nur bestätigen. Und zwar, wir haben halt versucht, über den Kampf reinzukommen. Keine Chance gehabt, ja. War dann... Auch danach, weiß ich noch, die ist so, ja, das ist auch einfach verdient verloren. So, das ist jetzt, akzeptiere ich es so. Passt doch halt nicht.
Und wie war das dann danach? Wie konnten die großen Männer im Verein bei Turbine mit so einer Niederlage umgehen?
Das habe ich immer hart ignoriert.
Ich wünschte, ich hätte deine Scheuklappen gehabt in dem Alter, in dem du dich da doch befunden hast.
Das ist aber auch, also wenn ich das so in der Rückschau sehe, einfach über Lebensmechanismus, ne? Dass ich mir da auch einfach nicht zu viel zu Herzen genommen habe. Ich meine, mir war relativ früh klar so, ich bin da ja mit 16 hoch und es ging ja schnurstracks nach oben und je höher, desto krasser ist auch die Fallhöhe. Da war eigentlich er immer so, wo ich den sehr aufmerksam auch noch mal war, wenn es halt nicht gut lief, auf wen kann ich mich verlassen und auf die obere Riege konnte ich mich halt nie verlassen. Dann haben die ihr Ding gemacht, so fair enough. Aber das ist ja dann immer das Ding, wie bringe ich mich wieder in Form, beziehungsweise wie als Mannschaft. Oh, und da waren, ich meine, die Phase, wo ich Kapitänin geworden bin, haben wir ja noch nicht, ne?
Nee, die kommt doch.
Da kommen noch einige Dinge, ja.
Du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, es ging immer für dich nach oben. Und jetzt kommt aber die erste klar sichtbare Delle, nämlich die WM 2011 in Deutschland, begleitet von irren Sorgen. Also ich habe noch ein Zitat gelesen von Hannelore Ratzeburg. Da wurde sie gefragt, warum waren in meinem DFB-Pokalfinale nicht so viele Zuschauerinnen, hat sie gesagt, ja, es gab ja auch zwei Demonstrationen in Köln. Vielleicht hatten die Leute Angst vor Ausschreitungen. Das waren irgendwelche Anti-Atomkraftdemonstrationen. Also weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich das gelten lassen würde. Aber das zeigt schon, wie nervös damals die Situation war.
Wahnsinn, ne?
Und du kannst dich ja wahrscheinlich auch noch erinnern an die an die Werbekampagne des ZDF damals. Dritte Plätze sind was für Männer, die ja fürchterlich den Frauen auf die Füße gefallen. Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr so genau. Wo du so unsicher bist, werde ich auch unsicher. Ich glaube, das war 2011.
Du, ich hab da einfach, mein Hirn ist da nicht mehr so drin.
Also ich mach's kurz. Trainerin, was sie wieder neigt. Letztlich ist Deutschland ja dann im Viertelfinale gegen Japan ausgeschieden. Die große Frage, spielt Alex Popp oder spielt sie nicht, war damals so ein Ding. Auch weil Alex Popp gesagt hat, ja ich würde eigentlich schon ganz gerne spielen. Und ich weiß noch, wie damals dann die Medien so, es gibt es ja nicht. Es stellt Ansprüche, was ist denn mit Birgit Prinz? Aber wenn wir jetzt auf die Rolle von dir zurückkommen, dann hast du sie selber beschrieben als Fan Girl, denn du warst eben nicht mit dabei.
Wie war das für dich? Voll okay. Also ich mein, dass die Schnelligkeit, wie mein Leben im Fußball war, wusste ich ja auch drum, irgendwo bremste ich halt immer was aus. Was auch im Nachhinein ist, ist auch völlig okay gewesen, weil das war meine Pause. Ich hätte ja vorher nie eine Pause gehabt.
Naja, also wenn ich es richtig sehe, dann hast du da Abi geschrieben in dem Sommer.
Ja gut, das ist ja...
Aber ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Und was ich aber noch weiß, ist, dass ich zur Eröffnungsfeier, ich wurde vorher angefragt, ob ich nicht vor Ort bin. Und es gab ja diese Riesenzeremonie, da war ja dieser riesen Ball im Olympiastadion und den musste man anschießen. Das hat in dem Fall Inka Wesely gemacht, Turbinespielerin. Und dann ist quasi diese Weltkugel so entzogen worden. Und da war da ein Fußball. Und da hatte mich mein Mann mich gefragt, aber ich bin zu meinen Eltern zu Hause gefahren.
Du wolltest nicht vor 70.000 ZuschauerInnen im ausverkauften Olympiastadion das...
Nee, irgendwie war so, ich fahre jetzt nach Hause. Ich wollte einfach nach Hause. Ich wollte Ruhe und habe das dann zu Hause im Fernsehen geguckt. Da war ich auch sehr konsequent oft.
Ja, das zieht sich ja sowieso durch dieses Gespräch. Aber warum glaubst du, also du hast zwar gesagt, es war okay, dass du nicht mit dabei warst, aber warum warst du denn nicht mit dabei?
Das kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen. Ich glaube, kommuniziert wurde mir da gar nicht. Ich war einfach bei den Lehrgängen auch nicht dabei. Das war ja das auch. Im Nachhinein, wenn ich auch höre, was die für eine Vorbereitung gemacht haben, also sechs Wochen eine knallharte Vorbereitung, wo ich mir auch denke, um Gottes Willen, eigentlich war ich nicht dabei. Weil die hatten da schon ganz schön Lagerkoller, das weiß ich noch. Oder das habe ich jetzt im Nachhinein, wenn man jetzt so mit Anja und Josi auch quatscht oder so nochmal Revue passieren lässt, so wie wir das jetzt machen. Eigentlich waren die in der Vorbereitung schon stehen ko und das Training ging noch gar nicht los. Aber ja, nichts verpasst.
Ja, das hat man, also das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen sehr detailliert, aber es gab die eine Schusschance für Inka Grins, ich glaube in der ersten Hälfte der Verlängerung. Den macht sie in neun von zehn Fällen, aber der Schuss war so kraftlos, dass ich mir damals auch gedacht habe.
Was eher voll. Ich weiß aber um den Drive, das weiß ich noch so, das war halt mega cool. Also was da in Deutschland noch passiert war. Und ich kam ja von U20 WM, so gefühlt hatte ich die WM ja schon gespielt. Und irgendwie hatte ich auch das Vertrauen darin. Ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch selbst jetzt in der Rückschau nicht so, die so, ja ich war halt nicht dabei, fair enough. Weil ich wusste ja irgendwie so, das ist ja, ich meine, ich war da 18 und habe gerade irgendwie versucht, mal mein Abitur unter 3-0 zu bringen. 2-9 war es.
Natürlich hast du das geschafft. Ja genau. Lass mich raten, du hast es konsequent erreicht. Richtig.
Ja, mit Hilfe der Lehrer und Lehrerin. Und dann hatte ich glaube ich einfach mal Urlaub. Ich hatte einfach mal frei und das war so geil.
Und dann geht es in die Saison 2011-2012. Nadine Kessler und Josie Henning gehen zu Wolfsburg. Entschuldigung, Lyra Bayramay. Damals glaube ich noch.
Da war noch Bayramay.
Noch Bayramay zum FFC Frankfurt. Und ab Winter auch an ihr Mittag nach Schweden. Dann hätte die MBHK ab da Remote machen müssen.
Ja stimmt eigentlich so. Da hatten wir tatsächlich noch gar nicht so viel miteinander zu tun. Weil ich war ja auch, wie gesagt, ich hatte ja dann Abitur fertig. Weil ich halt echt so eher eine Sportschulklicke war. Ich war auch, weißt du, wenn immer irgendwie wieder was los ist, ist ja oft so, hast du das schon gehört? Ich habe ja nie was gehört, was wieder eben passiert war. Ich war immer so, ich war absolut nicht im Game.
Du musst nicht immer nachher…
Ich habe nichts verpasst, also es wird mir auch immer wieder gefeedbackt, aber du hast da nichts verpasst. Dann war ich auf der richtigen Spur auf jeden Fall unterwegs.
Es kam damals an, Katrin Berger aus Sindelfingen und Sandra Starke aus der Jugend wurde hochgezogen. Und es ist das undenkbare, nicht ganz undenkbare passiert, aber du wurdest in den EM-Kader berufen für das Spiel gegen Rumänien, aber nicht eingesetzt. Und nach allem, was ich gelesen habe, warst du vier Tage später dann gegen Schweden, hier am Millantor, nicht im Kader.
Nee. Das war auch dieses... Aber warum? Ich war drei Jahre, aber ich hatte sie mich nicht spielen lassen.
Ja, aber du warst ja für das Spiel auswärts in Rumänien.
Ja, aber es war ein 23er-Kader und es wurden vielleicht 21 im Trainingskader und 21 durften halt nur nominiert werden. Und dann saßen die anderen zwei auf der Tribüne und ich saß da auf der Tribüne hier im Millantor. Ja, das war eine knackige Zeit im Sinne von Ausdauerbeweisen. Das war ein Punkt so ein bisschen, weil es war teils so, wenn Spielerinnen in die Nähe von zu Hause kommen, so dieses und war ja bei mir Hamburg, so dieses ich komme nach Hause. Da war ich auch einmal kurz, es war ein kurzer Moment, wo ich mir dachte so, na gut, soll nicht sein.
Aber muss ich dich fragen, doch, ich will dich fragen, wie war die Feedback-Kultur?
Zero. Es war auch so ein, ich meine da prallen ja auch einfach zwei Charaktere aufeinander, also in dem Fall Coaching-Team, also Sylvia Knight und du quasi. Genau, so dieses und dann meinen sehr klaren Weg und auch konsequenten Weg. Und das passt halt nicht immer in die Philosophie des Stuff-Teams oder jetzt in dem Fall Sylvia Knight natürlich so. Und es war dennoch aber irgendwie so, wir haben nicht drüber geredet. So, das war, ich habe meinen Schuh durchgezogen, sie hat ihren Schuh durchgezogen und ich hatte das Vertrauen in mir. Es wird dieser Punkt kommen. Ich bleibe in meiner Leistung und irgendwann ist kein Weg dran vorbei. Und das hat sich nach drei Jahren hat sich das begehrt.
Ja, da kommen wir bald hin. Ich versuche mal ein bisschen abzukürzen. Also du warst dann auch im Oktober 2011 und im Februar 2012 nicht im Kader der Turbine. Da geht es eben weiter mit eben Verletzungen, die du immer wieder hast. Nach dem Viertelfinale in der Champions League gegen Rossi Anker hast du zum Beispiel gar nicht mehr gespielt. Da ist dann Potsdam im Halbfinale gegen Lyon ausgeschieden.
Da hat man die Schulter kaputt gemacht.
Exakt. Ich sage noch kurz, wie es für die Turbine weiterging. Im Viertelfinale war gegen den FFC Frankfurt wieder Schluss im DFB-Pokal. Aber die Turbine ist wieder Meister geworden. Und du hattest dann eben aber die Operation an der Schulter. Und ich habe mir dann die Frage gestellt, ob das eigentlich jetzt deine erste längere Verletzung war oder ob man das so gar nicht sagen kann, weil du ja vorher schon so lange eine Dauerverletzung mit dir rumgeschleppt hast.
Nee, das war schon die erste operative Verletzung. Schultergelenksprengung, auch selbst verschuldet im Sinne von, weil ich habe mit dem gebrochenen Ellbogen gespielt.
Wusstest du, dass er gebrochen ist?
Ja, das wusste ich schon. Wir haben sogar ein Bild machen lassen, der war gebrochen. Eine Ellbogenfraktur. Und dann habe ich mir ja den Ellbogen quasi eingipseln lassen, von Handgelenk bis knapp unter die Schulter und dann ein Luftduell entgegengen. Ja, ich habe mich zu eng abgerollt und habe die Schulter gesprengt. Ja, intensiv gelebt, würde ich sagen.
Wie war damals, also wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2012, wie war damals so Reha-Maßnahmen und so weiter bei Turbini Organisieren?
Tatsächlich hatten wir da wirklich, also deswegen eine Mannschaftsarzt, der war mit Stützpunkt in Berlin, hatten wir einen sehr engen Draht. Also heute passiert, morgen schon immer Tee, sowas war schon mal richtig gut. Ja, und Physio war auch richtig gut immer. Das ist ja, Physio ist ja auch immer so eine Position im Verein. Die werden ja auch gnadenlos ausgenutzt. Die werden so schlecht entlohnt. Und die haben einfach ihr Herz auf der richtigen Seite und geben alles für dich und ja, und sehr vertrautes, enges Zusammenarbeiten immer.
Und hast du in der Phase, weil das war jetzt zum zweiten Mal, dass du zwangsweise weg vom Fußball warst. Einmal war es eben nicht Nominierung für die WM 2011, aber da hattest du ja noch Abi. Und nach dem Abi beginnt ja eigentlich die geile Zeit. Also man fühlt sich ja nie so frei wie im Sommer nach dem Abi. Den hattest du 2011. Hast du dich dann noch mal neu kennengelernt? Oder war das alles so geprägt? Weil Reha ist ja auch unheimlich durchgetaktet und du hast ja da auch wahnsinnig viel zu tun gehabt.
Ja, oft wird dir immer gedacht, ja, du hast jetzt Reha, jetzt kannst du, hast ja mehr Zeit.
Das Gegenteil.
Ja, man hat weniger. Weil du einfach viel individueller arbeitest. Das hat mir tatsächlich richtig Spaß gemacht. Auch wirklich mal individuell wirklich zu arbeiten. Du siehst den Fortschritt, du hast deinen Plan mit, was ist jetzt der Stand, die Einschränkung. Dann haben wir, du kriegst so einen 8-Wochen-Plan. Dann wollen wir so viel Grad, halt Beweglichkeit. Das war mega geil, weil das hat mir vorher auf dem Fußball, hatte ich das ja auch nicht. Haben wir jetzt teils auch nicht. Und diese individuelle Arbeit einfach mit mir und auch einfach, ich meine, das war in dem Berufsfindungsjahr. Also ich hatte ja ein Jahr, ich wollte ja unbedingt zur Polizei. Das wäre aber in den normalen Studiengang nicht gegangen. Und dann habe ich ein Jahr warten müssen. Und das Jahr war genau deswegen, da hatte ich total schön Zeit für mich und die Reha und einfach auch mal die Dinge ein bisschen langsamer anlaufen zu lassen.
Wir kommen in die Saison 12, 13 rein. Da gehen Viola Odebrecht, Babette Peter und Sandra Starke, die ist dann schon wieder weg. Es kommt eine gewisse Sarah Dorsun und Andrín Hegerberg, die ihre 16 Jahre alte Schwester mitbringt, Ada Hegerberg.
Ja, das war auch cool.
War das Talent von ihr damals schon zu sehen?
Ja, voll. Also ihr Auftreten vor allem, ihre Präsenz.
Echt, mit 16 schon?
Ja, das war schon echt krass. Ihre Dynamik, ihre Athletik, ihr Drive, auch ihr mentaler Drive. Da war so, ok, Ada, yes, du bist eine Skorrin, alles klar, sehe ich, fühle ich, ich schicke dich.
Aber wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, hat ja Andrín erst mal mehr gespielt als Ada.
Ja, ja, ja. Das war auch eine Entwicklung. Es war ja auch erstmal kommt natürlich der Trainer, der auch immer so, ja, ja, trainier erst mal, beweist mir das im Training und dann gucken wir mal. Das sind ja dann auch solche Dynamiken.
Ja, ok, ja, ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Wo getestet wird.
Ich habe mich gefragt, was wurde euch denn gespiegelt von Spielerinnen wie eben den Hegerbergs zum Beispiel, die eben aus einer anderen Fußballkultur, in dem Fall auch aus einem anderen Land, zur Turbine kommen. Was wurde euch gespiegelt bezüglich wie trainiert wurde, wie das Ganze angegangen wurde?
Wie bescheuert seid ihr denn? Aus dem bescheuert, wie seid ihr denn, wurde ein, wie bescheuert sind wir denn? Weil sie jetzt Teil dessen waren. Und weil du ja dann auch so eine Dynamik entwickelst, so dieses, ok, wir stehen das irgendwie durch, irgendwie schaffen wir das zusammen. Dann gehst du echt zusammen da durch. Das war, glaube ich, so das, was einen immer daran gehalten hat.
Aber wie bescheuert seid ihr denn, weil es einfach zu sehr drüber war im Körper?
Voll, ich meine alleine, wenn wir da drei Mal am Tag trainiert haben, da hatten wir eine Mittagspause, da wurde uns Mittagessen gegeben. Und wir haben unser Mittagessen timen müssen, wie viel ich jetzt esse, weil ich danach Läufe mache, und nicht, dass ich auf die Laufbahn kotze. So muss man sich das ja vorstellen. Und jetzt, wenn man das in der Rückschau ja auch sieht, oder ich treffe ja dann auch die Spielerin auch immer, dann ist man so, mein Gott, was hat man damals eigentlich gemacht? Aber irgendwie war es ja eine geile Zeit, weil man hatte ja sich zusammen und auch den Erfolg. Du wusstest, wofür du es tust.
Bei der Bundeswehr schaffst du so auch Zusammenhalt. Wenn alle den Ausbilder hassen, dann haben sie wenigstens eine Gemeinsamkeit. Aber trotzdem kann man da ja Fragen stellen.
Ja, ganz viele bitte auch, ja.
Ja, und vor allem, ich habe mich das eben wirklich gefragt. Ich meine, Ade Hegerberg ist jetzt natürlich ein Extrembeispiel, weil die später Weltfußballerin und so weiter und so fort. Aber ihr hattet es ja immer wieder, dass Spielerinnen auch aus anderen Ländern mal nach Potsdam kommen. In der Phase nimmt es ein bisschen zu. Und da habe ich mich eben gefragt, wie die das aufgenommen haben, ebenso durch die Bernd Schröder-Schule dann auf einmal gehen zu müssen.
Ja, das war schon hart. Also das ist auch, jetzt reden wir über Machtmissbrauch. Was, also, weil jetzt haben wir es klar, dieses, auch dieses, dir werden halt Defizite aufgezeigt und dann hast du, du hast sie zu trainieren. Also was teils Spielerinnen an Läufen machen mussten, um sie einfach mental zu brechen. Also Thema Machtmissbrauch, dieses, du hast jetzt hier die 10 mal 400, 400, ja wir hatten 10 mal 200, 10 mal 400 und 5 mal 4000. So, ja, dieses und auch, also mir wurde ja nicht gesagt, warum laufe ich die jetzt, warum in dieser Zeit, warum jetzt auch in der Saisonvorbereitung oder in der Saison auch. Das hieß einfach nur so willkürlich, hat man uns auch am Montag schon gar nicht die Trainingsinhalte für die Woche genannt, weil du hast immer vorbereitet zu sein. Alvi, Assi ist das bitter.
Und du warst ja dann damals schon Kapitänin, ich glaube auch in der ersten Saison, oder?
Ja, ich war kurz weiß, ne?
Ja, kommen wir gleich noch dazu, warum du nur kurz warst. Aber hattest du damals schon das Standing, dass du das auch mal thematisiert hast? Weil du warst ja auch dafür da, dann die jüngeren Spielerinnen zu schützen.
Ja, voll, ja.
Wie kam das so an?
Nicht gut. Also es war immer, immer wieder dieser Weg in dieses Trainerzimmer, dieses okay, habt ihr einen Plan für diese Woche? Alleine wegen der Zeiten, weil wir hatten ja auch Schülerinnen, wir hatten welche, die in die Sprachschule sind. Also wir hatten parallel so viel zu koordinieren vom Time-Management und es war uns nicht wirklich gegeben, weil der Plan immer halt nur halb kommuniziert wurde. Mann, warum schafft ihr es nicht? Wir haben jetzt einen Monat, die Spiele sind alle klar, die sind in den ganzen Season sind die klar. Warum könnt ihr uns nicht die Trainingsinhalte folgendermaßen schon geben? Zu welchen Zeiten? Damit ich mich auch vorbereiten kann, mental, schlafessens-technisch. Da sprichst du gegen eine Wand, habe ich da gesprochen.
Ja, ich meine, Felix Maggert hat das mal früher bei den Männern der Bayern extra nur von Tag zu Tag bekannt gegeben, weil sie dann keine Marketingtermine ausmachen konnten. Das kann ja bei euch nicht das Problem gewesen sein. Das ist nicht böse gemeint.
Ja, das stimmt. Irgendwie versucht man ja dann, ein Agreement zu schaffen und das war echt eine Knüppelzeit. Ich habe mich ja dann auch immer als Vermittlerin gesehen, zu sagen, das sind die Bedürfnisse der Mannschaft. Und die gilt es jetzt zu vermitteln dem Trainerstuff, also hauptsächlich Bernd Schulda. Und das war ja auch, wir hatten ja teils, ich glaube, wir hatten sogar auch mal eine Datenerfassung, wie, wer, was läuft, um mal so ein Maximum. Das war dann der Athletiktrainer. Der wurde aber nicht wirklich gehört, weil Bernd hatte das Machtwort. Also dieses so, wer ist, der hätte uns schützen können, der kann uns nicht schützen, weil der über Mund, Mand, heißt das ja, glaube ich, wird. Und dann gilt das Recht von Bernd Schulda. So lief das, ja. Oh, ich weiß auch, da habe ich auch irgendwann, weil ich wurde auch so wütend, habe ich auch geheult, so weil das, weil das fand ich auch einfach nicht fair so. Und du hast natürlich bei den Spielern auch, wie die auch mit sich gekämpft haben, weil die waren auch am Limit. So und am Ende des Tages war es die Verletzung, die sie dann ausgebremst hat. Wo sie mal einen gewissen, oder ich ja auch, ich war ja mitten drin, mal kurz wieder in Abstand zu dem Ganzen, zu sagen so, okay, Grenze. Also Körper spricht mit dir. Das war, glaube ich, sagt alles. Und dann kannst du die Verletzungshistorien der jeweiligen Spielern unter Bernd Schröder sehen, bis hin jetzt in Validitätsrente. Ich kriege 20 Prozent Invaliditätsrente. Ne Viola Odebrecht, Babette Peth, also die haben ja Jenny Zietz, eine Nadine Kessler, die haben gefühlt keine Knie mehr. Also so das, und am Ende des Tages tragen wir die Konsequenz. Schon heavy. Und das war auch, ich weiß noch, um ein Gespräch, da habe ich dann zu Bernd Schröder auch ins Zimmer gegangen und meinte, habe ich ihm die Situation erklärt, wie ich mich sehe als Kapitänin, Vermittlungsposition, dass ich nicht ansatzweise das Gefühl habe, dass das irgendwie hier einen Raum hat, sondern dass er quasi immer nur mit dem gesprochenen Wort handelt, ohne dass es irgendwie um uns geht, um die Bedürfnisse von unsererseits. Habe ich ihm die Kapitänsspinde auf den Tisch gelegt, meinte er, unter den Bedingungen bin ich keine Kapitänin mehr. Und? Und dann, ja, dann habe ich mir was anhören dürfen. Persönlichkeitsdefizite hätte ich ja eh und also dieses dann, dieses, dieses klein machen, dieses. Ich meine, ich habe es in der Situation auch gesehen, so dieses, okay, ich, ich stelle mich jetzt halt einfach. Ich setze eine Grenze und das gefällt dir halt nicht. So und dann nimmst du Mittel als Kommunikationsstil, um mir wehtun zu wollen und mich brechen zu wollen. Aber du brichst mich nicht. So dieses, ja.
Ja gut, eine Tabea Kemme hat er nicht gebrochen. Aber du wirst bestimmt auch Spielerinnen kennen. Die sind einfach genanlos zum Handmorden.
Ja, die sind einfach, haben gewechselt noch.
Im Bestfall das ja.
Ja schon, ja. Oder auch, also ich mein, das lehrte mich auch um ganz, ganz vieles. Ich weiß nicht, ob mir das irgendein Lehrbuch aufgezeigt hätte. Das weiß ich halt auch nicht. Ich will jetzt auch nicht schönreden, dass man das braucht, um gewisse Dinge zu lernen, um Gottes willen. Das war halt mein Weg. Ich wusste, das ist die Konsequenz, die ich gelebt habe, die ich dann aber auch natürlich erfahren habe. Ich glaube, das ist ja auch immer so, wie du gibst, du kriegst auch.
Ja, aber gleichzeitig ist halt die Frage, also ich will auch nichts am sportlichen Erbe vom Bernd Schröde wegnehmen. Deswegen habe ich das vorhin auch schon mal gesagt. Natürlich hat, also jeder hat seine Zeit, würde ich sagen. Und wir bewegen uns ja aber jetzt in der Situation, das wird sich jetzt dann eben quasi auch, ab diesen Saisons zeigt sich das langsam, der langsame sportliche Abstieg von Turbine Potsdam, der auch damit zusammenhängt, dass es von außen betrachtet keinen Mut oder keinen Willen zu einer Weiterentwicklung geben, denn wir haben das immer schon so gemacht. Ein typisch, ich nenne es das Deutschland Phänomen. Ja. Und das zweite aber auch, ich glaube und das wäre jetzt aber die Frage an dich, dass es damals ja auch gar keine Möglichkeit gab, das zu adressieren, weil du bist zu Bernd Schröder gegangen und hast seine Kapitäne in den Binde hingelegt. Dann hast du einen Einlauf bekommen und wurde es quasi noch mal niedergemacht, aber weil du so bist, wie du bist, hat dich das nicht fertig gemacht. Aber hätte es denn jemand anderen gegeben, zu dem du überhaupt hätte es gehen können? Denn ich vermute, Präsident Kurzmutz wäre es jetzt nicht gewesen, dass der gesagt hätte, was hat der Bernd da gemacht?
Nein, nein, das war Freundeskreis, hat das aufgefangen. Das war die Chaos-WG.
Aber das zeigt ja, was damals gefehlt hat bei der Turbine und ja sicherlich auch ganz lange noch gefehlt hat bis in die Gegenwart hinein.
Ich meine, letztlich beschreibst du das perfekt mit dem, dass der Erfolg ausgeblieben ist. Und dann ist so der Erfolg, der deckt ganz viel. Der lässt ganz viele Dinge unsichtbar werden. Und da haben wir es nicht mehr tragen können. Ich glaube, das beschreibt es am besten. Und eine Situation, die es auch noch mal richtig gut beschreibt, ist, es war auch zu der Zeit, als ich Kapitänin war, dass wir hatten ein Spiel verloren, ich glaube in Essen oder so. Und wir hatten im Zuge dessen, wir hatten eine englische Woche und das Spiel haben wir spielerisch, also haben wir absolut underperformed und da lief alles schief, es hat schief laufen können. Und dann war die Maßnahme von dem Trainerteam, dass wir in der Vorbereitung aufs nächste Spiel uns hier jetzt bitte hinsetzen und dieses Spiel 90 Minuten kommentarlos angucken. Was ist das jetzt schon wieder für eine Sanktion, ganz ehrlich? Dann haben wir uns in der Mannschaft besprochen und dann, weil wir alle gesagt haben, wir wissen, dass das echt scheiße war, also wir brauchen jetzt einen Ausblick in Vorbereitung auf das nächste Spiel, was in drei Tagen ist. Wir gucken das hier nicht 90 Minuten jetzt an. Und dann haben wir einen Schlagplan gemacht. So und dann war die Situation, dass wir das Spiel wurde angeklickt. Und dann bin ich halt aufgestanden, habe auf Pause gedrückt und habe gebeten, dass wir doch bitte darauf verzichten, dass wir uns als Mannschaft da einig sind. Unser Bedürfnis ist, uns in eine Vorbereitung zu gehen. Wie gewinnen wir gegen den nächsten Gegner? Und dann kam nichts und dann meinte ich so, okay, dann verlassen wir jetzt alle zusammen den Raum und dann bereiten wir uns jetzt auf den Gegner vor.
War das auch die Zeit, in der ihr den Sitzstreik gemacht habt, um das Aufwärmen mit Ball, zwei mit Ball?
Das war noch was anderes, ja. Aber das war auch manchmal dieses Bild. Das hasse ich auch für die Pässe. Dieses, okay, wir machen 12 Minuten Erwärmung und dann wären es 12 Minuten, 25 Minuten, und dann machen wir hier noch Quatsch und da noch Quatsch und so. Und dann haben wir da die ganze Zeit. Dann kommt noch die Nichte. Weißt du, dann kommen die kleinen Kinder an den Zauen. Und dann ist, dann sieht man diesen Trainer so herzlich im Umgang mit der Nicht und wir alle so, ist das nicht sein Ernst? Wieso kann er nicht so zu uns sein? Ja, also es war echt, ja, das ist halt einfach dieser autoritäre Stil, der hat mich sehr geprägt, uns alle sehr geprägt. Ja, das war schon krass.
Wie ging es weiter nach der Videoanalyse?
Das war nochmal sehr brenzlig, weil auch dort kein, also in einer gewissen Wut an das Trainerteam, die dann aufgesprungen sind und sich groß gemacht haben und und dann haben wir einfach den Raum, also sind einfach gegangen. Wir sind schlichtweg, sind wir gegangen und dann haben wir uns auf die Zimmer aufgeteilt, beziehungsweise haben uns in einen Raum getroffen und haben uns besprochen. Und dann sind wir nächsten Tag ins Training und es wurde alles ignoriert. Also ist das klassischer.
Ja, okay. Und das muss ja relativ früh gewesen sein, denn also am vierten Spieltag gibt es wieder mal ein Duell gegen den FFC. Das war das, wo du Lira Bayramay gefordert hast und die sich das Kreuzband gerissen hat. Da gab es eben die Morddrohungen, über die wir vorhin gesprochen haben. Und nur einen Spieltag später gab es eben eine Partie gegen Bad Neunahr. Und da bist du nach 55 Minuten raus, obwohl du, ich zitiere hier, bis dahin hatte Kemme Bad Neunahrs Kapitänin und Nationalstürmerin Celia Okuina Darmababi, heute Saasic, fast zur Wirkungslosigkeit verurteilt und immer wieder verzweifelt die Hände heben lassen.
55 muss ich raus.
Ja, du hast, danach hat Bernd Schröder gesagt, sie hat einen Schlag auf den rechten Oberschenkel bekommen, und wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, ob es eine Einblutung gegeben hat.
Ah, das war ja wieder den Mündelriss, den ich da ja hatte, genau. Das war dann auch gerade vier Wochen raus, ja. Das war auch so, auch ein bisschen Selbstschutz, das weiß ich auch noch, weil ich gemerkt habe, da wird das alles ein bisschen viel so, und ich hatte eine muskuläre Dysbalance, und da habe ich dann gemerkt, okay, warte mal, wenn ich jetzt hier weiter gehe, das holt mich doppelt ein, ja.
Es gab kurz darauf das Champions-League-Achtelfinale gegen Arsenal. Im Hinspiel warst du dann eben nicht im Kader. 1 zu 2 vor Achtung, auswärts bei Arsenal 832 ZuschauerInnen. Nur noch mal ganz kurz, wie es mal war bei Arsenal und wie es jetzt ist. Im Rückspiel dann wurdest du beim Stand von 0 zu 2 ausgewechselt. In Potsdam waren es über 3000 ZuschauerInnen. Ihr habt mit 3 zu 4 verloren und so seid ihr dann ausgeschieden. Bernd Schröder hat damals gesagt, unter anderem, Arsenal hat die erste Halbzeit 150 Prozent gespielt, wir haben 60 Prozent gespielt, wir haben die erste Halbzeit völlig verschlafen. Und ich würde dir gerne noch einen weiteren O-Ton von ihm jetzt einspielen. Und dann kannst du mir einfach mal sagen, wie du heute darüber denkst. Ist mit Tabea Kemme, also war die leicht verletzt oder war es ein Taktischer weg?
Die haben ja immer noch diese Grippe und das war sicherlich ein Fehler, die überhaupt hier reinzubringen, weil das war ja gar nicht. Und das muss man einfach mal sehen. Aber man hat gedacht, das Kapitän versucht, einigermaßen die anderen mitzuziehen, ist nicht gelungen. Ist einfach nicht gelungen. Und da zeigt sich natürlich immer wieder, wenn wir hier irgendwas, wenn ein, zwei Leute ausfallen, im Spiel selber in Ugimi war auch eine Katastrophe. Gar nicht. Hätten wir gar nicht, hätten wir auswechseln müssen. Vom Roller durch, den Olympischen Spielen und ähnliche Dinge. Und da muss man einfach mal sagen, wir haben es heute einfach selber in der Hand gehabt, haben es nicht gepackt.
Habe ich noch nie gehört. Krass.
Und weißt du, was das Krasse ist? Ich habe den Ton jetzt nicht irgendwie von irgendwelchen kritischen Medien. Das kommt vom Vereinsfernsehen von Turbinen.
Ja, das ist schon heftig. Ja, das war teils auch so, wie es nischt. Das haben wir dann schon teils übernommen, weil wir es auch wieder ein bisschen verniedlicht haben. Ja, das ist die Situation, würde ich, glaube ich, ziemlich gut auf den Punkt bringen, wo der Trainer nicht hinter deinem Rücken steht.
Ja, also ich hätte nämlich jetzt gefragt, wie damals das Verhältnis zwischen Bernd Schröde und dem Team war. Aber ich weiß es ja jetzt. Die Spielerin, die er noch angesprochen hat, das war Ugimi, die heißt heute Yuki Nagasato. Und die ist aber eben zum Beispiel dann nach der Saison auch gewechselt. Sie ist weggegangen als Torschützenkönigin.
Ja, voll. Also ich glaube, das ist dann die nötige Konsequenz, die die Spielerinnen aufgrund solcher Situation getätigt haben. Und einfach weil wir auch irgendwann müde geworden sind, die Dinge im Fallein zu tragen. Habe ich selber ja auch gemerkt. Also dieses, auch nach Olympia weiß ich auch noch dieses. Auch dieses, ich meine, U24 war das nächsten Tag direkt ins Trainingslager. So nach Olympia bzw. irgendwann war auch dieses so, okay, ich nehme mich jetzt auch mal raus, weil ich trage es auch einfach nicht mehr. Und somit zerstückelte sich das dann über oder Hegeberg ging dann auch weg und wurden dann Weltspielerinnen. Die wurden nicht entpotzt an Weltspielerinnen. Kann man sich mal fragen warum?
Wir müssen noch einen extra Potsdam-Freude-Spin-Aufgabe machen. Also du warst bis Frühling dann raus mit der Schulter-Gelenks-Sprengung, bist dann im Pokal-Halbfinale gegen die Bayern wieder eingewechselt worden. Es ging in die Verlängerung mit 1 zu 1, dann 4 zu 1 gewonnen.
Wow, eine Verlängerung, ja.
Ja genau, das lief dann ganz gut. Diesmal wurde man Zweiter hinter Wolfsburg. Wenn man so will, kann man da eben schon den langsamen Abstieg sehen. Und gegen Wolfsburg ging es dann auch im DFB-Pokalfinale. Da stand es relativ früh schon 0 zu 3. Ihr seid noch auf 2, 3 herangekommen, aber ihr konntet nichts mehr machen. Und weißt du was? Beim Schröder hat es sich verändert. Weißt du noch, was er verändert hat in diesem Finale?
Ja, die Aufstellung. Also nicht die personelle Aufstellung, sondern das System. Der ist auf viel Zeit gegangen.
Und Viererkette hat er nie spielen lassen.
Das haben wir nie trainiert.
Na, fantastisch.
Und weißt du, wer das übermitteln musste, weil das Trainerteam das nicht geschafft hat? Die haben mir die Aufgabe gegeben, das der Mannschaft zu erzählen. Und sie haben mir auch die Aufgabe gegeben, dass eine Spielerin, die Andrine Hegeberg, die immer gespielt hat, in diesem Spiel nicht spielen wird.
Aber warum muss denn die Kapitänin das...
Ja, frag mal mal. Genau, ja. Frag mal, wer hier jetzt die Verantwortung wie nicht getragen hat. Dann haben wir... Oh, das war sie noch. Krass. Das habe ich auch schon hart verdrängt. Die... Dann wurde mir das übermittelt. Dann sind wir... Ich so, okay, wir müssen irgendwie die Mannschaft zusammen trommeln. Mit, weiß nicht, fünf DIN A4-Zetteln und einem Adding sind wir raus irgendwo im Park und haben uns das quasi selbst angeeignet. Das kann noch nicht sein. Oh, das war auch... Das war so eine... Weißt du, wenn so einer Seite ist, so viel Wut drin in dir und die andere ist so, ne, warte jetzt, Blick, Fokus, Akzeptanz, geht gar nicht, was da passiert ist. Am Ende des Tages sind wir die Spielerinnen auf dem Platz und wir wollen weiter. So, das war die ganze Zeit. Ja, und auch diese Empörtheit auch in der Mannschaft, ne? Also auch wir Achsenspielerinnen. Und dann mussten wir das tragen und dann hatten wir ein, auch dieses, okay, ich weiß oder wir wissen, es ist kein Verlass aufs Trainerteam. Was machen wir? Wir ziehen das jetzt vier für zwei durch, wie die Forderung ist. Und wenn wir aber merken, es kippt irgendwie ein Spiel, dann gebe ich ein Zeichen, dann stellen wir um und das kam ja dann auch.
Und das habt ihr gemacht.
Dann sind wir auf ein 3-2 gekommen und dann hat Ada noch die Möglichkeit und es ist ein Pfosten-Schuss. Also wir sind fast aufs 3-3 gekommen. Ja, also deswegen auch dieses, okay, auf wen kann ich mich am Ende verlassen, das ist halt nicht der Trainer.
Und das ist auch so im Nachhinein, ich meine, man weiß natürlich dann, wie es weiterging mit Turbina, aber im Nachhinein gibt es so viele Anzeichner, die man sieht, auch an dem Spiel. Vor dem Spiel wird noch Ogimi, wie sie damals noch hieß, eben als Torschützenkündigin ausgezeichnet. Und es ist aber schon klar, dass sie zu Chelsea wechselt. Also und das zielt sich jetzt eigentlich durch, dass du bei jeder Saison siehst, oh, bei den Abgängen echt bekannte Namen mit dabei. Und ich will jetzt gar nichts gegen die Neuzugänge sagen, aber du siehst, es kommt nicht die gleiche Qualität nach. Und vor allem die Frage, warum geht eigentlich so viel Qualität die ganze Zeit? Wenn du dann versuchst, das irgendwie in Archivrecherche rauszukriegen, dann, also ich verallgemeine jetzt ein bisschen, aber es wurde schon oft so dargestellt, ja, die wollen halt alle, die sind alle Geldgeil.
Ja, richtig. Ja, und das wurde auch so offenkundig, wurde das auch erzählt. Ja, wurde schön das weggemacht, was eigentlich, also infrastrukturelle Themen, die uns jahrelang versprochen worden sind, die nicht umgesetzt worden sind.
Hast du ein Beispiel für?
Trainingsplätze war ganz oft Thema.
Ach ja, stimmt, das was du später mal erzählt hast, dass Arsenal allein drei Millionen Pfund für Trainingsplätze ausgibt.
Ja, genau, und in Potsdam war es halt einfach dieses, okay, inwiefern, das sind ja dann auch, wenn man das System einmal so ein bisschen hat, diese Luftschifffahven GmbH, das ist der Stützpunkt, da ist die Rasenpflege, das heißt, braucht eine gute Kommunikation. Kommunikation haben wir jetzt auch schon, ne?
Was ist das beim Problem? Hättest du da nicht mit einem Zettel hingehen können, was soll Kapitänin?
Also so ein bisschen, ich sag auch mal, die Menschen, mit denen man zusammenarbeitet, auch sich gegenseitig bei Laune zu halten, das funktionierte nicht so gut. Dann war natürlich die Konkurrenz auch, Football kam auch ein bisschen mehr, so die sind dann auf die Plätze und wir hatten dann halt auch einfach nicht mehr das Standing, zu Recht, weil wir es uns einfach auch verspielt haben, das muss man auch ganz klar sagen. Also off, head off position, ja, ja schon, ja. Ja und dann immer dieses, genau, und dann die Berater waren immer schuld, das Geld war immer schuld, die Schuldigen waren immer außerhalb des Systems.
Ja und das Schwierige ist aber, komplett falsch war es auch nicht, weil du konntest anderswo besser verdienen.
Ja voll, ja. Und du hättest auch viel mehr draus machen können von Seiten-Turbine-Potzen. Da habe ich ja meine Kandidatur dann versucht umzusetzen.
Ja, das ist jetzt so ein Thema. Also wir sind nämlich jetzt schon wahnsinnig über der Zeit. Wenn du noch okay damit bist, wollen wir auf einer Hainaut enden und wir machen noch bis wir in Rio angekommen sind. Und vielleicht machen wir dann Teil zwei irgendwann.
Ja, das klingt schön.
Okay, also ist für dich okay, weil wir sind schon okay. Das tut mir total leid.
Nein, um Gottes Willen. Das passt.
Dann sind wir ja auch schon beim Nationalteam, denn im September wurdest du in dieser Saison eben bei der EM-Quali in einen Kader berufen, dann später nicht mehr. Das haben wir vorhin besprochen. Bei der EM in Schweden warst du dann nicht mit dabei, aber du warst ja auch vorher lange verletzt. Weiter ist natürlich Sylvia Knight, die Bundestrainerin. Deutschland hat damals noch das EM-Finale gewonnen gegen Norwegen. Die haben zwei Strafstöße verschossen.
Nach dem Angerer, ja.
Absolute Legende einfach. Muss man einfach sagen, in sämtlicher Hinsicht. Weil ich weiß, wie du die EM 2011 verfolgt hast. Wie hast du denn damals die EM 2013 verfolgt? Weißt du das noch?
Auch nicht so. Das, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich da war. Ich glaube, ich war irgendwo surfen oder so. Ja, ich war woanders unterwegs.
Ich habe sie damals verfolgt. Du hast alles richtig gemacht.
Ja, Anja. Anja und Josi haben mir noch viel erzählt. Anja hat ja dann noch das Tor gemacht, beziehungsweise die Vorlage auf das Zelt gegeben. Ja, doch. Aber ich war irgendwo auf der Welle.
Gute Entscheidung. Wir kommen in die Saison 2013-14 rein. Es kommen Julia Simic, Velti kommt. Pauline Bremer wird hochgezogen. Hélène Jacques, Sarah Dorson, Nagasato Ogimi habe ich schon angesprochen und Andréin Hegerberg verlassen Potsdam. Du hast im September dann noch in der zweiten Runde von Potsdam gespielt. Wurde, glaube ich, wieder herangeführt, nach der Verletzung gegen Magdeburg. Und dann gab es die Rücke im DFB-Pokal, wo man in der zweiten Runde, was quasi die erste Runde damals für die Erstligistinnen war, direkt gegen Essen ausschalte, 2 zu 3, nachdem man in der zweiten Hälfte, in der 63. Minute, noch mit 2 zu 0 geführt hat.
Heftig. Ja, heftig.
Und danach musstest du wieder Zettel zur Mannschaft bringen. Wir sind jetzt sauer auf vom Trainerteam.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe sehr schnell die Akzeptanz daran gefunden, dass der DFB-Pokal und meine Wenigkeit ist. Da wir konnten uns da nicht einigen.
Aber was soll ich sagen? Der November, der wird besser. Im Champions League-Achtelfinale gegen Lyon. Hinspiel noch 0 zu 1, aber im Rückspiel 2-1. Exakt.
Boah, das war auch krass.
Und dann das absolut Unmögliche passiert. Am 27. November 2013 wirst du vor 400 ZuschauerInnen in Kroatien beim Stand von 6 zu 0 in der 76. Minute im Nationalteam eingewechselt.
Drei Jahre haben sich ausgezahlt auf diesen Moment. Und ich weiß noch, es war Schnee, Regen, Chaos. Und der Platz war eine einzige Schlammschlacht. Und wer von den 11 Spielerinnen dann auf dem Platz trägt Nockenschuhe? Ich besaß keine, keine Eisenschuhe, Eisenstollen habe ich auch nie getragen, weil davon, ich jetzt einmal getragen meine Wade wurde fest, meine Wadenmuskulatur. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich verbanne euch ihr Eisenstollen.
Das ist auf das Kotzband nicht gut. Also ich verstehe gar nicht, dass die so viel strengen.
Gerochen habe ich das damals schon. Und da weiß ich auch nur alleine deswegen in der Vorbereitung, also im Warm-Up, waren schon auch schon Mitspielerinnen, die so, ja, also du weißt schon, wenn du hier nur einmal ausrutschst mit diesem Schuh, du kriegst richtig Stress von Silvia. Und ich so, weißt du, so blauäugig, du weißt ja, es soll erstmal passieren. Ja, aber weißt du, wenn das ist ja auch alles so irgendwie, wo dann schon so subtil dir gesagt wird, so ey, pass auf, was du hier tust. So und das ist, wenn sich das summiert, ey, da bleibt mal konsequent, also das hat mich jedes Mal natürlich auch gefordert und mich auch hinterfragen lassen, so dieses okay. Und dann immer sich wieder einzunorden, zu sagen so, nee, das ist jetzt mein Bedürfnis und ich kenn mich. Das war da auch noch mal ganz groß gefordert.
Angstkommunikation ist echt so ein bisschen das Thema.
Heftig, heftig.
Weißt du noch, für wen du eingewechselt wurdest?
Nee, du?
Leonie Meyer.
Oh Leo, ja, stimmt, Außenverteidigerin, ja.
Das war jetzt drei Jahre nach dem U20-WM-Titel, hast du endlich deinen Debüt gegeben. Man kann sich das wirklich eigentlich nicht vorstellen, muss man echt sagen, weil du ja die ganze Zeit gespielt hast und Kapitänin warst, also.
Ja, schon eigentlich. Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite, was ja dann mehr im Fokus war oder wo es ja rasant ging, war, okay, von Schulabschluss zu Berufsfindungsseminar zu Studiumsbewerbung für die Polizei zu Studiumsstart. Das waren ja in diesen drei Jahren plus Verletzungen aus Korean. Eigentlich auch wieder geil genutzt.
Natürlich, aber es ist halt schon interessant, dass also heutzutage macht man es ja so, dass man jemandem wenigstens mal das Debüt in Anführungszeichen schenkt und letztlich könnte man, wenn man jetzt in dem Moment, weißt du ja auch noch nicht, wie es für dich weitergehen wird und auch die Geschichte mit Nationalteam wird noch eine erfreuliche für dich werden. Aber beim Stand von 6 zu 0 im Schneeregen, in der 75. Minute, also man kann es auch als Geschenk sehen, aber ich habe mich gefragt, ob sich da irgendwas verändert hat zwischen dir und Sylvia Knight, weil es war ja schon einfach auch sehr personengetrieben.
Nee, gar nicht. Also ich habe es auch, ich glaube, das ist auch was, was mich ausmacht und woran ich mich auch immer messe, ist, dass ich auf der Sonnenseite des Lebens sein möchte und immer irgendwie die Zeit, die ich bekomme, egal in welcher Ansicht für mich erfüllt, nutzen möchte. Und das waren dann halt auch die paar Minuten, die ich hatte. Ich weiß noch, ich hatte da auf jeden Fall zwei Aktionen, die noch zu einer gefährlichen Torchance beispielsweise geworden sind, zu sagen, okay, die geringe Zeit, die ich habe, nutze ich maximal und so erhasche ich mir dann im nächsten Spiel ein paar Minuten.
Und bist du ausgerutscht im Spiel?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Gott sei Dank. Du warst damals mit Anna Mittag schon auf dem Zimmer, habtest die Bühne gefeiert?
Ja, ich weiß noch, sie hätte, glaube ich, auch irgendeinen Runden-Ländespiel zahlt. Und ich halt das erste und dann musste man ja mal was machen. Und wir haben dann auf dem Rückflug haben wir dann das Boarding mit übernommen, im Sinne von wir haben das Essen ausgeteilt und haben diese Boardansprache gemacht. Und es war auch wieder, mach mit Anjas auch mal Zucker.
Das kann man wirklich auch sehr gut nachruhren. Und wenn wir also wenn man MBHK hört, was ich nur sehr empfehlen kann, dann werden wir beim Nationalteam bleiben, mit Deutschland dann den Algarve Cup gewonnen. Im März, im April bist du dann gegen Irland beim Stand von 0 zu 1 in der Halbzeit ausgewechselt worden und danach wurdest du in meinem ersten WM-Quali-Spiel erstmal nicht mehr eingesetzt. Lief das damals einfach so?
Da ich wurde ausgewechselt, weil ich taubes Bein hatte.
Ach so, okay.
Das war quasi Bandscheibenvorfall. Ja, das war auch so eine Konsequenz aus zu viel Belastung, zu wenig auf mich aufgepasst, der Körper spricht mit dir, ich schenke dir jetzt erstmal einen schönen, doppelten Bandscheibenvorfall war das sogar.
Ja, okay, dann habe ich das nämlich falsch mir hergeleitet. Es gab ja mal die Nummer mit dem Einzelvideo-Lehrgang von dir, da hast du in einer Länderspielmaßnahme einen Fehler gemacht und Wochen später, bei der nächsten wurde dir als allererstes das Video davon.
Ich weiß noch, das war WM 2015 Kanada Spiel um Platz 3, da habe ich den Elfmeter verschuldet.
Ach so das? Das war auch nicht mal ein Elfmeter oder war es nicht ein Falschpaus?
Das war ein Elfmeter dann.
Ja genau, er wurde als Elfmeter gepfiffen, aber ich glaube, der war doch auf der Kante.
Ja der war auf der Kante, aber der wurde als Elfmeter gegeben.
Ich dachte nämlich, ich hätte hier den Moment identifiziert, dass du deswegen ausgewechselt werden wirst beim 0 zu 1.
Das war 2015.
Okay, alles klar, da müssen wir noch mal kurz drüber sprechen. Wolfsburg war damals euer Kryptonit in der Liga, ein Unentschieden, eine Niederlage im Champions League Halbfinale, ein 0 zu 0 und dann ein 2 zu 4 und Wolfsburg wurde auch Meister. Pokal haben wir ja vorhin schon besprochen und gleichzeitig war Wolfsburg damals auf dem absolutes Prime Wolfsburg. Also die haben das Trippel geholt, 2013, Ralf Kellermann wurde Welttrainer des Jahres.
Halbturbine ist zu Wolfsburg gewechselt.
Kann man fast sagen, ja. Und auch in diesem Jahr, also 2014, hat dann Wolfsburg wieder die Champions League gewonnen und die Meisterschaft, habe ich ja schon gerade gesagt, und die Champions League hat man ohne Niederlage gewonnen und im Viertelfinale Barca noch mit 5 zu 0 in Addition besiegt.
Ja, das war krass. Ja, das war High Performance.
Wie hast du denn das wahrgenommen, dass damals Wolfsburg ja schon eine Wachablosung vorgenommen hat?
Ja, also ich wusste ja auch so, das war klar. Ich wusste ja, wie es bei uns läuft. Und ich wusste auch um die Strukturen, also um die strukturellen Bedingungen bei Wolfsburg und auch die Trainingsmethodik. Da war das klar, dass am Ende das Ergebnis herumkommt.
Und warum ist dann die Kapitänin von Turbine Potts haben dich auch nach Wolfsburg gewechselt?
Weil ich mein Studium hatte. Ich glaube, um die Zeit war ich im Wachenwechseldienst. Und das war für mich, das war ja die Sportfördergruppe, fünf Jahre Studium und das war für mich schon auch ein Anker zu sagen, okay, weil ich weiß, wie schnell lebe ich und was passieren kann im Fußball. Und ich ziehe auf jeden Fall dieses Studium durch. Und da bin ich als Streifenpolizistin durch Potsdam gedüst.
Hätte ich ehrlich gesagt auch sehr viele Fragen zu beantworten.
Ja, war auch kurios, ja. Ich auch oft erkannt wurde als Turinenspielerin.
Ja.
Auch verzwickt manchmal in so Verhalten mit häuslicher Gewalt, das mit Kindern, das war. Ja, also deswegen die Bandbreite des Lebens, so, ne? Das, ja. Und deswegen waren so diese Auszeiten im Fußball gezwungenermaßen, weil halt die Performance nicht gesehen wurde, nicht da war aufgrund von Verletzungen. Parallel hatte ich ja immer noch mein Leben, was lief. Ja.
Okay, dann gehen wir in die Saison 2014-15 rein. Feli Rauch, Victoria Krug und Jenny Hüpp kommen hoch aus der Jugend. Mielde und Ada Hegeberg, also jetzt eben auch die Schwester, verlassen Turbine. Ich glaube, die Frage, die ich mir aufgeschrieben habe, warum konnte die Turbine Ada Hegeberg nicht halten, die haben wir, glaube ich, schon beantwortet.
Ja, voll. Auch einfach fachsendicke. Und ich meine, also 2015 war ich in Lyon einmal, weil ich ein Angebot hatte von Lyon. Ich habe mir das alles angeguckt und war auch, also rein finanziell war es so ein dreifache mehr oder so. Nur für mich war dann auch nochmal klar, ich mache erst das Studium zu Ende. Und das war super attraktiv. Jetzt unabhängig von dem finanziellen, das ist ein Part, aber letztlich die Bedingungen. Das heißt, okay, zu welchen Zeiten kann ich Full-Time platzmäßig trainieren? Die Gegebenheiten waren halt so ein Nummer Prozent gegeben. Das hatten wir in Potsdam halt so nicht.
Das heißt, Potsdam hatte irres Glück, dass du dieses Studium.
Ja, durchaus. Das war ja dann hier immer, weißt du, Handshake, Bernd Schröder mit zweiter Standbein, sowohl Schule. Deswegen hat er mich dann auch mal eine Woche ins Skilager gelassen.
Da hat er es vorbereitet, der alte Fuchs. Also, ihr habt in der Saison 14, 15 keinen internationalen Wettbewerb gespielt. Im Oktober 1 zu 2 gegen Wolfsburg verloren und 0 zu 1 gegen den FC Bayern. Und nach einem 1 zu 5 bei Frankfurt war im Februar die Meisterschaft im Grunde schon weg. Am Ende wird die Turbine vierte mit acht Punkten Rückstand auf den Meister Bayern, die damals kein einziges Spiel verloren haben. Wie ist denn das, wenn man über so viele Saisons hinweg eigentlich immer mit dabei ist, bis im Frühling? Irgendwas gab es immer zu gewinnen. Und wenn es ein DFB-Pokalfinale war, auch wenn es nicht gewonnen wurde in deiner Karriere. Und da war ja die Saison im Grunde...
War durch. Luft komplett raus. Ich meine, es war schon sehr schnell klar, dass also diese Art von Wachablösung, dass einfach, wenn wir da irgendwas entgegenbringen, dann schaffen wir das nur einheitlich als Teammannschaft. Und da brauche ich halt 100 Prozent von jeder Spielerin. Aber das haben wir nicht stemmen können, ne? Das war einfach dann auch von den spielerischen Anlagen, vom Verständnis Plan A bis E zu haben. Wir hatten immer nur Plan A. Außer dann mal Plan B mit einer Viererkette. So, also diese, diese Art von Verständnis und auch, ja, auch die Art von Überzeugung dann auch nicht mehr, weil auch einfach so sich so eine Müdigkeit eingeschlichen hat. Das merke ich jetzt gerade auch noch mal, also das ist auch, weil auch, wie du jetzt den Weg noch mal skizzierst, so bewusst hatte ich das ja auch schon lange nicht mehr, dass sich, wie sehr sich das ja überall immer wieder angebahnt hat. Schon grau. Es ist so ersichtlich, es ist so offensichtlich.
Ja, das ist mir auch noch mal so gegangen. Offensichtlich ist auch, dass ihr ins DFB-Pokalfinale gekommen seid, weil das war so euer Ding. Leider war auch, dass sie es verloren haben.
Also wenn wir, wenn ich mir eine Sache treu geblieben bin, dann ist es DFB-Pokal.
0 zu 3 gegen Wolfsburg am Tag vor diesem Endspiel, das war dann 2015 eben, da hat der DFB bekannt gegeben, dass man jetzt eben fix erstmal in Köln bleiben will. Es gab auch zwischendurch mal die Überlegung, vielleicht nach Frankfurt zu gehen, aber da wurde der Vertrag für Kinder verlängert. Und Bernd Schröder hat danach gesagt, wir fühlen uns in Köln wohl, aber wer das Spiel im TV anschaut, sieht ein halbvolles Stadion. Da könnte man überlegen, in ein kleineres Stadion zu gehen. Und Ralf Kellermann vom VfL Wolfsburg hat gesagt, eine Größe von 25.000 bis 30.000 und ein ausverkauftes Stadion wären wünschenswert. Wie denkst du denn über diese Zitate, jetzt so in der Rückschau?
Das ist die Größe Brauch und dass wir auf den Weg vertrauen sollten, weil jetzt ist es ausverkauft.
Ja, ich meine, wir sind natürlich in einer komfortablen Situation, dass wir jetzt schon wissen, es ist mehr möglich. Aber das ist mir in der Recherche wirklich oft aufgefallen, dass relativ oft gesagt wird, mehr geht nicht, wir müssen ein bisschen kleiner machen. Und das wird immer gesagt, entweder von Männern und oder von jemandem, der beim DV arbeitet.
Ja, ja, also damit hast du, also damit haben wir die Antwort, dass wir, das merke ich ja sowohl als Spielerin oder auch in der Historie des Fußballs der Frauen, dass wir auch lernen, uns selbst zu unterschätzen, wenn dir das tagtäglich quasi immer schön serviert wird. Nee, das ihr habt nicht und ihr könnt nicht. So irgendwann nimmst du das ja auch an, wenn du nicht irgendwie über den Tellerrand schaust oder auch nicht die Vision hast. Ich merke es ja immer wieder, so diese Vision, die wir haben, die hatten Wert und demnach gehen wir in die Gestaltung. Und dann brauchen wir, dass die anderen Menschen das auch immer noch kurz sehen und Lust haben, so diesen Zauber, komm wir gehen mal hin. Das ist die Plattform, die der Fußball der Frauen schafft. Und ja, vielleicht sind die ein oder anderen in den Gremien noch nicht überzeugt davon. Da müssen sie sich bei sich mal gucken.
Ja und es braucht halt auch ein bisschen Zeit. Also ich meine, ja, das ist jetzt auch schon elf Jahre her. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann dann das erste ausverkaufte Pokalfinale war, aber so lange dürfte das gar nicht mehr gedauert haben. Also ich glaube, bei dem 2011er-Finale war ich sogar. Ich müsste dich da spielen gesehen haben. Lustig, habe ich in der Vorbereitung nie dran gedacht, aber ich glaube, da war ich. Aber das war nicht der wichtige Wettbewerb für dich, sondern der wichtige Wettbewerb, der kam dann im April beim 4 zu 0 gegen Brasilien im Testspiel. Da standst du noch auf dem Feld.
Das war auch cool, ja, gegen Marta.
Gegen Marta.
Zauber.
Und Christiane.
Ja, das war, weiß ich auch noch, das war, da habe ich mich auch richtig gefreut auf dieses Spiel. Weil ich auch als Verteidigerin wusste, was mit Marta auf mich zukommt. Und das habe ich ja geliebt, auch so diese krasse Qualität der Gegnerin, mich dem zu stellen und aufzunehmen, also gerade als Verteidigerin aufzunehmen und dann dennoch immer wieder meine Stärken auszuspielen. Das war cool.
Spielt denn Marta auch so Mindgames? Denn was ich sagen kann, ist, dass sie sehr viel mit den Schiedsrichterinnen zum Beispiel spricht.
Ja, genau. Das war ja auch deswegen auch, was ich auch immer priorisiert habe, so dieses, wenn ich weiß, ist jemand körperlich stärker als ich, dann gehe ich über die Psychologie. Sie ist im Antritt, also Handlungsschnelligkeit nicht unbedingt, aber im Antritt, die Antrittsgeschwindigkeit, da darf ich sie nicht kommen lassen, weil dann ist sie weg. Und dann versuche ich vorher halt direkt den Kontakt aufzunehmen, dass sie gar nicht erst da reinkommt. Stellungsspiel ist dann gefragt. Dann wird sie sauer, dann wird sie grantlich, weil sie nicht in ihre Aktion kommt.
Wenn sie schimpft, dann ist das ein guter Weg.
Genau, und dann war es immer so, yes, I got you. So, und das dann für meinen Vorteil zu nutzen, für mein Spiel dann offensiv auszulegen. Aber auch in der Bundesliga ganz viele Spielerinnen, die ich da auf meiner Karte hatte.
Auf deinem Cup mal jetzt.
Ja, genau. Ja, so naja, das ist ja irgendwie, das liebe ich ja auch an diesem Spiel. Also weil für mich ist jedes Spiel oder auch so dieses, wie lege ich das mental aus und dann zaubert der Körper einfach nur.
Du wurdest dann am 24. Mai 2015 in den WM-Kader berufen. Ab wann wusstest du, dass du zur WM darfst?
Ich glaube, das hat sich schon herauskristallisiert in der WM-Vorbereitung. Nur war ich da immer B11. Es war das Abschlusstraining zum ersten Spiel. Es waren noch mal sechs Defensivaufgaben für mich und meiner gesetzten Spielerin, vor mir gesetzten Spielerin, Jennifer Kramer war das. Unterhand dieser sechs Defensivaktionen, wie ich mich verhalte, hat Sylvia Knight entschieden.
Und wusstet ihr das dann auch?
Nein, das hat sie uns nicht gesagt, aber das war so, wie verhalte ich mich, wenn die Stürmerin auf mich zuläuft, wie dränge ich sie nach außen, und das habe ich ja geliebt, so volle Geschwindigkeit kommt auf mich zu, wie nehme ich auf, wie drücke ich weg, wie schiebe ich weg und schiebe mich zwischen Ball und Gegnerin. Das war ein Geschenk für mich. Und das ist ja dann auch so dieses, okay, ich habe Sylvia da schon sehr schnell, sehr klar gesehen, worauf sie jetzt was sehen will, beziehungsweise das war ja unmittelbar auch mein Anspruch. Und es waren sechs Situationen im Abschluss, im letzten Training. Und das hat mir die Stammelf-Garantie für dieses ganze Turnier gegeben. Deswegen, wie krass das manchmal ist, so dieses, ich habe ja, ich habe drei Jahre, irgendwie ob auf Tribüne oder auf Bank gesessen, war dann irgendwie wieder verletzungsbedingt raus, wurde nicht berufen und dann waren es sechs verdammte Situationen, wie verteidigst du.
Das ist schon, ich meine, so funktioniert Leistungssport, aber es ist auch Absorgung.
Ja, und das ist ja so das Thema der Verlässlichkeit. So das liebe ich. Dafür habe ich, das war 2015, ich habe 2006 bin ich auf dieses Internat gegangen. 2008, ne? Ne, 2006, 2008, erster Probevertrag. Das waren diese 2006 bis 2015. So das ist dieser Moment geil. Das könnte ich jeden Tag, hätte ich da Bock drauf. Gut, ein bisschen Regeneration dazwischen. Wäre super.
Ja, aber und dann erstes Spiel gegen die Elfenbeinküste in Ottava. Weiß noch, wie es ausgegangen ist?
Gewonnen.
Ja, 10 zu Null. Echter? Ja, man glaubt das nicht, weil die WM 2015 für alle, die im Thema sind, ist anders in Erinnerung geblieben. Aber das war dann doch sehr, sehr deutlich. Melanie Leupold hat sich verletzt in dem Spiel. Daran erinnerst du dich vielleicht noch?
Knie?
Das war damals so ein Thema. Ja, ich weiß gerade gar nicht mehr, im Sprunggelenk hatte ich im Kopf.
Ah doch, schon im Sprunggelenk war das ja, oder das war Krieg auch gar nicht mehr, so genau alles zusammen. Wer verletzungsbedingt da ausgefallen ist.
Zweites Spiel dann gegen Norwegen. Frühe Führung durch Anja Mittag. Und dann schreibt die Presse nach dem Seitenwechsel, ließ die zaghafte und körperlich nachlassende deutsche Mannschaft die Norwegerinnen in die Partie kommen. Und am Ende war es dann ein 1 zu 1. Und ich lese dir noch kurz vor, was Anja Mittag zu diesem Spiel gesagt hat, wie sie zitiert wird. Das Ergebnis ist nicht okay. Das ist ärgerlich. Wir haben so viele Chancen in der ersten Halbzeit gehabt. Schade, dass wir uns nicht belohnen. Nach der Pause haben wir es nicht mehr geschafft, so präsent zu sein. Und jetzt lese ich dir noch kurz vor, was Sylvia Knight gesagt hat. Ja, du wirst überrascht sein. Ich bin total zufrieden. Wir haben eine richtig gute erste Halbzeit abgeliefert. Wir haben fast gar nichts zugelassen. Und Norwegen ist ja auch nicht irgendein Gegner.
Ja, geil.
Interessant, oder?
Hat uns nicht für die Mannschaft gestellt, würde ich sagen, ja. Ja, und also Gruppenphase. Ich meine, Norwegen ist schon krass, das darf man nicht unterschätzen. Gruppenphase eins zu eins gegen Norwegen. Wir hatten die ersten drei Punkte aus dem ersten Spiel schon. So, lass mal den Ball ein bisschen flach halten.
Ja, ich fand das nur lustig, weil das gab es nicht so oft, dass Sylvia Knight diejenige ist, die das Positive sagt nach außen.
Ja, und ich finde auf der anderen Seite auch wieder so klassisch, wie krass selbstkritisch wir Spielerinnen sind.
Das ist es nämlich.
Das ist Wahnsinn. Wie sehr wir immer den Fokus darauf haben, was nicht funktioniert hat, anstatt auch mal das zu feiern, das vorzustimmen, was doch gelaufen ist.
Bis heute zieht sich das durch. Also das ist dann in Teil zwei. Da müssen wir dann mal kurz drüber reden, wie Steffi Jones nämlich damit umgegangen ist. Weil eigentlich glaube ich, dass die manche Dinge total richtig gemacht hat, in der Kommunikation auch nach außen.
Wie überfordert waren damit?
Gut.
Haben wir jetzt schon einen Check.
Dritte Spiel gegen Thailand. In Binnipäck mit 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Da wurdest du rausrotiert, weil ihr wart schon qualifiziert. Es ging dann ins Achtelfinale gegen Schweden in Ottava. Da hätte Alex Pop schon nach 20 Sekunden treffen können. Am Ende wird es dann aber trotzdem ein 4 zu 1. Du wurdest dann beim Stand von 2 zu 0 ausgewählt gegen Jenny Kramer. Diese Duelle mit Schweden, das war ja damals eigentlich immer so das Ding. Und wir wissen ja auch noch, dass ein ganz wichtiges noch kommen wird. War das der FFC Frankfurt im Nationalteam für dich quasi?
Voll, ja. Auf Europäischer, auf europäischem Boden und US halt auf globalem Boden, ja, Weltboden.
Hast du da noch Erinnerungen an dieses Spiel? Im Nachhinein war es ja wirklich sehr, sehr überzeugend.
An das Spiel, ich merke gerade, dass ich an die WM generell nicht ganz so viele Erinnerungen habe, außer dass Anja Mittag ihren Ring verloren hat und nicht ihn aber irgendwie wiedergefunden hat.
So eine gute Geschichte.
Ja, irgendwie so. Ich meine, das war mein erstes großes Turnier und ich weiß, dass es krass auf Kunstrasen war. Wir hatten unmittelbar über Höhe des Kunstrasenteils Temperaturen von 50 Grad. Also meine Sorge war, dass mir meine Haut unter den Füßen nicht weg brennt. Das waren so Sachen, da haben wir auch noch eine Petition unterschrieben, weil wir gesagt haben, wir haben hier WM, das höchste, größte Turnier ever, FIFA. Wieso auf Kunstrasen? Ihr würdet euch nicht ansatzweise erlauben, eine Männer-WM auf Kunstrasen spielen zu lassen. Das fang halt auch noch alles mit. Und an was ich mich halt erinnern kann, ist an das Spiel in Platz drei.
Also Viertelfinale gegen Frankreich in Montreal. Es waren eins zu eins nach Verlängerung. Den Ausgleich gab es erst eine 84. Minute durch ein Hand-Strafstoß von Celia Saazic. Das war damals so das Ding. Und dann ging es ins Elfmeterschießen. Und was ist da passiert? Es ist einfach zu wissen, denn Nadine Angerer stand im Tor.
Ja, die hat geregelt wieder.
Genau.
Das ist unfassbar.
Wirklich. Und du hast aber wieder nicht geschossen im Elfmeterschießen.
Nee, war auch wieder nicht mein Spielfeld.
Ja, aber ich finde das so interessant, weil da war es, also du warst im Nationalteam noch nicht so etabliert. Aber du warst natürlich eine völlig etablierte Spielerin. Und mein Eindruck war auch, dass du bei den Mitspielerinnen immer schon etabliert warst. Nur die Bundestrainerin hat das nicht immer so gesehen und dich nicht immer eingeladen. Und eigentlich würde es total zu dir passen, dass du sagst, ja, da war ich halt konsequenter, habe ich mir den ersten genommen, dann habe ich ihn halt reingemacht.
Also ich habe ja eine 100%-Quote beim Elfmeterschießen.
Das ist korrekt. Aber wie wir sehen, hast du auch nicht so viel teilgenommen.
Das schiebe ich noch schnell nach. Tatsächlich, ja, schön, dass du das so siehst, weil so habe ich es auch immer empfunden. Also mein Type of human bzw. player war auch dieses, okay, ich möchte oder das eine Verlässlichkeit ausstrahlen in meiner Position. Ich liebe es. Deswegen habe ich es auch geliebt, mit Maro auf der Sechs zu spielen. Einfach Maro, ich verteidige dir jeden verdammten Ball, damit du bitte alles nur offensiv machst. Und ich stehe dann einfach da und denke mir so, wie schön kann man einfach bitte Fußball spielen? So das ist dieses, okay, wie können wir gucken, dass es uns allen gut geht? Was braucht wer wie was? Und damit wusste ich natürlich auch, dass ich nicht die Spielerin bin, die jede Aktion kreiert, die die vielen Tore macht, die vielen Vorlagen macht, sondern eher, sage ich mal, so auf diese Soft-Skills zu sagen, so okay, wie positionieren wir uns? Dieses große, ganzheitliche zu sehen, so ja. Und das wurde sehr schnell immer erkannt von meinen Mitspielerinnen und auch sehr geschätzt, weil diese Verlässlichkeit einfach da war. Und dann braucht es manchmal den Weg, der ein bisschen länger ist zu der Trainerin oder zum Trainer.
Du heutzutage wärst du wieder total modern. Rollenspielerin wärst du jetzt heute.
Ja, stimmt. Ja, ja, ja. Oder oder so ein Quer-Past-Toni, hat man doch immer gesagt. Vielleicht wäre die Quer-Past-Toni.
Ja, wobei du hast schon, wenn du die Möglichkeit gesehen hast, hast du schon viel vertikal gespielt. Ja, da hattest du schon Bock drauf.
Ja, schon, ja.
Manchmal auch zu viel.
Zu langen Holz. Das war ja immer so langen Holz von außen.
Ja, ja, ich meine, wir reden ja gleich noch über das Olympia-Finale, der erste Ball, den du da lang geplant hattest.
Das war so ein Quotenball. Das hatten wir auch mit Anja und Josi immer so. Ich hatte mal einen kemschen Quotenball, wo ich dann auch selber so, was war hier jetzt gerade nicht eingestellt?
Na ja.
Das hatte ich einmal im Spiel, das hatte ich dann immer.
Also es ging ins Halbfinale nach Montreal gegen die USA. Celia Sašić verschießt einen Strafstoß.
Ja, stimmt.
In der 69. Minute gibt es dann einen unberechtigten Strafstoß. Ach, Entschuldige, das war der, wo das Foul vor dem Strafraum war. Ich habe es verwechselt. Das war das Halbfinale. Und ich spiele um Platz drei. Dadurch gehen die USA in Führung. Alex Popp erleidet eine Kopfverletzung, spielt mit Torbarn weiter. Und O'Hara macht dann letztlich das 2 zu 0. Und Sylvia Knight wechselt in diesem ganzen Spiel nur einmal. Was ich, ich weiß noch genau, dass ich das damals schon interessant war. Sie hat Marujan für Mittag gebracht, wo ich mir noch, also ich weiß noch nicht, ich meine, Sofa-Trainer und so weiter, alles klar. Aber wo ich mir damals halt noch gedacht habe, ich hätte gerne beide auf dem Platz gehabt. Aber ja, welche Erinnerung hast du an dieses 0 zu 2 gegen die USA?
Das war körperlich so eine krasse Herausforderung. Also die haben uns richtig gefordert. Und auch diese, diese Kipppunkte in diesem Spiel, die Möglichkeit, eigentlich ins 1-0-Führung zu gehen. Boah, das also, und das meine ich so, diese mentale Greatness von den Amerikanerinnen. Das war halt einfach eine höhere Liga, mit der wir nicht mithalten konnten. Das muss man schon ganz klar sagen.
Ich hatte auch den Eindruck, ich habe es jetzt nicht noch mal komplett geguckt in der Vorbereitung, aber ich habe mich an das Spiel noch so selber daran erinnert. Ich hatte damals das Gefühl, dass die in eurem Kopf drin waren.
Ja, voll. Da waren die ja wie so indoktriniert. Kennst du so Tip-Kick? Man steuert sich nicht selbst. Diese Überlegenheit und wenn du auf diesem Spielfeld bist und du merkst, dass da ist eine Resonanz, der du nicht weniger entgegenbringen kannst. Und so wie so ein Meer, so einmal.
Ja, wobei es gab so die einzelnen Momente, also hat der Vorschuss einen Strafstoß. Ich weiß noch, dass damals als Alex Pop dann weitergespielt hat. Ich meine, also damals war ich dann noch nicht so ganz so sensibel. Inzwischen ist das so Kopftreffer im Fußball total so mein Thema. Und ich sehe das grundsätzlich eher kritisch, da jemanden weiterspielen zu lassen, auch wenn ich weiß, dass das die Spielerinnen immer wollen. Aber das wäre auch so eine typisch deutsche Geschichte gewesen. Wenn dann die Turban-Spielerinnen, dann hätten sie alle wieder mit Dieter Hoeneß kommen können, wenn die das 1 zu 1 gemacht hätte. Und den Gedanken hatte ich damals auch, jetzt muss sie doch was machen.
Genau, und deswegen dieses, du merkst irgendwie, du kommst nicht ganz hinterher, du weißt, ob du kannst diesen einen Moment kreieren. Wir haben ihn kreiert und dann hat es nicht sein sollen. Und dann, das nagt an dir. Und ich glaube, das war dann auch mit dem 2-0, war es so okay.
Ja gut, das war 89.
Ja, genau, die ist so, you got it, US.
So, dann kommt das Spiel um Platz drei. Ich hatte mir auch noch was zu dem Strafstoß aufgeschrieben. Also es war gegen England, 108. Minute. Und also zumindest die Einschätzung der Presse war, zuvor soll Verteidigerin Tabea Kemme, die eingewechselte Lianne Sanderson, strafstoßwürdig gehalten haben. Also da wurde es immerhin hinterfragt. Aber für sie wäre etwas eindeutig, deswegen musste das noch sein.
Es war Ungestümtheit meinerseits. Also es war ja aus dem gegnerischen Einwurf. Und da hatte ich mich quasi schon in Stellungsspiel gehabt. Und die Gegnerin zuppelte schon an mir. Und die hat es einfach richtig schlau gemacht. Die hat sich dann so ein bisschen eingefädelt. Und ich war dann so... Ich war zu gut, glaube ich. Ja, und dann war es passiert. Und dann war es auch direkt so dieses so... Mein Verständnis auch so, ja, Natze ist ja im Tor. So erstmal keep cool, Natze ist im Tor. Und dann hat sie aber unhaltbar geschossen. Ja, und dann habe ich mir das nochmal ein bisschen vorhalten lassen dürfen.
Das war ja auch das letzte Länderspiel von Nadine Angerer, die hat dann ihre Karriere beendet. Wusstet ihr das schon vorher?
Ich glaube ja. Oh Gott.
Ja, ich war mir auch gerade nicht sicher, ob die Öffentlichkeit nicht sogar auch schon wusste. Vor dem Spielplatz.
Ja, ich glaube irgendwie war es schon, ja.
Und du hast später mal gesagt, genau über dieses Turnier, es ist interessant, dass du ans Sportliche gar nicht so viel Erinnerungen hast, aber du hast später gesagt, dass du damals zum ersten Mal dran gedacht hättest, ins Ausland zu gehen, weil, also Zitat, weil ich 2015 mein erstes Turnier mit der Nationalmannschaft gespielt habe, rumgekommen bin und dadurch immer mehr den Gedanken hatte, eben mal ins Ausland zu wechseln. Kannst du dich daran noch erinnern?
So klar nicht mehr, aber auf der anderen Seite muss ich auch schmunzeln, weil das so zu mir passt. Weil einmal so die große Welt gesehen, so gefühlt so und dann habe ich natürlich auch, habe ich Freude daran gefunden und ich wusste auch mit Studium, okay, ich mache das Studium fertig, 2017 werde ich durch sein, dann möchte ich auf jeden Fall, das wusste ich da schon, über den Fußball auf jeden Fall noch mal, die Ländergrenzen überschreiten und für einen anderen Verein spielen.
Also im Nachhinein kommt natürlich viel noch in Teil zwei, aber schon eine gewisse Ironie, dass du für dein Studium wahnsinnig viele Dinge aufgeschoben hast und dann kurz vor der Lebenszeit, vor der Beamten gesagt hast, aber es ist doch nicht.
Und das, ja ja voll. Voll Leben, ne? Und das Schöne ist immer wieder, ich würde nichts, keineswegs irgendwas dran ändern wollen, weil das in den Situationen sich immer alles so richtig und gut angefühlt hat und mir immer irgendwie ein Fundament für meine Autonomie gegeben hat.
So, jetzt kommen wir endlich in die Saison 5 zu 16. Kannst du noch?
Ja, Olympia geht immer.
Gut, danke dir. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, euch wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so wundern, aber wir überziehen mal wieder. Also Sven Jehoud kommt, Pauline Bremer wechselt und Jenny Zietz beendet ihre Karriere. Die Saison startet schon ätzend. 1 zu 3 in München. Spieltag 3, 4 und 5 geht alles verloren. 0-1 in Frankfurt. 0-2 zu Hause gegen Sand. 0-1 in Leverkusen von den ersten sechs Spielen. Gewinnt Potsdam tatsächlich nur eins. Die Was war da los Frage, die spare ich mir jetzt einfach mal.
Stark nachgelassen.
Im Viertelfinale im Pokal zu Hause gegen Wolfsburg 0-3 verloren. Und am Ende landet man auf Platz 7 mit 27 Punkten Rückstand auf den Meister Bayern. War das in der Saison. Und da wird dann auch klar, dass Bernd Schröder nach der Saison aufhört. Kannst du das, ich will jetzt nicht wieder so ins Detail gehen, damit es nicht noch eine halbe Stunde länger wird für dich, aber kannst du mal diskutieren, was war das für eine Phase damals? Wann habt ihr auch gemerkt, vielleicht hört jetzt dieses Urgestein als Trainer auf? Wie habt ihr es erfahren?
Es sind auch so zwei Seiten gewesen. Auf der einen Seite war es, haben wir auch uns gesehnt nach diesem Moment, weil wir ja auch einfach nicht mehr weitergekommen sind. Also dieses, was wir getragen haben, einfach kein Benefit daraus ziehen konnten. Und das hat uns so müde gemacht. Und es war auch dieses, wann passiert es jetzt endlich mal? So, das auf der einen Seite. Und dann auch natürlich dieses, was man ja bis dahin auch erreicht hat. Nur, das hat sich ja so entzerrt. Das war ja so ein lang anhaltender Untergang, kann man ja fast sagen. Und dann auch so dieses, ist es jetzt wieder dieses Phänomen, wenn Menschen, die so lange in etwas sind und was teilen und groß gemacht haben, dass sie nicht diesen Absprung schaffen. Das war das auch, ja. Und natürlich hatten wir uns auch, ich meine, am Ende des Tages so wünscht man das Keim, mit dem man irgendwie so viel erreicht hat. Auch so eine Vereinsikone und dann so ein Abgang. Das ist doch irgendwie, das wollen wir doch alle nicht. So, und das ist jetzt aber auch einfach selbst verschuldet.
Aber das ist auch leider nicht so untypisch für den Sport. Also die alle, alle wenigsten schaffen es quasi auf einem hoch zu gehen. Wie hast du das denn dann damals empfunden? Und wie habt ihr es dann eigentlich erfahren, dass dann Bernd Schröder aufhört?
Guck mal, allein das ist krass, dass ich das nicht mal genau weiß, spricht auch für sich. Also ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, wie die Kommunikation war. Und ich weiß nur, dass Achim Pfeiffel ja auch schon immer, Bernd Schröder hatte ja dann schon immer so ein bisschen jemanden an der Seite. Es war dann irgendwie Achim Pfeiffel, da weiß ich auch noch, da habe ich ja positionsbedingtes Spiel noch mal auf die 6 zurück. Dann hat Achim sich die Zeit genommen, hat eine dreiviertel Stunde über mit mir ein Training gemacht, wo er halt Spielsituationen auf dem ganzen Platz dargestellt hat, hat mir immer so die Bälle, wirklich richtig geiles, individuelles Training, der dann aber auch irgendwann gesagt hat, so nee, also irgendwann, also was passiert denn hier jetzt, Bernd? Das war lange nicht klar und dann hast du auch einfach gute Leute verloren. So dieses, wenn du an was festhältst und es nicht loslassen kannst und Qualität voll auch da gewesen wäre und die dann aber auch irgendwann sagen, nee, hier ist eine Grenze, ich lasse mir auch in gewisse Dinge nicht mehr reinfuschen. Und dann noch so ein bisschen das als nach wehen so. Es war schwer irgendwie dann auch immer wieder das Gute daran zu sehen, was man geschaffen hat. Es haben sich ganz viele Dinge vermischt. Ja. Und das war also was ich ja auch wieder dann so dieses okay, das sind Dinge, die kann ich nicht kontrollieren. So was. Was nehme ich daraus mit? So dieses Okay, ich möchte nicht diese Person sein, die an irgendwas so klebt und festhält und mir das ja selber irgendwie versaut.
Ja gut, ich meine, es ist natürlich auch, also wenn ich jetzt einfach versuche, dass aus Sicht von Bernd Schröder zu denken, wohin soll es gehen? Ich meine, wir wissen, wohin es dann ging. Es ging dann in eine sportliche Leitungsfunktion. Ehrlich gesagt nicht so kreativ. Es ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig kreativ, vom Trainer quasi zum sportlichen Leiter zu werden. Aber letztlich sehen wir halt, es ging eigentlich dann nirgendwo mehr so wirklich hin mit der Turbine.
Ja, und das ist, also ich meine, das habe ich im Nachgang auch bei meiner Kandidatur, die ja dann wesentlich später nochmal war, auch gemerkt. So dieses, wie selbst er da, es gibt einen Brief, den er handschriftlich verfasst hat und an alle Mitglieder geschickt hat. Den habe ich mir jetzt im Rahmen des Podcasts auch nochmal durchgelesen. Dachte mir so, alter krass, so du warst Trainer über so viele, das war ja eigentlich fast quasi mein Ziehpapa. Ich bin mit 16 da hoch so. Und dann lese ich diese, diese Worte, die du da schreibst, auch mit dem Team, mit dem ich mich aufgestellt habe. Und dann denke ich mir so, okay. Also das ist nicht den, das bist nicht du, den ich damals als Trainer hatte. So was passiert da? Was passiert mit dem Ego da gerade? Warum verletzt du mich?
Ja, weil du in deinem, in den du sprichst ja gerne von Räumen. Du bist in den Raum rein, in dem er saß und König war. Und also kurz für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die es nicht auf dem Schirm haben. 2020 bewirbst du dich. Was? 2020?
Ja, oder ja, ich glaube, 21 war das.
Genau, 21 war die Wahrheit. 20 hast du, glaube ich, bekannt gegeben eben als Präsidentin. Und hast es dann mit 100 zu 116, 110 Stimmen verloren. Entschuldigung, nicht alles falsch. Aber das werden wir dann in Teil zwei nochmal besprechen müssen. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich aber auch deshalb nicht mal so gut daran, wie das genau mit dem Abschied von Bernd Schröder war, weil es nämlich in einem anderen Feld sehr, sehr gut lief, dass 22 Spiele für Potsdam gemacht. Wie das lief, haben wir jetzt gerade schon so ein bisschen auch unter Tisch gekehrt extra. Denn im Nationalteam hast du 16 Spiele gemacht. Und weißt du nämlich, was in dieser richtig ätzenden Phase mit den drei Niederlagen gegen Frankfurt, Sand und Bayern passiert ist, in der Länderspielpause?
Nein.
Du hast richtig Angst.
Nee, nee, aber das ist so geil, weil ich das selber nicht mehr weiß. Ich finde das dann immer aufregend.
Dann es gab ein Länderspiel gegen Ungarn. 12 zu 0 habt ihr gespielt. Du wurdest beim Stand von 3 zu 0 eingewechselt. Entschuldigung, du wurdest ausgewechselt in der Halbzeit. Aber du hast, du hast das 3 zu 0 erzielt. Das war dein erstes Länderspiel-Tor.
Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Jetzt habe ich total Angst, dass die Datenbanken alle falsch sind.
Du wirst da absolut recht haben. Aber das, ich glaube, das ist mal wieder so, das ist wieder so ein kemsches Ding. Das ist so, muss krass gewesen sein, das erste Länderspiel-Geschoss-Tor.
Ich kann mich nur nicht mehr dran erinnern. Meine Frage hier, welche Bedeutung hatte das erste Tor für dich? Okay, gut.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber witzig. So Tore und so. Ich kann dir nicht mal sagen, aus welcher Spiele. Nichts kann ich dir darüber sagen. Aber läuft.
Es lief. Du warst dann auch beim Schiebel-Leafs-Cup mit dabei. Da warst du dann Einwechsespielerin vor allem, also gegen Frankreich. Da bist du für Melanie Behringer gekommen. Einmal warst du Startelf. Da wurde dann Leonie Mayer für dich eingeweckt. Und nochmal Startelf, bis dann Melanie Behringer reinkam. Also da sieht man nämlich auch, dass sich so ein bisschen deine Position verändert hat. Auch im Nationalteam. Gegen die Türkei warst du dann auswärts nicht im Kader, aber zu Hause gegen Kroatien wieder in der Startelf. Das war dann wahrscheinlich wieder so ein 23er-Kader-Ding.
Oder muskulär.
Ja, ich glaube, dass die Spiele innerhalb von ein paar Tagen waren. Deswegen war es wahrscheinlich eher, dass du bist mitgereist, aber warst in den Spieltags-Kader und deswegen tauchst du da nicht auf. Stellt sich aber die Frage, denn es gab ja dann eben das Olympische Turnier, Fußballturnier. Wie sicher warst du denn da, dabei zu sein?
Ich wusste, wenn ich in diesem Flieger sitze, wenn ich am Frankfurt Tor 13, da wurden wir immer eingebucht, eingecheckt, wenn ich bis bis dahin geschafft habe, dann weiß ich, okay, jetzt beginnt Olympia.
Aber wann, wusstest du? Also am 15. Juli hatte Sevian Knight bekannt gegeben. Sie hat Pauline Bremer, Feli Rauch, Lena Petermann und Maike Kemper zu Hause gelassen. Ein Drittel des Kaders bestand aus den Bronze-Medallengewinnerinnen von Peking. Das waren Batusiak, Kran, Laudea, Mittag, Peter und Behringer. Also sollen wir mal so, sie hatte ja schon ein gewisses Fable für die routinierten Spielerinnen.
Und ich weiß auch, dass es begründet ist dann, dass ich ein mulmiges Gefühl hatte, weil es war ja so, dass Spielerinnen nach dem letzten Lehrgang oder vorletzten Lehrgang bekannt gegeben wurden, wurde, dass sie nicht dabei sind. Und dann hieß es, dass sie, also das Phänomen dann, wenn es an deiner Tür klopft, dann sieht es nicht gut aus. Ja. Und dann, das fiese ist, wer klopft dann, ich war mit Aymut Schuld immer auf dem Zimmer, wer klopft, dann es klopft an der Tür und Aymut und ich gucken uns an, so, nee, scheiße. Bei Aymut war klar, dass sie dabei ist und so. Und wer ist dann an dieser Tür, ich glaube Josy hat geklopft oder Anja, eine von den beiden, ey. Wirklich, also haben sich noch einen Spaß draus erlaubt. Ja, aber da, er hat es da, also es kam keine an meine Tür oder an unsere Tür und somit war dann irgendwie klar, am Start. Beziehungsweise dann auch wieder, weil kann ja auch immer noch viel passieren, hab schon einiges erlebt, bei der U17 WM hat sich vor dem letzten Training, im Training vor Abflug nach Neusitland Kreuzband, also deswegen ist das alles Teil gewesen, wo ich dachte so, ich bin mir vorher nie zu sicher.
Ich habe gerade ein paar der Spielerinnen vorgelesen, die mit im Kader waren, wenn auch auf Abruf mit dabei waren, waren Lisa Weiß, Kati Hendrich, Lina Magul und Svenja Huth hat es auch geschafft. Und im Nachhinein habe ich mich gefragt, es kann jetzt auch sein, dass es jetzt viel zu kritisch ist, aber findest du es im Nachhinein richtig, dass da alles auf den Titelgewinn fokussiert wird und deswegen auch so viele 2008er-Rinnen mit dabei waren, also von Peking eben noch, oder ist es schon ein Anzeichen dafür, dass ein Umbruch verschleppt wurde, was wir jetzt natürlich im Nachhinein alle wissen, dass es passiert ist?
Hab ich in dem Moment gar nicht wahrgenommen. Also nicht ansatzweise, da war natürlich eher dieses Thema, so es sind vier Spielerinnen mit im Kader, die aber voraussichtlich keine einzige Minute spielen werden. Auch das verletzt sich jemand. Die Monalaurier hatte sich verletzt, dann wurde, glaube ich, Sven-Jahut in den Kader berufen. Das ist so okay, und dieses so krass, ja das ist Olympia und wie schaffen wir da irgendwie dieses Teamgefühl? Ihr seid eigentlich vier, seid irgendwie immer außen vor und dann doch drin. So dieses, boah, wie tragen wir das alle gemeinsam? Das war für mich zumindest eher so im Fokus. Und natürlich damit der Einkleidung und dann vor Ort dieses, also dieses klare Ziel. Ich weiß noch, Almir und ich hatten in jedem Save, hatten wir den Code von vier Zahlen, 1-9-0-8, 19.8., das war der Tag des Finals. Weil wir nur mit Aussicht, wir sind im Finale, die Aussicht hatten, dass wir ins Olympische Dorf kommen. Und Almir und ich, wir mussten in dieses Olympische Dorf. Und danach war alles ausgerichtet. Deswegen so die Art, Thema Umbruch, Kader und all sowas. Das war bei mir so zweitrangig, weil das ist ja dieses, okay, was ist der Ist-Stand, wie können wir jetzt was kreieren. So das war halt voll im Fokus und der Rest war psch.
Und dann ist ja Olympia aus verschiedenen Gründen noch mal ein bisschen weird, auch aus rein Training und Kader, weil der Kader ist ja kleiner.
Ja, 18er-Kader.
18er-Kader-Stadt. Das ist, wie hat sich das denn angefühlt? Also ihr habt dann zum Beispiel euer erstes Spiel, ihr habt noch getestet gegen Ghana, da habt ihr 12 zu 0 gewonnen, du wurdest eingewechselt in der Halbzeit, also jeder hat quasi eine Hälfte bekommen. Und dann eben Gruppenspiel gegen Simbapfel in Sao Paulo vor etwas mehr als 20.000 Fans, 6 zu 1. Simone Laudet musste schon nach 19 Minuten raus, sie wurde hart zusammengetreten, Zitat Sylvia Knight. Es gab nicht mal, nicht mal gelb von der Schiedsrichterin aus Malaysia. Und du kamst dann der 72. Minute rein für Isabel Kaszowsky, mit der du ja schon ganz am Anfang.
Ja, das schon da.
Hast du da Erinnerungen dran an dieses erste Spiel? Und wie war Olympia? Das war ja auch so vorgelagert vor den Spielen, oder? Da ging es doch auch früher los, das Fußballturnier.
Ja, doch, weil wir haben dann zusammen im Hotel die Eröffnungsfeier geguckt. Und naja, das war das Brasieren, dieses Land, dieser einzige Tanz, diese Leichtigkeit. Das hat mich beflügelt. Das war so, okay, das finde ich toll, das will ich auch. So und wir kommen halt so aus dieser rasanten Tugend, die Disziplin, dieses einheitliche Aussehen. Ja, irgendwie nicht zu viel, zu viel lachen, zu wenig lachen, zu viel reden, nicht zu, also dieses so immer austarieren, wo kann ich gerade was, in welchem Raum, wie was. Und da ist einfach nur so sein. Ja, das war echt, das war so genial da. Das war die Phase, wo ich ja auch dann ganz viel mit Anja, mit Josie so eine richtig tiefe Freundschaft sich entwickelt hat. Das war, wir sind da in den unterschiedlichsten Städten. Das war eine richtige Städtereise. Ich weiß, dass wir in El Salvador waren und wir hatten da noch ein bisschen Erwärmung. Dann hieß es so, ihr habt jetzt Zeit zur freien Verfügung. Die einen haben alle mehr oder weniger Fußball-Tennis gespielt. Ich bin da ins Meer gerannt und bin da Bodysurfen gewesen. Und die ganzen Militärer, die uns halt betreut hatten, sind da mit und haben uns dann quasi beschützt, dass wir dann wassersicher sind, Josie und ich. Das sind diese Momente, die so hängen geblieben sind. Dieses Eins-Sein auf der Reise mit den Locals im olympischen Fieber, bis hin zu wissen, ok, ich möchte in dieses olympische Dorf.
Habt ihr denn dann überhaupt irgendwas mitbekommen davon, wie in Deutschland das Turnier rezipiert wurde? Weil wir kommen jetzt gleich noch zu den einzelnen Spielen.
Nee, also das gar nicht, sondern das war wirklich, also auch bei allen anderen Turnieren, das war so, du bist vor Ort so drin. Und auch dieses Erlebnis so, dass das, was ich erlebt habe, kommt keinem Artikel in Deutschland, wird dem gerecht. Da ist, also ich glaube, das trifft auf den Punkt dieses freudige, flair olympischer Drive. So das schaffen wir nicht, irgendwie in die Worte, in die Zahlen, in die Sätze zu kreieren im deutschen Journalismus.
Spannend, denn ich habe hier zum Beispiel, also zweites Gruppenspiel gegen Australien, 37.000 Fans, frühes 01, Körr, eine 6. Minute, dann gibt es eine 45. 0 zu 2, aber Sarah Dabritz schafft es noch vor dem Halbzeitpfiff, das 1 zu 2 zu machen, das war damals ganz wichtig. Und Saskia Patusiak schießt dann in der 88. Minute das 2 zu 2. Und ich lese dir mal kurz vor, was du dann ja damals zum Glück nicht gelesen hast. Ich glaube im Spiegel stand es bei beiden Gegentreffern bestrafte Australien das zu langsame Umschaltspiel der deutschen Mannschaft, die sich für den Traum vom ersten Olympiasieg erheblich steigern muss.
Ja, also wo ich mitgehe, ist, dass wir spielerisch jetzt nicht die überzeugendste Mannschaft waren, der Spirit. Also wir haben dieses Turnier über den Spirit gewonnen.
Ich habe in Spielberichten gelesen, dass es als Überraschung galt, dass du gespielt hast. Klar, du wurdest ja auch eingeweckt zum ersten Gruppenspiel. War es für dich auch eine Überraschung? Nö, gar nicht. Eigentlich kann ich die Antwort jetzt nach unserem Gespräch schon.
Nee, irgendwie gar nicht. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum.
Dann gab es das Gruppenspiel gegen Kanada in Brasilia vor nur 8.000 Fans. Ein 1 zu 2. Du hast komplett durchgespielt, von der Startelf bis zum Ende. Nach dem 1 zu 2 in der 60. Minute, zweimal Tank greedy, hat er zweimal getroffen, ist nicht mehr wirklich viel rangekommen. Sylvia Knight hatte fünfmal die Startelf durchrotiert, aber du bist geblieben. Was dann am Ende kommentiert wurde von deutschen Medien mit fast verzockt. Die deutschen Fußballerinnen sind als Gruppenzweite denkbar knapp ins Olympia-Viertelfinale eingezogen. Mit einer B11 unterlag die Auswahl von Bundestrainerin Sylvia Knight Kanada mit 1 zu 2. Und ich lese das deswegen vor, weil ich das so krass finde, das ist ja auch mein Problem. Wir als Journalisten müssen wir Urteile fällen. Und trotzdem ist es natürlich so, das sind ja so harte Worte eigentlich, die da gewählt werden. Da werden ja einfach elf Spielerinnen, also sechs waren ja noch aus dem Spiel vorher, werden als B11 bezeichnet.
Ja, das ist brutal. Ja, und da sind wir auch, also merke ich ja jetzt selber auch in einem Wande. Ich glaube im Sinne von dieses, okay, diese Belastung auch jetzt da in Brasilien, das war ja heftigst, das hast du gar nicht mit der ersten safe 11, wenn wir jetzt davon so reden, hast du das gar nicht tragen können. Und das brauchen wir, die Belastung wird immer intensiver. Wir brauchen Spielerinnen 1 bis 18 in dem Fall. Und ja, das ist so krass, da sind wir echt immer noch so, differenzieren wir einfach viel zu hart, viel zu auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen. Und das meine ich, also ich sehe die Schwierigkeit von außen zu urteilen. Und ich bin auch mittlerweile der Verfassung dieses, okay, wir brauchen einfach mehr, zeigt euch mehr von innen, weil dann können wir es doch viel klarer auch skizzieren im Außen.
Ja, also das war damals, glaube ich, schon auch Teil des Problems. Zum einen war es so, also generell haben viele Medien schon auch einfach Lust am Scheitern.
Das ist schon heftig, ne?
Und bei Frauen noch viel mehr als bei Männern, so ehrlich muss man sein.
Und wer sind dann die, sind es eher Journalisten oder sind es Journalistinnen?
Also die Zitate, die ich hier vorgelesen habe, waren, wenn ich mich gerade nicht komplett täusche, alle von Männern.
Rahmen ist doch, oder?
Man muss allerdings auch sagen, also ich kann mich an das Turnier auch noch erinnern. Es war halt spielerisch wirklich nicht so doll.
Voll bei dir.
Aber was man halt zum Beispiel nicht gesehen hat, das ist mir jetzt erst in der Recherche dann aufgefallen, wie viel ihr neben dem Platz da eine Veränderung hattet. Also in Brasilien waren komplett andere Temperaturen als vorher in Sao Paulo. Ihr hattet die Rotation. Es war eine komplett andere Kulisse. Du spielst einmal vor 37.000, einmal vor 8.000. Und ja, klar, in einer Spielanalyse ist es schwer, das einfließen zu lassen. Aber man müsste dann, also das versuche ich jetzt, das habe ich aus dieser Recherche mitgenommen. In der Wortwahl kann man ja so viel machen. Man muss ja nicht von der B11 sprechen, sondern man kann ja davon sprechen, war ein schwieriges Spiel, war auch kein gutes Spiel, auch verdient verloren, ehrlicherweise.
Ja, und vor allem, ich finde auch, dieses war kein gutes Spiel. Das kannst du ja, ich finde, immer gut und schlecht oder richtig und falsch. Ich brauche irgendwie eine Substanz, woran das Messball ist.
Das war nicht gut.
Genau, ja, und da kommen wir ja seltenst hin zu sagen so, hey, im Aufbauspiel kamen wir halt schwer ins letzte Drittel, vor allem schon gar nicht spielerisch, sondern dann haben wir halt den langen Ball immer, immer gegeben und sind nicht in die zweiten Bälle. Dann sage ich, okay, jetzt kann ich es daran festmachen und siehe selber, war nicht gut. Aber das ist mir zu einfach zu skizzieren. Ja, war nicht gut.
Ja, das ist halt, ehrlich gesagt werde ich das nie verstehen. Der berühmte Witz, ja, die anderen wollten es mehr. Der kann ja ganz leicht ausgehebelt werden, egal wer das sagt, egal ob das Pep Guardiola oder Mario Basler sagt, die anderen wollten es mehr. Die einfache Frage ist, was wollten sie denn mehr? Und wenn dann die Antwort ist, gewinnen? Ja, nee, aber wie? Woher wollten sie das denn umsetzen? Ja, und schon bist du ja in der Diskussion, die zählt, aber man hört vorher auf.
Ja, das beschreibt den kompletten Journalismus, Deutschland, Sport.
Ich lasse es mal so stehen. Das ist nämlich was für Teil 2. Viertelfinale gegen China in Salvador vor 10.000 Fans. Trotz Überzahl, gelb-rot in der 57. Minute für eine Chinesin, gab es wenige Chancen und dann war es nur das Tanzschuss von Melanie Behringer. China hat auch noch einen Strafschuss an Pfosten geschossen.
Oh ja, das weiß ich noch, ja.
Du hast durchgespielt und ein Schuss von dir wurde noch von der Linie geklärt. Du hättest die Melanie Behringer diese Spießwerke nicht mehr sein sollen schießen können.
Ich kam der Sache bereits näher.
Eine Beobachtung aus der Presse. Sylvia Knight stand fast die gesamte erste Halbzeit am Rand ihrer Coachingzone und gab Anweisungen an ihr offensichtlich verunsichertes Team mit zunehmender Frustration, egal was die DFB-Auswahl probierte, lange Bälle, das Spiel über die Flügel, Kombinationen, nichts gelang. Und ich möchte mit dir nicht darüber sprechen, warum da nichts gelang. Ich möchte mit dir über Micromanaging von Trainerinnen sprechen.
Ich habe ein, zwei, ne, einen Trainer, wo ich aktiv was wahrgenommen habe, weil wir ein Coding hatten, was mir geholfen hat. Matthias Rudolf, Turbine Potsdam. Sonst kein einziger Trainer, keine einzige Trainerin, wo ich irgendwas während des Spiels aufgegriffen habe. Weil entweder sehe ich immer nur, was emotionales rumgefuchtelt ist, aber hören tue ich dann gar nichts.
Und es hilft dir auch nicht, wenn so gesagt wird, steht doch mal kompakter, weil du wärst selber nicht drauf gekommen, dass man kompakter stehen soll?
Nee, das kam nicht. War mal... Also, und dann war ich auch sehr schnell... Vielleicht ist es dann auch immer gekommen, aber da war ich schon längst weg. Da war ich weg im Sinne... Ja, einfach... Nee, für mich hatte ich dann sehr schnell klar, von draußen kriege ich nichts. Okay, ich fokussiere mich auf das, was ich kriege. Ich kriege von meiner Spielerin, wenn ich hinten links gespielt habe, war immer irgendwie defensiv denkende Mittelfeldspielerin, beziehungsweise vor mir und Innenverteidigerin. Sassi war das ja oft. So dieses, okay, wir managen uns. Und wenn ich mal irgendwie eine Absicherung wirklich brauchte, wenn es mir nicht gut ging, dann war Almut. Okay, dann kann ich wirklich hinten, dann stellt Almut sich so, aber von außen. Und das finde ich so krass. Ich meine, jetzt, auch wenn ich das sehe, ich beobachte, weil ich merke, wie ich selber das erlebt habe und wie wenig ich bekommen habe. Und beobachte jetzt ganz viele Trainer, eigentlich sind es fast nur Trainer, die ich beobachte, weil es einfach wenige Trainerinnen gibt. Und denke mir so, okay, also bei mir, ja, ich beobachte einfach nur, ich sage es mal so.
Ja, ich finde das so interessant, weil das letztlich ist, Trainer sein, anscheinend auch ein bisschen Schauspiel. Zumindest in der Männerbundesliga. Denn ich habe noch eigentlich keinen Spieler getroffen, der mir gesagt hat, boah, mir hat das total geholfen, dass der in der 30. Minute gesagt hat, ich soll mal mehr auf meinen Raum aufpassen. Die Spieler, und sie werden ja auch so erzogen über die NSZ und so weiter, dass sie eigentlich ja alles wissen sollten. Vielleicht werden Spieler sogar auch manchmal überfrachtet. Und dann ist das wirklich manchmal, glaube ich, so eine Art Performance. In der Bundesliga der Frauen habe ich den Eindruck, es ist noch anders, weil da hörst du, was die Trainerinnen rufen, weil einfach weniger Zuschauer da sind.
Manchmal willst du es nicht hören.
Genau. Und da fällt aber zum Beispiel auf, wie wenig positive Affirmation es da gibt. Theodoros Dedis von Hoffenheim, der hat immer gerufen, sehr gut, gut so, wenn sie sich aus dem Pressing rausgespielt haben. Und zwar nicht, sie haben sich nach vorne rausgespielt, sondern sie haben hinten rum gespielt. Den langweiligsten Pass der Welt. Aber er hat immer gesagt, ja super, sehr gut. Und das ist mir so aufgefallen, weil ich ansonsten immer nur gehört habe, nein und Shiri.
Und alleine nur, wenn wir dahin kommen, dieses, weil ich habe nicht mal mehr was drauf gegeben, wenn mir jemand gesagt hat, hast du gut gemacht. Weil ich merke es in der Situation. Ich brauche keinen oder keine, die mir noch sagt, super. Dieses nee, ich fühle es.
Ja gut, vielleicht gibt es aber auch Spielerinnen, die es brauchen.
Ja und das ist doch, ich brauche doch nicht die Anerkennung von außen, sondern ich gebe mir sie selbst, weil ich im Gefühl bin und ich merke, wenn ich den Ball spiele, alles signalisiert mir, okay das ist ein 100 Prozent gespielter Ball, weil ich voll in der Situation bin, voll im Gefühl. Und das ist reine mentale Arbeit. Und deswegen auch, wir hatten das eine Jahr dieses, von wegen Motivator, ich brauche keinen verfluchten Motivator und soll mir nicht anfangen.
Ja du nicht.
Ja aber warum braucht es meine Mitspielerin? Ich lerne es ja nicht, wenn stetig jemand mich im Außen motiviert, lerne ich es nicht mir selbst, diese intrinsische Motivation zu geben, beziehungsweise aufkommen zu lassen. Und wenn sie nicht da ist, dann muss ich mich fragen, ob das das Richtige ist, was ich hier tue. So und dann verliere ich die Freude daran, da muss ich nochmal erst überlegen, ob ich hier richtig bin. Und das ist für mich. Und deswegen ist das, das ist signifikant für mich, diese Frage, die ich mir stelle. Ich überlebe in diesem System als Trainerin, überlebe Tabea Kemme als Trainerin nicht.
Ja, aber andererseits wärst du ja wahrscheinlich eine Trainerin, die ein Vertrauen geben würde. Also Thomas Tuchel hat mal gesagt, it's a players game und er meinte damit, das ist wie eine Theateraufführung. Du gibst den Spielern alle möglichen Varianten mit und sagst ihnen, was sie tun können in den Optionen. Man sucht ja nach Lösungen. Auch ganz interessant, viele Trainer sprechen immer nur von Problemen. Rossi Bakalat zum Beispiel von Bayern spricht immer von Lösungen.
Ja, ist geil.
Wir haben die Lösung nicht gefunden. Sprache auch wirklich interessant. Und letztlich aber gibt dann Thomas Tuchel auch das Vertrauen ab und er macht sich aber selber halt damit auch kleiner. Und das ist glaube ich das, was viele gerade Männer nicht gerne haben wollen, wenn sie Trainer sind. Dann wollen sie derjenige sein, der mit der tollen Einwechslung oder mit dem tollen Matchplan es gemacht hat. Aber de facto ist es so, es gibt die Szene im Bond for this. Ich glaube, in der ersten Staffel, da spielt Lena Oberdorf in einem Vorbereitungsspiel auf der Innenverteidigerin Position. Und Martina Faust-Hecklenburg ruft bei jeder Aktion rein, was sie gut macht. Und du siehst, das stresst sie. Genau, Lena Oberdorf sagt dann auch, und es wird dann gegengeschnitten mit, dass sie, ich glaube, sie sagt, ich hoffe, ich zitiere sie nicht falsch, aber ich glaube, sie hat gesagt, sie hätte fast geheult, weil es einfach so viel war. Und ich meine, das ist eine der besten Spielerinnen dieser Generation von Nationalspielerinnen.
Ich finde, beobachte mal bei den männlichen Trainern Company und bei den Frauen, die Fritzi Krump.
Ja, stehen beide nur da.
Bringt so Freude, genau, ja, so Freude. Und mir geht das Herz auf, wenn ich sie coachen sehe, wie in einer gewissen Ruhe, Sachlichkeit, und es braucht wenige Worte. Und die Spielerinnen, das siehst du auch in der unmittelbaren Umsetzung, also Senderempfänger. Du siehst einfach im Ergebnis, okay, das kommt an, das kommt in meinem Hirn an. Okay, ich setze direkt um, weil macht Sinn. Und das hast du in den wenigsten Fällen.
Ja, allerletzte Anekdote dazu. Augsburg gewinnt in Bayern, beide Männern jetzt. Und Elvis Rexbiltzschai, die haben ja so ein interessantes Spiel, Nachballgewinn in die Tiefe. Und Elvis Rexbiltzschai verhaut einen Pass so richtig. Und du hörst richtig laut Manuel Bombier ruft, Elvis, scheiß drauf, der nächste sitzt. Und da dachte ich mir so, ja, das ist vielleicht auch der Unterschied zu Sandro Wagner. Ich weiß jetzt natürlich gar nicht.
Ich habe ja noch ein Studium gemacht beim Internationalen Fußballinstitut. Da hat mit Baum was auch super entspannt, weil der auch deep arbeitet im Sinne, so was sind die Motive der jeweiligen Spieler. Und da halt reinzugehen, so okay, was ist das Motiv? Ist offensiv denken oder defensiv? So welche Ressourcen sind da? Welche sind halt nicht da? Und welche wirst du auch nicht mehr lernen, weil die Synapse ist nicht da, die kommt auch nicht mehr. Und damit zu arbeiten, so und da, deswegen habe ich auch, also es bringt immer super Spaß mit ihm im Austausch zu gehen und auch mit seinen analytischen Sichtweisen, wie, was, auch taktisch und das ist geil. Das ist ein richtig geiles Puzzle, was er da immer zusammen steckt.
Ey, Teil 2 wird auch wieder so langweilig. Jetzt schon 1000 Anschlussfragen. Aber wir kehren zurück zum Olympischen Fußballturnier. 2016 Halbfinale gegen Kanada im Bello Horizonte vor 5600 Fans. Es wurden immer weniger bis zum Finale. Melanie Behringer verwandelt einen Strafstoß. Sarah Dabrits macht dann das 2 zu 0. Du spielst durch. Sylvia Knight verliert beim Jubel nach dem Spiel einen Ohrring.
Witzig, das wusste ich gar nicht. Den habe ich nicht gefunden. Ich habe nur an ihr ihren Ring gefunden.
5 der 12 Treffer hat inzwischen Melanie Behringer erzielt. Und was ich so interessant fand, im Nachhinein wurde berichtet, dass, weil 2014 ja die Männer 7 zu 1 Brasilien besiegt hatten, dass vorher im Training vor dem Spiel die Betreuer gepfiffen haben, um euch eine feindselige Atmosphäre zu simulieren.
Ja, das war so krass. Das hat sich über das ganze Turnier gezogen, dass wir in den Steinen ausgefiffen worden sind. Und dann haben wir das ja auch irgendwann so mitgekriegt. Das ist der Schmerz, wenn wir auch mit dem Locals, vor allem im Austausch waren, dieser Schmerz von der 7-1-Nierlage aus 2014. Das ist so groß. Wir mögen euch nicht mehr. Ja, und dann merkte man auch irgendwie so ein bisschen. Und spannend war es dann im Finale, wie man dann auch merkt und trotzdem irgendwie so ein bisschen die Herzen gewinnt. Und dann aber irgendwie so merkte man den inneren Konflikt bei den Brasilianern.
Sie haben Marujan gesehen, dachten sich, die spielt wie eine von uns.
Ja, genau. Und die U21-Männer im Finale, die Deutschen hatten ja gegen Brasilien dann verloren.
Stimmt, das war Nils Petersen, der den Elfmeter verschießt.
Ja, ich glaube ja. Und dann war auch die Seele wieder freudig der Brasilianer.
Aber das heißt, es war wirklich so, dass eure Betreuer euch ausgepfiffen haben im Training?
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich fand das auch irgendwie, fand ich das auch wieder ulkig und witzig.
Ja, das ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen lustig vor, wenn da 20 Leute pfeifen, um zu verunsichern.
Aber geschmunzelt habe ich sowohl wie da und dann auch im Stadion, wenn die Fans halt irgendwie, wenn man den Schmerz gehört hat der Brasilianer und Brasilianerin, muss ich auch ein bisschen schmunzeln.
Und wie fandst du, dass das nur nicht mal 6.000 ZuschauerInnen waren?
Das ist zum, auch bei den generellen Zahlen, die du gerade genannt hast, habe ich nur so empfunden. Weil einfach die Olympia ist noch mal was ganz Eigenes. So ob da jetzt 6.000 oder 8.000 oder 27.000, das war, das andere ist größer. Dieses, du gehst raus, bist in dem Land und das ganze Land ist irgendwie olympisch geprägt, fokussiert. Und es geht ja nicht nur um deine Sportart, sondern wir saßen dann da und haben die anderen Sportarten geguckt. Man hat sich gegenseitig supportet. Und das war viel mehr im Raum wie jetzt die Zuschauer in Zahl bei unserem Spiel.
Okay, dementsprechend wird es dich jetzt auch nicht überraschen, dass 52.000 Zuschauer beim Finale waren. Finale gegen Schweden eben Mara Kanat. Du hast in der Startelf gespielt. Jennifer Maroshan trifft mit einem super Schuss. Also wer den noch nicht gesehen hat, kann ich mir aber eigentlich nicht vorspielen, dass jemand...
Spiel, Spiel, also Spielerin des Spiels auf jeden Fall.
Genau, auch das 2 zu 0, das war dann Pfostenfreistoß, der dann von der Schwede ins eigene Tor abgefälscht wird von Linda Sembrand. Es gab allerdings, das habe ich ehrlicherweise auch wieder vergessen, in meinem Kopf war das auch so ein total souveränes Finale, aber 67. Minute fällt ja als 1 zu 2.
Ja, war nochmal knapp hinten raus.
Durch Obzplakstenius, was sind deine Erinnerungen an diesen Finaltag, an das Finale, an das Spiel?
Also persönlich bin ich heftig an meine Grenzen gekommen.
Ach ja, stimmt, das war die Halbzeitansprache.
Ja, genau, ja. Also es war, ich habe in der ersten Halbzeit schon gemerkt, so, ojojo, deine Kräfte schwinden hier aber gewaltig. Und dann hatte ich auch irgendwie so ein, zwei Pässe, wo ich mir dachte, so halleluja, was passt denn hier gerade? Ich kriege kaum einen Schritt von anderen gesetzt, habe ich, glaube ich, ziemlich früher eine gelbe Karte gekriegt. Woll einen tiefen Pass zu Anja spielen, der ging aber irgendwie, weiß nicht, quer in die andere Richtung. Und Anja dann auch nur so, reiß dich. Ich so, ja, ich komme noch nicht so ganz klar. Und in der Halbzeitpause war ich ja auch noch, da war Silvia dann so dieses, kannst du noch? Und dann war dieses so, mein Körper sagt, schreite alles, kann nicht mehr, aber ich bin so bereit. Ich kann noch, habe ich nur gesagt. Und ich war dann direkt, okay, Physio. Ich brauche Energie, Energie, habe mir da Energie reingefiffen. Schön kurzkettige Energie, hatte einen übelsten Kick. Und dann ging es in der zweiten Halbzeit halt. Aber das war wirklich wohl auch, also diese fünf Wochen, alles kam in dieser ersten Halbzeit zusammen, wo ich mich echt, das musste ich echt abschütteln. Also es war reine mentale Arbeit, da in die zweite Halbzeit wieder rauszukommen und zu sagen so, okay, das, was in der ersten Halbzeit existiert, nicht mehr, jetzt hier in die Souveränität wieder reinzukommen.
Also du hast es ja mal, ich glaube, das war die erste Folge, wo du Gast warst, damals noch mittags bei Henning, da hast du es erzählt. Da klang das ehrlich gesagt noch nicht nach einer Frage, kannst du noch, sondern nach einem ganz schönen Anpfiff, den dir Silvia nachgegeben hat. Soll ich dich jetzt rausnehmen oder kannst du noch?
Ja, genau. Sie hat mir die Option gegeben, das weiß ich noch. Ich hatte die Option und ich war so, du stehst jetzt an einem Punkt, da bin ich zu competitive. Da war so, du bist eine Olympischen Pnade. Körper, wir regeln kurz und dann...
Ja gut, aber es gibt ja unterschiedliche psychologische Profile. Es gibt ja diejenigen, die Affirmation brauchen, positive und es gibt diejenigen, da gehörst du offensichtlich mit dazu, denen man sagen muss, das war ja mal richtig scheiße, was du gespielt hast und dann wirst du so sauer, dass du das direkt selber oft bin ich dann.
Also das war ja, ob sie es jetzt gesagt hätte oder nicht, hatte keinen Unterschied gemacht, weil ich wusste das. Ich habe ja ein unmittelbares Feedback auch von von meinem Gefühl.
Dieses Okay, du bist gerade nicht von Andi am Mittag.
Ja, genau. Und ich weiß dann oder wusste an dem Moment auch, was ich brauche. Und das sind dann diese 15 Minuten waren Geschenk für mich. Diese Halbzeitpause, dieses Sammeln in die Atmung kommen, in die schnelle Energie wieder reinkommen und dann schütteln und weiter geht's. So ja, das war das konnte ich jetzt ja auch. Also teils brauche ich nur drei Atemzüge, um mich wieder zu regulieren. Da bin ich schon wieder drin.
Und jetzt ist es ja so, du hast mit Jennifer Maruchan schon damals in Neuseeland gespielt. Dann war sie aber ganz lange auch Gegenspielerin mit dem FFC. Wie ist es denn mit ihr im Team zu spielen und dann so ein Finale zu spielen?
Ja, es ist einfach eine Spielerin vom anderen Stern mit ihren Fähigkeiten, mit diesem Zauber im Sinne von Leichtigkeit. Und deswegen habe ich es auch geliebt, immer mit ihr zu spielen, weil sie mir auch so eine krasse Sicherheit gegeben hat. Also ihre Fähigkeiten, mir so eine Sicherheit im Zusammenspiel mit ihr gegeben hat. Und davon zu partizipieren, von Jenny selbst als Typmensch, als Fußballerin und vor allem vielmehr auch als Mensch neben dem Platz. Einfach diese Ruhe, das ist ein Fels in der Brandung. Und dann auch ganz klar zu wissen, was heißt das für mich. Ich liebe es, das dann auch defensiv aufzubereiten und dann dem offensiven Zauber auch manchmal einfach zuzuschauen. Das ist so eine Aufgabenverteilung und das habe ich bei ihr immer geliebt.
Wobei du bei einem der Tore relativ schnell beim Jubel mit dabei warst.
Ja, da war ich ganz schnell da. Da war ich auch immer schnell am Start.
Es war die erste Olympische Goldmedaille für den DFB. Die Männer der DDR hatten es 76 Mal in Montreal geschafft. Was mir aufgefallen ist, ich habe mir da nochmal weite Teile des Spiels angeguckt. Nach Schlusspfiff waren auch Spielerinnen wie Lina Magul, die keine Sekunde gespielt hat, weil sie war halt nur die 18 plus 1, die eben nicht reinkam, anders als Svenja Hut. Extrem gelöst und das wirkte auf mich. Da hat ein Team gemeinsam gefeiert. Jetzt habe ich aber neulich im neuen Buch von Ronald Reng über Thomas Hitzesberger, also es geht über die WM 2006, und er erzählt, wie Thomas Hitzesberger selbst in den Momenten, in denen das Team sich gefreut hat, das Gefühl hatte, immer einsamer und isolierter zu werden, weil er eben keine Einsatzminuten bekommen hat. Das für mich sah das so aus, also ich habe das auch zeitgleich, weil es konsumiert ist. Das Buch vormittags gelesen, nachmittags diese Szene gesehen, dachte mir so, das sieht hier irgendwie anders aus.
Ja, ich glaube einfach, dass was wir auch da in der Zeit geschafft haben, also der Fußball war das eine und dann haben wir aber ganz viele Momente kreiert, abseits des Fußballs und dann halt auch immer gemeinsam. Und ich meine, es waren ja vier Spielerinnen, die ja dann teils auch Spielerinnen-Ersatztraining zu viert gemacht haben und extra ihre Läufe teils von den Vereinen auch bekommen haben, weil sie ja ja das und dann ihre quasi Saisonvorbereitung schon gemacht haben. Also da vermischte sich ja so viel und dann auch einfach die, die die Rolle so krass angenommen haben und auch wenn es Momente waren. Weil das ist ja echt, du bist ja in Situationen ausgesetzt, du bist irgendwie nicht Teil und dann bist du es doch. Und wie zelebrierst du? Aber eigentlich mache ich gerade Vereinstraining. Also es vermischt sich ja so viel. Und das haben wir echt immer irgendwie über auch tiefe Gespräche. Das habe ich auch mal geschätzt. Das schätze ich auch oder das ist auch das, was ich am meisten vermisse. Einfach so die die schönen Ebenen, die man mit Mitspielerinnen auch kreiert. Themen abseits des Fußballerinnen-Daseins. Und das haben wir echt, echt schön, schön gemacht. Wir waren ja auch, ich weiß gar nicht wann es, später war das dann auch, dann sind wir auch teils zusammen in Urlaub. Und also man hat einfach viel miteinander auch geteilt.
War das der Höhepunkt deiner Karriere?
Ja, voll. Also Olympia, das dann am Ende des Tages, die Olympische Goldmedaille, warum kommt meine Family war vor Ort. Die sind ja auch mitgereist. Und auch Brasilien, das, also Olympia ist halt so viel, also hat so eine hohe Bedeutung in meinem Leben, in meinem Verständnis zum Sport.
Dieses Multisportive, ich habe im Olympischen Dorf auf den Fünfkämpfer mit Patrick Dogg, mit dem habe ich zusammen in der Chaos-WG geleistet. So ein Scharnis-Kraft, eine Diskusswerferin, wir haben uns zusammen im Münchendorf getroffen. So das war, Familie war da, so. Das war schon, das war echt ein besonderer Moment und dann ja die Abschlusszeremonie auch zu erleben, im Deutschen Haus das abzureißen mit den Hockeyspielerinnen, mit einer Seglerin aus Kiel in Gesprächen gewesen. Das sind ja eine Begegnungsstätte, die Olympischen Spiele, die erlebst du so nie im Einzelwettkämpfen wie in einem WM oder EM.
Es ist das perfekte Schlusswort, Tabea. Ich habe brutal überzogen. Es tut mir wirklich leid. Ich hoffe, es war auch wirklich okay für dich.
Ich habe, glaube ich, ah, jetzt gucke ich auf die Uhr und denke mir so stark. Aber es hat sich und das finde ich das Schöne, also lieben Dank dir, weil es hat sich nicht so lange angefühlt, wie die Zeit mir es gerade sagt, wie spät es ist.
Das freut mich sehr. Danke dir und ich freue mich jetzt schon auf Teil 2 mit dir. Danke dir.
Danke auch. Tschüss.
Tschüss. Das war mein Gespräch mit Tabea Kemme. Und möglich machen solche Sendung mit. Ihr habt ja vermutlich gemerkt, wirklich einer sehr ausführlichen Recherche. Ja, möglichst. Vielleicht macht ihr das da draußen, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert durch komplett freiwillige Überweisungen. Und wenn ihr euch fragt, wie kann ich den Rasenfunk unterstützen, das ist wirklich einfach in der Podcast-Beschreibung, der Videobeschreibung oder natürlich auf rasenfunk.de. Da findet ihr alle Informationen. Wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de seid, einfach auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken und dann kann man uns auch auf allen Wegen relativ schnell per Dauerauftrag oder per Einmalüberweisung Geld zukommen lassen. Und davon finanzieren wir alles, was wir hier tun. Also alle fünf Formate des Rasenfunks, unsere Spieltagssendungen, aber eben auch Gespräche wie dieses hier. Und wir zahlen auch unseren Gästen ein Honorar. Auch das ist von euch finanziert. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass das möglich ist und vielleicht auch dann eben so was hier leichter ermöglicht. Ich glaube, mit einem Werbepartner wäre es schwierig gewesen, dass das Thema so eskalieren zu lassen, sage ich jetzt mal. Von der Länge her nicht so gut für den Algorithmus. Also empfehlt sehr gerne diese Folge auch weiter. Ich danke sehr für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich möchte mich auch noch mal ausdrücklich nicht nur bei Tabea Kemme bedanken, sondern auch beim St. Pauli Museum. Diejenigen, die uns bei YouTube jetzt gesehen haben, die haben die Kulisse gesehen. Wirklich fantastisch, was uns da ermöglicht wurde, inklusive die Arbeiten an der zwei Tage später startenden Ausstellung. Die wurden unterbrochen für diese Sendung und wie ihr mitbekommen habt, wurden sie ja dann für ein paar Stunden unterbrochen. Also vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Das ist alles andere als selbstverständlich und hat uns aber ein schönes Setting ermöglicht und ist eben auch Teil dieses Gesprächs gewesen. Deswegen ganz herzlichen Dank an den FC St. Pauli und sein Museum. Und dann danke ich natürlich auch einigen von euch. In dieser Folge sind das Olaf, Adrian, SVW, Stefan, Ruki, Hoffmann, Steffen, Tobi, V und Brille. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt in der Vergangenheit, sondern sich auch als Supportende registriert. Und so konnte ich Ihnen hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip danken. Empfehle diese Sendung weiter, wenn ihr Feedback habt. Sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Das ist sowieso ein Forum, wo es sich vielleicht für den einen oder anderen und die ein oder andere von euch lohnt, mal reinzuschauen. Denn da kann man ein bisschen anders über Fußball sprechen als an vielen anderen Orten des Internets, sage ich jetzt mal. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich hoffe, ihr bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen. Bleibt oder werdet gesund. Bis bald. Ciao.